Good morning.
Seeing that board members are now present, Brooks, will you please call the roll to establish
a quorum?
Good morning.
President Darling-Hammond.
Here.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Here.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Here.
Member Olken.
Vice President Williams.
Here.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Morning.
Here.
Member Porter.
Member Rodriguez.
Here.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Good morning.
Here.
We have a quorum.
Everyone's present and accounted for.
Terrific.
I hereby call the September 20, 2021 roll to establish a quorum.
We have a quorum.
Everyone's present and accounted for.
Terrific.
I hereby call the September 20, 2022 meeting of the State Board of Education to order at
8.33 a.m. and I'd like to commence by saluting the flag.
Member Olken, will you please lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance?
Absolutely.
Please stand.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the republic for
which it stands, one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
Thank you very much.
And I'm happy to announce that we have two new board members of this meeting.
Allison Yoshimoto-Towry and Naomi Porter.
And as a first step, it's time for them to take the oath of office.
So we'll start with Allison and I will read and you can follow my lead.
Allison, please begin by raising your right hand and repeating after me.
I, Allison Yoshimoto-Towry, do solemnly swear.
That I will support and defend the Constitution of the United States.
Against all enemies, foreign and domestic.
That I will bear true faith and allegiance to the Constitution of the United States.
of the State of California, and the Constitution of the State of California, that I take this
obligation freely without any mental reservation or purpose of evasion, that I take this obligation
freely without any mental reservation or purpose of evasion, and that I will well and faithfully
discharge the duties, and that that I will well and faithfully discharge the duties upon which
I am about to enter. Upon which I'm about to enter. Thank you so much, Allison, welcome. Thank you so
much. And Naomi, now it's time to administer your oath. Please raise your right hand and repeat
after me. I, Naomi Porter. I, Naomi Porter. Do solemnly swear. Do solemnly swear. That I will
support and defend the Constitution of the United States. That I will support and defend the
Constitution of the United States. Against all enemies, foreign and domestic. Against all enemies,
foreign and domestic. That I will bear true faith and allegiance to the Constitution of the United
States. That I will bear true faith and allegiance to the Constitution of the United States. And the
Constitution of the State of California. And the Constitution of the State of California. That I
take this obligation freely. That I take this obligation freely. Without any mental reservation
or purpose of evasion without any mental reservation or purpose of evasion and that I will well and
faithfully discharge the duties and that I will well and faithfully discharge the duties upon
which I am about to enter upon which I'm about to enter thank you Naomi and welcome thank you
we'd love to give you an opportunity each of you to say a few words
Allison would you like to begin thank you so much I just wanted to say how honored I am
to have the opportunity to be with you all today and to serve on the state board
in reflection my great-grandparents arrived to this country about over 100 years ago
speaking no English and you know being multilingual learners and without a high
school education and yet they were very wise so I believe that our communities have many assets
to bring and really the journey of our students and families are so important but also in doing
so the journeys of our educators and our school leaders and as someone who began as a teacher's
assistant you know fostering that pipeline and opportunities for for folks and really just the
entire ecosystem in the state of California to make collective impact so thank you again for
the opportunity terrific wonderful to have you Naomi would you like to say a few words
yes so thank you so much President Darling-Hammond and to my fellow board members it's
really an honor to be here with all of you today and I do look forward to our work together
throughout my term so for those of you who don't know me my name is Naomi Porter and I am a senior
from Palos Verdes Peninsula High School in Los Angeles so all of us here this morning we really
have one thing in common we have a vested interest in the success of California students
and we want them to have endless opportunities available to them we believe in the importance
of supporting each other and putting kids first we want our schools to be a safe and welcoming
environment for all students and I wouldn't be where I am today without my teachers who unlocked
my lifelong love for learning and who really cultivated my commitment to civic stewardship
and so to the countless teachers and administrators in our schools thank you
for your commitment to continue to lead with integrity to my fellow students watching this
thank you for trusting me with this responsibility my job is to listen to you and to learn from you
and student voice is truly so crucial to the decisions made in Sacramento because we are the
ones who live with the policies that are passed and so to my fellow students there really is no
better time than now to have your voice heard I invite you to connect with me and other members
of the board as well as I urge you to get involved in state and local task forces and committees
where your voice and perspective is so needed and so whether it's voicing your opinion at
your local school board meeting or joining an advocacy group there are really many ways to
influence our education system and lastly to my fellow board members I really do look forward to
working with all of you throughout my term to ensure that we continue to set center student
needs at the forefront of our work so thank you terrific wonderful to have you
and with that we'll start into our very busy day with some general announcements the proposed
waiver consent items are w1 through w9 the proposed regular consent items are items five
through eight there's one public hearing on the agenda that is item 12 the appeal of the denial
of a petition for the establishment of a classroom-based charter school pursuant to
california education code section 47605 k2 consideration of the allegations of abuse of
discretion made by myacomis charter middle school which was denied by the nappa valley
unified school district and the nappa county board of education we have a couple of changes
in the agenda we'll be taking up item four ahead of item three and then we will reopen item one
state board of education priorities later this afternoon to take action on the july 2022 minutes
and to take up state board liaison reports in terms of public input members of the public
wishing to call in for public comment should view the live stream of the meeting to know at what time
public comment will occur for each item public comment may be provided by dialing the phone
number entering a participant access code and then following each of the operator's prompts
upon dialing in callers will be added to a caller queue the operator will notify callers when it is
their turn to provide public comment we'll also ask callers to please turn down the speaker volume
of their computers if they're following a live webcast to avoid an echoing effect public comment
is limited to one minute for each speaker item 10 is the general public comment item during which
members of the public may provide comment on matters that are not specifically listed on the
board's agenda board members please mute your microphones when not speaking and keep your
cameras on at all times except during the breaks to ensure that we maintain a quorum throughout
today's virtual meeting and for each item on the agenda there will be an opportunity for board
members to raise their zoom hand if they would like to ask a question or make a comment we'll
start with item one item one is our state board projects and priorities item and i'm looking to
see if our state superintendent is here i believe he is to give his report
state superintendent
actually linda i believe the state superintendent hasn't quite joined and so
okay and the magic words superintendent darman's with us all right perfect
we're looking forward to his report
apology superintendent i believe it's still on mute
thank you uh good morning president darling hammond and members of the board
i'm happy to greet you uh in here in september let me first welcome our new student board member
name reporter we look forward to the contributions that we know that you will be sharing and
congratulations on your appointment and also to board member alison yoshimoto
tauri thank you for your incredible work and also for the work that you provided in addition
to other members of the board including our state board president and and many others who
have supported and dr escapado who have supported the work of our task force on reading by third
grade and helping to improve literacy and by literacy in the state and we're excited to work
with you in your new capacity and grateful to have you here on the board as i come to you i want
to acknowledge that many of our school communities are continuing to be impacted by fire our emergency
team has been busy working with many of our school communities and i want to thank the emergency team
for all the work that they've been doing by my count there are 11 active fires in the state of
california this means that some 20 schools have been closed due to the conditions and that's
impacting more than 5700 students in our state and so i ask that you continue to support our
schools who are trying to manage all forms of challenge from wildfire to heat and other
challenges and again our hearts go out to those who've lost their lives due to the hamet fire
and we continue to support those who've lost a school or a home our team has been busy sending
resources to help with food and water and housing support to those who've been impacted in many of
our communities so as our schools continue to do the incredible work they do to help our school year
get underway we just want to acknowledge the many challenges that our schools have faced whether
it's fire whether it's heat conditions whether it's a cyber attack our schools continue to
find ways to support california students to make sure that they're in a position to learn
and to avail themselves for the many resources that have been provided for a universal preschool
for expanded learning for universal meals all the things that our schools are doing right now
to support student achievement and to help address some of the learning gaps that have been
exacerbated during the pandemic i'd like to also acknowledge that september is the month where we
recognize suicide prevention awareness and that we like to just acknowledge how difficult the
pandemic has been for the entire world feeling the toronto that they do and to remind folks in
our state that last month we officially launched a new text line and call line that can be helpful
to anyone who's experiencing crisis and just a reminder to a student or a staff member a parent
just to remind you that you can simply call or text 9 8 8 to get support 24 hours seven days a
week from trained counselors who are available to support you and to help you as the board members
know we've been working hard on this issue of expanding mental health supports very proud of
our work that we've done through legislation this past year and now in the budget to secure funding
to help us recruit 10 000 new mental health clinicians over the next several years and so
that is an effort that we will be engaged in and we have been engaged in and recruitment of staff
teachers and classified staff and counselors so that we can continue to try support our schools
as they work through staffing issues we invite the board members to join us and some of our
efforts we are working on a number of projects related to dealing with declining enrollment
dealing with student and staff support issues we'll be putting on a webinar that talks about
how we support our school staff as we as we should be doing we're always talking about
how we meet the needs of our students but we should also talk about the ways to meet the needs
of the staff who are supporting our students so look forward to some updates about our future
webinar on that note let me just thank all those who are working in our schools for your resilience
and for making this a great start of a school year with high expectations and hopeful expectations
for a better year than we've had and for great opportunities going forward just want to acknowledge
as always our students and family members for their resilience our teachers and classified staff
and our administrators we invite you to stay tuned for what will be the first of many parent
conversations that we'll be hosting this year we will be hosting a back-to-school parent town hall
statewide town hall on september the 28th we'll also be hosting a statewide zoom to promote new
money in the state budget for schools to provide financial literacy to our students
and so we invite you to participate with us and we'll make sure that you receive information about
these upcoming events the last thing i'd like to share is a welcome to our new director of state
schools who is not new to our work or new to our state schools and i'm coming to you today from
a great state school and our school for the deaf in riverside i want to acknowledge our
school for the deaf in fremont our school for blind students also in fremont but nancy he blocked them on
oh i think maybe we're frozen
in
questions madam president from you or any of the members of the board
thank you so much you know you froze for just a moment for us as you were announcing the new
person who's taking on that role would you like to go back to that point and
and complete your remarks so that we can hear them all thank you yes nancy he blocked him on
is taking on the role as a director of state special schools many of you know her she served
for many years and served well as the superintendent of the california school for the deaf here in
riverside terrific thank you so much it's great to see you it's wonderful that you're there
i'd like to hear more about that building on the superintendent's remarks i want to congratulate
our teachers principals staff and families for a wonderfully welcoming start of the school this
year i know that months of planning go into successful fall openings and i want to thank
everyone who worked so hard to get our schools ready and welcome back students in the continuing
number of unexpected challenges that we continue to face in the state this year took more planning
than previous years because school teams were working to launch initiatives like universal
meals and expanded after school and learning recovery programs and later school start times
and expanded transitional kindergarten and in some parts of the state you know community school
planning and a variety of other things that are being done for our students that hard work will
definitely pay off throughout the year and in the years to come as we have fewer hungry and sleepy
children in our classrooms and more young learners ready for kindergarten and more personalized
supports and enrichment for learning for all students and we know that this causes all of our
members of our education community to go above and beyond you know the routines and we really
appreciate it all children must have the opportunity to access learning and free meals and mental health
supports as superintendent thurman mentioned medical attention social emotional and wellness
programs all of these services set the stage for academic improvements expanded tutoring along with
literacy and math supports take advantage of that readiness so all of these are investments in
learning and i'm also grateful to our educators and families that worked hard to mitigate the
impacts of last week's awful weather events so that students could continue to learn despite the
searing heat as we all saw and as superintendent has noted the west faced unprecedented heat over
five straight days california so temperatures and range has never experienced before and we may
continue to experience these kinds of events and in anticipation of the heat dome staff from
several agencies came together including public health including the department of education
including the state board to create and push out guidance for schools to help them make safety
decisions about sports and other strenuous outside activities and that guidance was very well received
it is not hyperbole to say that it may have saved lives and it's a testament to our joint team's
hard work that they were able to do that so quickly and to respond to the school's needs and as you
know the heat event was unfortunately accompanied by fires which generated smoke and the two have
combined to lead to school closures we are all hoping that these fires are brought under control
as soon as possible and this is all related to how the climate is changing climate change is
happening faster and is affecting more people around the globe much sooner than many people
had anticipated as educators we need to ensure that students are receiving instruction and
curriculum aligned with the next generation science standards which include learning about
climate change how it can be addressed by changing human behavior last year the state took an important
step in ensuring that teachers have curriculum aligned with the standards when it provided
six million dollars in funding to the san matteo county office of education to develop open access
climate change and environmental justice curricula for all grades we hope people will reach out and
tap and use those curricula across the state and this year the budget signed by governor newsome
includes 85 million dollars to create pre-k through 12 educator resources and professional
learning to implement the stem standards including those that include environmental learning the
budget also included 1.5 million dollars over three years to support greening school fleets
through programs that will be operated by the california air resources board and the california
energy commission commission and 500 million dollars to support the development of pathway
programs for high school students focused on technology including green technology
and computer science and engineering as well as education and our need for teachers so
we're addressing the climate needs rapidly you probably know that the state of california has
also set goals for all vehicles to be electric within a relatively short period of time but we
have a lot to do we have a lot to do in our schools and we have a lot to do in our state
to ensure that these events that we're experiencing do not become even more exacerbated
these programs of course are predicated on developing local partnerships that bring together
school systems higher education institutions employers other relevant community stakeholders
we hope all of you will be thinking about how to leverage greater climate awareness and action
in your local communities another critical area for action this coming year is the need to continue
to expand our efforts for more equitable opportunities to learn and greater supports
for improvement as we all know the effects of the pandemic have made it clear that schools must
address the needs of the whole child and under understand education to be more than just drilling
for test scores california was the first state to move beyond no child left behind's narrow
framework which really was mostly about testing and punishing schools that didn't achieve certain
targets we had the first multiple measures dashboard and actually our work here led to
much of what was in the elementary in the essa every student succeeds act that replaced
no child left behind and we'll be expanding that work to be sure that we're attending to the
critical elements of educational opportunity that were rising up for public attention the
kinds of resources and opportunities that students need to learn and that we're making those
investments as we have been over the last couple of years in all of the elements of educational
support that children need the u.s department of education opened the door for a broader engagement
with opportunity to learn indicators for states in their accountability systems in the communication
that they put out in february encouraging states to expand and rethink their systems this week they
also messaged something we've been saying for a long time that these systems should be used to
invest in improvement not for punitive purposes we'll be talking more about our next steps in
today's meeting and in the months to come and you'll see in the first items on the agenda
a discussion of where we may want to be leaning in on our own ways of looking at opportunities
to learn i was privileged to be part of a group of a bipartisan group of state leaders who
have been by the aspen institute to look at this question and to see if there are common
um principles that could guide the work that we do to rethink and redesign what assessment
and accountability can look like in the country and there were nine principles that emerged from
that conversation which are principles that we are already engaged in in acting in various ways
but we will be returning to i think as we deepen our work the first is that all students deserve
the opportunity to develop their character talents and interests while receiving supports
to address individual learning needs we've been doing a lot to really think about how we need to
personalize and individualize learning supports for students we have new centers across the state
providing professional development for learning acceleration for that purpose the second principle
is that all students deserve opportunities to prepare them to succeed in the future of work
and we've been developing new pathways programs we have a college and career ready index that
encourages schools to be thinking about how students get access to those opportunities
principle three that all students deserve opportunities that prepare them to fully
to participate in american democracy we began the work to think about a civic engagement
a seal of civic engagement that work will be picked up again this year and we'll be furthering
our conversations about how to be sure that we're enabling young people to engage civically in
productive ways fourth that all students deserve safe and healthy environments that are conducive
to academic learning we'll be talking more about the efforts that we've made and may make more
deeply in measuring and supporting positive school climates in which all students are identity safe
and included and feeling a sense of belonging the fifth is that all students deserve access
to caring adults with expertise in creating quality learning environments and experiences
we've done a lot of work at the state level around strengthening the educator workforce
addressing shortages creating a more diverse teacher workforce and the superintendents had a
task force on that which emerged with a variety of very helpful recommendations that can help us
continue to deepen that work all students in number six deserve instruction and tasks that
are worthy of their efforts aligned to state standards and relevant to the skills they succeed
in life we'll be continuing to talk about ways to enable our assessment systems to like the kinds
of tasks worth teaching so that students are getting work that is worthy of their effort
seven is that states establish essential policy context in enabling conditions
regarding all students opportunities to learn and that really is what our efforts in the both
dashboards that highlight for us where we are on opportunities to learn and investments that seek
to enact more productive opportunities have been going and will continue to go
eighth that schools and public education systems need partnerships with other public agencies and
service providers to adequately understand and address student needs opportunities and outcomes
you'll be hearing more about the work that we are doing in collaboration with the department
of public health and with health and human services around connecting the mental health
provision that superintendent thurman spoke about to the ways in which schools operate in much deeper
and more integrated ways and of course our community schools initiative seeks to create
and tend those partnerships there's a lot to do to break down the silos that exist and finally the
state should strategically collect and use data to illuminate the extent to which schools are
providing all students with opportunities to learn when you hear from cindy kazanis in a little while
and the staff from the accountability division will be taking up that question and it will be
part of our work in the year to come so with that i just want to also note that we also heard
yesterday from our governor about the executive order directing state agencies and departments
to take additional actor actions to embed equity analysis and considerations and their mission
policies and practices this action will help expand opportunity for all by addressing disparities
for historically underserved and marginalized communities addressing unequal circumstances
that help drive equal outcomes so that all californians have the chance to reach their
full potential and lead healthy and rewarding lives and all california communities can thrive
and prosper under this order state agencies and departments are directed to embed policies and
practices and their strategic plans in order to further advance equity and opportunity and
address disparities in access and outcomes and as part of these efforts agencies and departments
will incorporate more inclusive public engagement and data analysis the executive order also
establishes the state's first racial equity commission the commission developed with senator
dr richard pan and the racial equity organizations that sponsored sb17 will produce a racial equity
framework consisting of resources and tools to promote racial equity to recommend tools
methodologies and opportunities and be available to provide direct assistance to state agencies so
this is an important moment moment in the history of the state of california as we've been making
both investments and are seeking a framework that really creates the california for all
that we have been working toward and then in a more more operational level i'll just conclude
by saying that we do have several advisory openings with applications due on september
23rd for those who want to join into this work we are looking for qualified educators for the
instructional quality commission and for a student iqc member we also have openings on the advisory
commission on charter schools and the california practitioners advisory group and while we are so
excited to welcome naomi today and look forward to her year with us we are already accepting
applications for next year's student board member and those applications are due on october 7th
and all of those opportunities are on our website so with that i conclude our first item
and we will move on to item two
item two is the update on the implementation of the integrated local state and federal
accountability and continuous improvement system and we will get we'll have some recommendations
that will be presented about particular measures in the accountability system but as i foreshadowed
we'll also be talking about the shape of the system and the commitments that we want to be making
around how we develop and use our dashboard in the future this will be presented by cindy
kazanis of the department and cindy please begin thank you very much and welcome to our our newest
board members i'm cindy kazanis i'm the director of the analysis measurement and accountability
reporting division for the california department of education and what that means is we are
responsible for making sure that we're in compliance with state and federal law related
to accountability and all the data reporting for our k-12 students for the state of california
comes out of my division this is going to be a bit of a long presentation so we may actually
go through the 11 o'clock hour depending on interest in in the topics and board member
discussion and public comment but i am going to be joined today by a couple of guest speakers so
i wanted to let you know it's not just going to be me speaking today we will pause after each topic
i'll defer back to president darlene hammon if you have questions clarifying questions or feedback
she will lead that piece of the conversation so just as far as logistics for the item we won't
take everything all at once there will be opportunity at the very end though for public
comments so to get started we are covering five different topics today the first you're going
to hear about the california school dashboard principles that are proposed attachment two we
will cover the english learner student group and our academic indicator attachment three we
are going to be talking about changes for differentiated assistance eligibility criteria
for this coming school year this current school year rather and then attachments four and five
are really the other pieces of your action item which are proposals to place links on the dashboard
to make sure that the public is aware of two very important pieces of data information about our
teacher assignment monitoring outcomes data as well as information about our science assessments
and specifically the item recommendation the action today before you is that the
california department of education is seeking approval to first use the lowest status level
as a proxy for red as reported on the 2022 dashboard to determine county offices of
education and districts eligible for differentiated assistance the second to include a link on the
dashboard to the teacher assignment data that is supported through data quest and then finally
number three to include a link on the dashboard to the science results that is supported through the
cast website so we're going to get started today with attachment one the california school
dashboard principles and specifically um for those of you none of you were around in 2015
in your current role so uh and i was actually not even in my role and i moved into the role in 2016
but we were definitely watching the board and the development around the implementation of the local
control funding formula and specifically the board had a very stated purpose to put together
a new accountability system and in order to develop that process they they used a set of
principles that actually was developed in part in cooperation with west ed to frame conversations
and decisions when developing the accountability system which was a multi-year process as you heard
back in july from from our very long presentation and so thinking about that the work that was done
back in 2015 there was interest from from board from the board to look at how we can
improve upon those components and so what you see today is a set of principles based on the 2015
frame but we want to make sure that they are meeting the needs of the board and so we are
bringing this forward for information for a conversation and then potentially for adoption
in november of 2022 and really the the purpose of the principles is to support um we we have a lot
of decisions that will be coming before you in 2023 and beyond and so thinking about how these may
contribute to your decision making moving forward at least can serve as guardrails that can serve as
a framework as we make additions to our dashboard whether it be our state or local
indicators or something entirely outside of those two pieces of information
so this i wanted to make sure that you were aware the california practitioners advisory group
which advises you on title one issues met in august of 2022 they had a very robust conversation
about the principles and we actually got some very good feedback from the public as well during
that meeting and specifically the feedback that they provided and i want to make sure i say this
specifically they don't take votes on any items they simply are a consensus group they they talk
about things and provide advice but there is no official vote that is ever taken at that meeting
but specifically their feedback were that the principles were useful to understand the
development the background of the dashboard especially as we think about again those future
changes that are coming down the road and also that the dashboard and its principles it should
be considered an integral and useful tool for continuous improvement so we're not um you know
wedded to everything being the same all the time we need to make sure that we can um roll with with
the changes as we've seen with our covid years and not not able to be able to produce a dashboard
we've seen that with legislation that's come before us as well it actually prohibits us from
reporting out on certain information during the last two years but also that the dashboard
shouldn't be thought of as a compliance-based tool but the value to parents and teachers and
school boards is that it provides some information that is actionable and then finally there is
definitely a strong contingent in the field that wants to see the dashboard expanded to include
science assessments and graduation profiles came up a couple of times as well
so we are incorporating we will incorporate this feedback depending on again the conversation today
to a final set of dashboard principles that would be brought for action in November so your next
meeting and with that let me just get us started with a little bit of a framing for those of you
haven't been on the dashboard recently i think it's always helpful to start with really why do
we have a dashboard what is its purpose and this is found on the home page of the dashboard so the
california school dashboard's purpose is to provide parents and educators with meaningful
information on school and district progress so they can participate in decisions to improve
student learning and with that frame in mind i am going to turn it over to my colleague who
is actually a former california department of education employee but is now a long-standing
probably two-decade region 15 comprehensive center staff person eric crane who's graciously
agreed to help us with this piece of the presentation welcome
thank you director kazanis president darling hammon vice president glover woods and members of the
board i'm eric crane and today i'm representing the region 15 comprehensive center at wested
the comprehensive center we have comprehensive in our name and that is because we provide a
wide range of services to state education agencies the intent is that we support the states with
capacity building and with a focus on evidence-based programs practices and interventions
that support what's going on at the state office and in local school districts
so it's with that that i address you today
just to set some context we at the comprehensive center we we receive kind of outreach we have
ongoing conversation about the accountability issues in in the states we serve and we in
speaking with california there was discussion about the history and the context with accountability
there had been some turnover and key positions at the cde team and of course there is a
a semi-regular cycle of turnover in the state board which you all are well acquainted with
and because of that turnover some of the key history about the california system
you know deserves to be kind of elevated and spot and spotlighted and so the department reached out
to the comp center to facilitate conversation and kind of document well what what really are those
bedrock dashboard principles and what you've got in front of you today is is that conversation
the request in part was informed by a very successful enumeration of principles back in
2017 when the department and board were thinking about the development of a growth model identifying
i think it was six key principles back then really did help frame the work set set guidelines to the
work and so the department asked the comprehensive center to provide content expertise to facilitate
conversation about the principles with cde leadership to present this information in
in front of groups such as the technical design group and the california practitioners advisory
group to take the lead in documenting the discussion and revising the principles and
to present to to you to this board and so as director kazan has said today we come with
information with the intent that there would be action at the november meeting
let me just say one more thing before we get into it in my work at wested i'm
privileged to do a lot of work with the state accountability systems and that includes
a convening that we do a community of practice with state staff specifically about state
accountability systems we launched that a couple of years ago and already we've had 90 distinct
educators and staff from various seas and i think our running count of seas that have participated
in at least one meeting is 37 or 38 so it's a really interesting conversation
they get peer-to-peer support and get to bring problems of practice and so it it's helped me
with something of a national perspective on state accountability systems one thing i'll say on that
is that while many states describe their systems the adoption of principles is something that you
really you really don't see so once again california is placing themselves in the in the
forefront of you know of thinking about best practice around accountability so with that i
want to go into the principles one by one dashboard principle one is that the system focuses on
elements that express the state's priorities for well-rounded well-supported education and make
space for what's valued locally so you know this the latest incarnation of the dashboard was heavily
informed by the lcff priorities i want to make sure that we have that distinction clear we're
talking about dashboard principles today and not the lcff priorities but this broad set of indicators
that's highlighting key aspects of school and student performance
as well as making space for local indicators principle one principle two the system promotes
equity through focus on student group opportunities and performance so the calling out and reporting
of progress of 13 different student groups as long as that student group has at least 11 students
has been a part of the dashboard and each of the indicators that are in the dashboard have an equity
report that talks it that further talks about the performance of the student groups
principle three gives equal weight to each indicator so california has experience with
boiling down all of the different indicators with various weightings to a single one number summary
of school and district performance we've been down that road and we know what that gained for
us what its positives were but we also know that that very reduction to a single number
brought with it some negative unintended consequences and so at the time that california
moved to the dashboard system this idea of replacing a single one number summary with
colors for each indicators was a way to foster more discussion about the indicators and really
a key part of accountability is the conversations the data informed data based conversations
about performance that can result and so this spotlighting of colors and elevating all
indicators does get us away from that there there are some folks that want to see a single one
number summary of performance but california system gives equal weight to indicators by
reporting results separately and in a non-summitive manner and i'll just say again while we're while
we're on this one i'll say that probably no aspect of the california system in my experience
gets as much interest from other states as this one you know they you know the questions have the
form what you don't you don't boil it down to a single a single number or you don't you know wait
to kind of add it all up to a single score for schools how does how does that work so i think
this is an aspect that many states are intrigued by and is is something that separates california
from the pack principles principle four is this concept of separating performance and growth
the the way that colors are arrived at is a combination of status current year
and change difference from prior year
principle five the system reports transparently and comprehensively at the state district school
and student group levels so in the accountability conversation it's so important to be able to
adjust your lens of analysis and to be able to look at these different levels
and california has made a commitment to that by reporting at all the different levels
so long as they're the student group has at least 11 students
principle six that the system promotes effective visualization clear communication and thorough
documentation so you know by the time that the department reports out on performance there's a
lot of background work that's happened to ensure that there are effective visualizations the number
of discussions that that i've been in while nowhere near the the full number but the number
about how to present the information cards gauges color this has been a very well thought out
process with a lot of conversation about what communicates well what's accessible what helps
drive the performance and accountability conversation forward and in addition to all that about
presentation of course the technical aspects of the system have long been well defined and
and available on the department's website and accessibility and translating into the top languages
spoken by california families principle seven that the system reflects technical quality through
measures that are valid and reliable certainly validity and reliability is something that is
mentioned called out by the u.s department of education and talking about state systems of
accountability and the the department through through all the work that it that it does looking
at indicators looking at how indicators are defined looking at how cuts between categories
are set that the the technical properties of indicators and of the system as a whole
receive a thorough treatment and consideration
principle eight that the dashboard system leverages the expertise and perspectives of a broad set of
educational partners and community members so i'd mentioned that part of the ask for me was to
present this information before groups such as the technical design group and cpag
besides those groups the the chance to connect with with other experts thinkers about how the
system will play and perform in the field is you know a key a key principle so the psychometrics
the school leaders the you know the the various players who interact parents advocates that
interact with the the dashboard system is something that is taken seriously and that the system
is built upon principle nine that the system promotes coherence between data reporting
and support and improvement programs the idea you know a key idea of the accountability system
is that it needs to you know seamlessly knit up with support and improvement processes
the l cap the system of support and you know i think this board along with the department you
know in the periodic review of the system is you know is making sure that that continues to happen
that everything coheres well and speaking of continuous improvement principle 10
that the system is subject to continuous revision and improvement so you all annually review the
system to make sure that it is performing as designed and you know this last sentence i think
deserves a mention and that is that when new data become available that is valued and important and
you know valid and ready to go into the system the board you know evaluates and you know eventually
would adopt and include into the system and i think that's you know that's kind of at the
at the core of of accountability is you know defining and deciding what matters asking the
question do we have good information on what matters do we have standard information across
the state that we can include what matters and if something doesn't exist currently what can we set
in motion to develop that indicator develop that information so that it can it can enter the system
so continuous improvement with that those are that's my presentation and i'll turn it back
to director kazanis thank you
thank you eric and with that i'd like to turn it to president darling hammon to ask or have a conversation
do you want us to just ask clarifying questions at this point or can we take this up more broadly
clarifying questions and we can take it up more broadly i'm hearing
because this is just an information item right it's a disinformation correct
so um as you can see the the dashboard in california and you've got some glimpses of
this from the discussion was really a pioneering effort at the time that it was created um and
it's wonderful to revisit the principles this is something we want your input on
further and if we want to be thinking about the implications of these principles for our future
work we don't have to treat all of that today but we can begin to get the wheels turning around that
as well so with that said let me find room to get my participant list up there are there questions
or comments from members of the board
i know it's a lot to process
all right i'm not seeing any comments at this point cindy so i know as you go along in the
presentation there will be other things that link back to this so we will keep this in mind as
we're proceeding i think cynthia had a comment oh okay sorry i didn't see your hand go up cynthia
please um thank you and um i just wanted to um again emphasize the level of conversations that
have taken place around the dashboard principles and just how important they are as we consider
um future actions along that idea of continuous improvement and revision for the dashboard so
really again appreciate all of the comments that have been made in formal meetings as well as
comments we've received outside of those meetings and in correspondence and look forward to how we
will anchor our decisions to these principles for future uh actions thank you terrific thank you so
much um and you've got a glimpse of the fact that um these these are um
were groundbreaking at the time uh and continue to be in the way that states have operated um
and they and that the way in which we think about what is measured and presented and part of the
process of local conversations and um planning and problem solving is really important to what gets
done in local communities um yes member arrozco conzalas um yes this is a definitely a continuous
conversation that we have for our students when it comes to the english language subgroup um i
think about often when i look at these um the dashboard of how we can revisit the english
language definition uh for the academic indicator and how we can maybe separate some of the
information in the dashboard for for instance to illustrate the english learner data and just to
have maybe a better illustrative um model for to report the e.l.o.s and the rfps separately that's
actually on our agenda for deep uh inquiry and just a little bit so that's great you are
foreshadowing our future work member rodriguez thank you i'm i just want to say that i'm excited
to see science um be talked about in these in the dashboards and i'd also like to echo
member arrozco's comments regarding the what we're going to be talking about in a little bit
terrific and i actually i see kenji hakuta on the screen hi kenji he's going to be
part of that conversation um member yoshimoto tari hi um i i first just wanted to say i'm very
complimentary of the fact that we have principles i think guiding principles are anchors that um
really provide a good foundation for the dashboard as a whole um and i and i look
for i know when you member today i look forward before the november meeting i'd like to get a
little bit more information on um principle three not today necessarily but just about
um sort of the the tensions right between or the the opportunities between having a single
indicate single indicators with equal weights uh versus um perhaps a more uh complex uh system
that looks at a balance of different indicators so i just want to become more knowledgeable about
that um and then i would um particularly because of principle six right which talks about ease of
of understanding and then for principle two um have we ever given any thought to identifying
and calling out specifically closing opportunity or performance gaps over time and i just commend
again the board for having an equity focus i think that was the underlying consideration and
concern around having progress indicators right you may recall back in the nclb era
it was status indicators only and very little attention to progress that was being made for
both the overall ends and for groups within that and so that has been an intention um you know for
the way that we have approached it but we can certainly when cindy when you come back on if
you want to add any uh data points to this conversation we'd be glad to hear them
member louis i think i saw your hand go up and just to remind folks that if you want to you
can go into reactions on your zoom keyboard at the bottom and you'll be able to raise your hand
there also and then i will see it on my little grid but i saw your hand go up thank you president
darling heaven i'm having difficulty finding my little hand so thank you
i get it but i too would like to echo my fellow board member on wanting a little bit more
information about adding the phrase because i saw that in the correspondence that we received about
closing opportunities and performance gaps over time the implications of that and maybe adding
that to principle number two and then a little more information i know our presenter talked a
little bit about why there's no single score for schools and giving equal weight to each indicator
i'd like a little bit more information as we go into making a decision in november about
uh the possibility of of giving uh weight between the state and the federal uh indicators
just a little what the impact of that might be i'm not sure what you're asking about state and
federal but before we do that before we get to that um member louis i'd love for us to go ask
cindy to put the slide back on principle two which you wrote so that everybody's following
and if you could make again the point that you were wanting to make about principle two
okay and there was a lot in the uh in the correspondence i think it's more about
uh transparency and one of what one of the board members also mentioned about um um
um closing the achievement gap and they were more concerned about the english learners
and the transparency of the the uh differentiation between english learners and our fits i believe
if i remember there was a lot of correspondence a lot of them echoing the same thing and i know
we've talked about that a little bit before but just adding uh the the line closing opportunities
and performance so that i think the intent is to make sure that uh schools and districts are really
focusing in on uh basically the division between english uh elos and rfx i think that's where the
the the attention is that you're making one is the question about english learners which we are
going to go to okay that's soon uh the other is around which i think i'm i heard as well from
member yoshimoto torii was that you may want to be explicit about closing gaps in the language
of this principle so i think that's a good piece of concrete advice that i wanted to be sure that we
hold up um and then you had a second point and i'm sorry i wanted to get the first one nailed
before we went on to the other point that you were making member louis i think the other one was just
giving equal weight to each indicator just a little bit more background on that yeah
a little walk down history lane for for those of you um are younger and uh may not recall but back
in the 1990s i guess it would have been in early 2000s we had an api system which did give every
school number and you were a six or you were an eight or you were and it was highly correlated
about 0.9 correlation between the number that you got and the socioeconomic needs of your student
population and it was really just based on the test score and the status of the the level of
the score so there was not a lot of encouragement in that system for people to pay attention to
progress for people to get credit for the investments they were making in student gains
for students with greater needs there was not a lot of attention to the level of need of students
there was not a lot of attention to the other needs of students beyond academic achievement or
to their opportunities to learn so if you ended up being a six or an eight or two or whatever it was
there wasn't a lot of information either to guide uh what um what you did there were concerns as
well about things like school exclusion zero tolerance suspension rates failure to pay
attention to the other needs of students which really was the genesis of the conversation that
occurred in the state and took fruition in the board that preceded us under governor brown and
board president michael kirst and the folks who were there to expand attention to the broader
needs of students the legislature also put in place with with the local control funding formula
eight state priorities because they were getting so much feedback about negative feedback about
the system that we had and the eight state priorities were the things that they wanted to
be sure people paid attention to including resources for learning and the williams lawsuit
was taking place around that time noting that a lot of schools we had very unequal school funding
system a lot of schools didn't have basic textbooks didn't have you know clean buildings didn't have
qualified teachers etc so those were part of the those fundamentals were part of the eight
priorities having a rich curriculum that was not just about um you know drilling for for state
test scores and not getting science not getting social studies etc having um pathways to college
and career so all the things in the eight state priorities many of which are reflected well which
are reflected in one way or another in our dashboard came about through that process and
that was kind of in reaction to the single number approach it was a i would say a widely shared
a set of conversations across all the branches of government and among the advocacy groups who were
very very involved in trying to be sure that the state would pay attention both to the inequities
and the opportunities to learn and to the other elements of the student experience
in addition to the scores so just just a little walk down the history road of history on that
i see member oaken's hand is up i don't see president i just want to say i thank you for
that and i did live through that period and i certainly don't want to go back to a punitive
point where we are just looking at test scores because the overall system of paying attention to
all of the the various indicators to make sure that we're taking care of the whole student and
all the student needs is is certainly where we want to be so thank you for that thank you
thanks for raising those questions and those good points um member oaken yeah thank you um i just
want to start by expressing my appreciation for these dashboard principles um i i said
i think it was in our last state board meeting that in my in my in my experience back in the 90s
and early 2000s i always thought of accountability the long four letter word um it felt so
punitive and single-minded and i thought it pushed us to a vision of what's the purpose of schools
is that um was not inclusive enough in any way about what our job is and i really appreciate
that um our accountability system has changed and that this set of principles helps us understand
what we're trying to capture on the dashboard um as we what's there now and what how that might
when we make changes to it what those changes are prioritizing um and with that i just want to
say that um the principle that stands out to me um is the first one um because it really um
articulates by referencing the state priorities um that are really broad in the types of things
we're trying to accomplish on our schools on behalf of our students and by referencing those
and also referencing that um there's still space for what is value locally
there's really um a commitment to the whole child to what is important in the local context
um and to being responsive to students needs um in ways that are based in what we're seeing in
our schools um and my only comment or thought on that is um i and i could be wrong but i think
it's that priority is the only place where the state priorities are referenced and um
the state priorities are truly so important in helping schools focus on the whole child
and all sorts of ways that we can support young people um and their growth and
and so i wonder if there's a way to even further call out in that principle
in that principle
the if there's a way to further call out in that principle in that guiding principle
what those priorities are trying to do um in a way that
it's really helps move us away from a punitive approach to schools and a very single-minded focus
on test scores and that type of understanding the quality of schools
so um are you proposing a any i think you're making a general point about the principle
not necessarily proposing specific additional language but i want to be sure i'm understanding
i so i think in in some i think to me that's the only principle if i am correct that actually
mentions the state priorities and perhaps it's something in that principle or even in the
dashboard principle i mean dashboard purpose perhaps that say something about the purpose
of the state priorities yeah and yeah i get it done yeah thank you i think that's a good
point because you know when that was all being done you know creating the state priorities and
so on there were a number of very important purposes which was to both to hold the state
accountable not just local schools and districts but for the state to have data that would drive
continuous improvement and investment on our end and you can see how that's been unfolding
over these last number of years as well as to point through opportunities to learn to point
to the nature of the curriculum and opportunities that students should have the variety of outcomes
that we care about including graduation including you know being on college and career pathways that
are productive etc etc so there were a set of purposes for those priorities and the purpose
that they would inform the l cap the continuous improvement
element that had was being invented at that time and that's again another thing that celford is
very unique in having i talked to folks across the country in state policy positions and they
often say well what do you once you've got your accountability system how do you get people to
pay attention to the data we actually have a mechanism by which the community looks
at the data and the data that we use and the data that we use and the data that we use
and the data that we use and the data that we use i think i froze i think i might have frozen for
a moment did i did i yeah okay i'm sorry i have bad internet i'm gonna go to another place in my
house where i have better internet um but but the point was simply that um the uh ways in which we
come back around on l cap and how that functions with community engagement and with the right kinds
of data so anyway what i think that would be something useful to figure out a way to add a
little bit of any other comments i believe member patilla brownson thank you i was in motion trying
to get to another room
um so i i also wanted to express um appreciation for both the presentation as well as um so much
of what has gone for into these principles um i think principle one um lifting up the importance
of well-rounded and well supported um is is unique and i think um something for us to be proud of
uh and also principle two's uh focus on equity which you know was not quite 10 years ago but close
um during a period before i think the word um became fashionable um and so frequently
circulated as it is now um so it's something i i'm really delighted that california has been at the
history it has had a history of being at the vanguard um of focusing on this um i also
appreciate that there's a focus on continuous improvement of the system and effective communication
um as the state evolves and leans more deeply into this um so my question really is about
the history of the equity provision in uh principle two and as to whether there was any past
discussion previously um not just sort of naming equity as a value um and sort of a um
noun with a level of stillness as opposed to a verb with a level of focus on closing opportunity
and achievement gaps um and that that precedes my time on the board and just hoping someone can
comment on that i think there's been a lot of conversation about that but these principles
the statement of principles for the dashboard is brand new so it's just been developed uh with
the help of the comprehensive center and i think i'm i'm going to turn off my video i hope that's
not a violation of our quorum rules but i my bandwidth is really bad right now so i can't
talk and be seen at the same time can you hear me okay yeah okay um so yes i think it's that's been
in the conversation i think we can add it to this statement of the principle which just evolved
in the last you know few months of work with the department and the comprehensive center and the
cpg so i think we will make that explicit great thank you any other um comments at this point
for those of you who have your seal on the left side of your screen it's sometimes hard to see
your hand go up so i apologize for that okay cindy this has been a great conversation let's
go ahead and proceed great we will move on to the next piece which uh is covering attachment to the
academic indicator for specifically around the english learner student group this was a
conversation that the board asked us to bring to you um back as a result of our conversation in july
and so this is for information purposes today and specifically um a little bit of of history
i think we're going to do a lot of history today which is which is always great to know
why we're grounded in um in prior decisions that have been made and so just to orient you to
the english learner student group and of course it being a core
uh group of of our 13 student groups we are required under the every student succeeds act
and the local control funding formula to measure english learner progress towards english proficiency
those are key components of both state and federal law federal law under essa allows states
specifically allowed states to include students who are reclassified as fluent english proficient
or rfip in the english learner student group for up to four years within the academic indicator
and specifically um to meet those requirements not only under state but federal law the el
student group um is reported out as a student group in every single state indicator uh it's
further should be noted that the english sort of student group is the only student group
and the one indicator which is its own the english learner progress indicator
so the board uh took action on this decision uh over five years ago in january of 2017
and specifically uh based on technical work that was done by the department as well as
policy considerations uh that came from national experts and you're going to hear from one today
the board approved the inclusion of current english learners in the definition and english
learners have been reclassified for four years or less and this action is specific to the academic
indicator so we look at graduation rate we look at suspension if we look at chronic that will only
see current english learners this is the only one again under essa that we were allowed to deviate
under and so the conversation today is around um you know why is that in essa to begin with what
is the history behind the inclusion of our febs and then we will show you some current data
from the student group and hopefully that will inform the conversation
so to get us started i'm going to turn it over to a very esteemed um a researcher in this area
kenji hakuta from stanford university who has graciously agreed to join us this morning and
prepared some slides to walk us through this conversation
dr hakuta the floor is yours thank you and uh members of the board uh board president
linda darling hammond great to see you and uh thank you for this opportunity to um to uh have
this conversation and provide some of the the the historical uh background i realize that
in in policy you know the devil is often in the detail and you're obviously having to consider
a lot of that uh but it's also important to think about how the details
and the decisions that lead to that really fit within kind of the larger larger policy picture
and the history and and so forth and i'm really here to to share with you some of uh the the big
picture uh so that you can kind of use that as ways of thinking about about the the the detail
that you need to deal with and especially this issue of uh the boundaries around english learners
and how the group is uh is defined and uh and uh how it's interpreted and most importantly how
it's used in communication uh to the stakeholders as well as the back to the policy community i
think is is really important uh the i was i i joined uh part of that the earlier discussion and
those those various dashboard guiding principles seem an incredibly important way to uh you know
to think about the the the communication of uh of how schools and uh systems are uh supporting
and contributing to improvement in in uh in our student learning uh and and and well-being and
i think the california is i'm so proud to be a californian uh in a state where uh much of that
is uh is uh we're really on the on the cutting edge of of that um the uh before i get the the
big picture i wanted to just share with you as a researcher uh the kinds of considerations from
research and this next slide here uh that uh that i've kind of struggled with and and others have
you know my my my vast network of of great colleagues who work in this uh in the research
on bilingual uh students uh where where that kind of comes out and the the four that i i wanted to
highlight here and that have led to i think the way in which uh california has framed uh uh english
learners uh is really the first is an asset orientation we've never we we've often not been
there uh in the in the in the policy world uh but is recognizing uh the the assets that uh english
learners bring through their native language uh the uh you know being a speaker of native
speaker of spanish uh is not something to be explicitly erased by the system
in favor of the learning of the second language and there is uh considerable research now
fortunately that that support uh the the the advantages that that native language
provide uh to those students who become bilingual uh the second kind of consideration
is really a better understanding of the time frame for the development of english language
proficiency to reclassification uh those of you who were involved with uh the bilingual education
debate of the 60s and 70s they're probably not that is the 1960s and 1970s and that may not be
many of you um may remember that uh the early title seven which is now title three programs
in esea called the bilingual education act had lots of uh efforts to limit the time frame
during which uh of of programs of being made available to students
um i remember a conversation i had with senator uh claymore and pell of Rhode Island
back in the the 80s uh in which i i uh after a testimony we had a little side conversation
uh where uh where he sort of said professor you know i was very intimidated by the situation here
but as a as a young uh assistant professor from Yale and uh he's a professor how long
do you think it takes children to learn english and i sort of you know at that time we didn't have
a whole lot of data but basically i hemmed and hawed and said well you know something like
you know five six years and he said i disagree it should be six months and um and that was and he
was actually behind a proposal um to limit uh participation in title seven funded programs to
six months that did not come to law but there were you know kind of voices around that and uh
sort of a better understanding of that that that the development of english language proficiency
to full bilingualism uh is really something that takes a long period a much longer period of time
than policy uh allows and um uh and and policy has often violated that understanding uh those of you
who remember proposition 227 uh which uh was passed by many uh californian uh voters uh called
for a time frame of one year for a period of special programs immersion programs for kids
to learn english so anyway that's the second uh consideration the third is really the relationship
between english language proficiency and academic progress fortunately there's a lot better
understanding now that you know really one of the drivers of academic progress is progress in
english language proficiency and especially in english language proficiency that is
related to academic learning and and we've made a lot of progress in aligning
the kinds of language that is english language proficiency that's measured in our our assessment
systems uh to um essentially academic language academic uses of language over more conversational
and and sort of things senator pelle bless his heart what he was basing his six months
view was uh when he took his kids to europe you know he'd see his kids playing with their french
friends uh almost instantly right they were able to communicate in some form and that was the kind
of language that that he he had in mind uh the the fourth um is is really just gets to
kind of the heart of the the issues is uh you know kind of uh an understanding of the consequences
of uh the inclusion or exclusion or how you include and consider uh former english learners
those who have become successfully bilingual in the english learner subgroup and and uh and there's
clearly a a relationship there as well um but before i kind of get into a little bit more of
the weeds there um let me just sort of um give you a little bit of the historical background here
and uh in 1987 i was recruited from uh yale university to the university of california system
through the uh and i kind of uh flew over to stanford and went to university california at
santa cruz uh to join the education department there with uh my a good colleague of mine
or several of them uh eugene garcia and uh and barry mclaughlin and and uc uh and this was back
in 1987 and the university of california had a a program called the language minority research
project which eventually expanded to become called the uc lmri language minority research institute
and that was in recognition of the the growing numbers of uh english learners and so forth
but at the same time i was i was really kind of uh intimidated by coming to an environment
in california uh those who were here during that time uh in the uh in the 80s
california was defined by these kinds of things that are in this uh this slide here
um uh the the bilingual wars when secretary of education benet under reagan came in to dismantle
the u.s department of education he chose the bilingual education act as the thing to attack
and that was kind of that version of culture wars uh in those days uh california had passed
proposition 63 the english only initiative um overwhelmingly uh and and uh supported by
senator hayakawa uh governor wilson uh at that time uh uh pushed the initiative proposition 187
and there were conversations about letting california which was
one uh among the first states to have state bilingual laws uh sunsetted uh the the law
and uh so that was kind of the the the environment and in that context of the culture wars for these
kinds of programs um the the uh essentially they were uh english learners were were outside of
accountability they were just sort of in a program that could be attacked through culture wars and
uh and so the battle was was really to somehow include them in the larger mixture so the next
slide will show kind of some graphics from uh the the battle over uh inclusion and i would say that
the the stand the the beginnings of standards-based reform which began with the the
the the uh goals 2000 uh and the improving america schools act
under uh under clinton was kind of the the first beginnings when people started talking about
having standards and what does it mean to include english learners in those uh the the standards
efforts and so forth the national academies uh of sciences issued a report improving schooling
for language minority uh children which looked at the still the sparse research in this area
and tried to kind of gather the sort of basically advocate for the need for greater research around
the broad array of issues uh in that for english learners that would uh inform uh the the standards
based uh efforts um and of course that you know resulted in no child left behind uh that uh you
know during this period uh california developed the eld standards but that was during that period
around the the the um the the reading wars um and uh those standards were aligned to very much
the efforts around e.l.a uh standards of of those days uh and then uh of course the the bilingual
sort of and the cultural wars around bilingual education continued uh we we felt like the
inclusion efforts might uh might help uh sort of beat back and put behind us the the culture
rewards of bilingual education but prop 227 came along and that that sort of uh caused some uh
regression and then the next slide uh is sort of inclusion effort too which i think uh one can
inscribe uh credit uh the common core uh and what the common core did which uh really
amplified and helped us articulate uh the language uh needs of uh of of all students but especially
english learners uh around uh the the sorts of academic uses of of language in learning
and that was very very helpful in creating the the framework the council of chief
ccsso issued a kind of a framework for thinking about english language proficiency
in the context of academic learning by students the california independently developed the
e.l.d standards too which is still the the standards that are used uh for for lpac uh and
and those were much more academically uh focused uh for for students and um and that was really uh
a real uh kind of uh strength of of what we accomplished then uh essa came along
um and then you know for specific to english learners uh we reversed uh 227 through prop 58
the edge initiative uh and then that kind of laid the the frame the groundwork for the california
el roadmap and that's um i think that was actually around the roadmap was the last time i was in
front of the board uh speaking and and so uh anyway this kind of gives you a broad picture
of what um where um you know essa came along there were state plans that were developed
and so forth um and uh and i'll kind of come back to the conversations around
sort of uh the the these kinds of big ideas uh uh helping us think through how uh state plans
might include english learners so the next slide this will be a quick set of slides just to say
you know the question of how long does it take uh kids to learn um this is a slide that i put this
in here i was the author of this uh this slide uh but it was a 2000 uh analysis that um was very
much a back of the envelope uh analysis but it kind of looked at district data showing that
uh the amount of time it takes for kids to the the red graph shows uh kids up to uh uh growth in oral
english uh in a this is a very different kind of assessment that i won't get into
but uh the oral english and then re-designation as it was called then is the blue line uh so it
takes uh you know roughly up to up to sixth grade basically for kids who start out in kindergarten
in a high-performing school district uh to to to take uh to attain proficiency the next slide
shows a much more refined analysis by karen thompson who looked at data from a large
this is from la unified of how long it takes kids to attain proficiency
in in this case this was in in selt as well as to reclassification
um but it also was important because it showed some of the drivers of the the the path towards
reclassification so it it's basically dependent what these different color lines are are kids
who begin with different levels of initial uh initial proficiency so if you start with
at level one even by after eight years you're still at about 75 probability of reclassification
whereas if you start at um you know at a higher level like the gold line you're going to get to
that a comparable point after about four years so anyway these are the kinds of of understandings
of the time course as well as as the drivers of reclassification um these are things that take
time and just to show you and share with you the value in a big picture sort of way the next slide
is um is uh basically the the it's really a comparison between looking at english only
i'm sorry kids who are current english learners versus kids who are uh have at some point
been english learners so they include in current english learners but also include
reclassified english learners and this is an analysis by michael keifer and karen thompson
uh looking at nape and this is national data on on on math fourth grade math and reading
you get similar results for seventh grade or eighth grade and um and what it shows is
what they're saying is that they concluded from this analysis that the multilingual students
which are the english learner plus the the reclassified students have improved two to
three times as much as monolingual student scores narrowing the gap by 24 to 39 percent
from one third to one half of the grade level over time and this is the kind of of of important
improvements in performance unfortunately that doesn't get picked up by the press as much as it
should you know the press will pick up that negative stories and the negative stories are
really that the english learner uh evidence which is that bottom line is if you look at
the current english learners uh you know the the trend is flat right so this is really the
again this is not accountability this is just the nation's report card but these are the kinds of
of uh differences that you'll see in it you know whether you get to see improvement or not
in the system by looking at data that considered just current english learners
that exclude kids who have been reclassified versus kids who you know looking at the category
the entire category of kids and that is not to say that the you know that the data at the bottom
of that slide the the the flat lines are made up no those are indeed the true english learners
uh current english learners but that's almost by definition uh you know they're doing poorly
because english language proficiency is the driver of or the main driver of english uh of academic
progress the next slide will give you a demonstration these are the kinds of considerations
that went into the debate that happened in towards essa around whether to include english
reclassified english learners or not and this is data from a district in the publication it's
it's identified as sanger from from sanger unified which shows their their students improvement
um and if you look at the the the graph on the the left um it's the the the dotted line the dash
lines on the top is for all students in the district um and uh it shows what what we it was
widely recognized as sanger going from a very underperforming school to sort of at or above
the state average over those years between 2004 and 2009 and then the on the bottom is
really that comparison between english only i'm i'm sorry that the current english learners
versus if you can consider the english learner plus the reclassified students and what that graph
gives you is the sanger's data is the dark uh the dark line uh and uh the statewide data is the
the gray bar the gray line and uh what it shows is that the um uh the the english
if you consider just the english learners on the left uh it's you know you kind of get them up to
the state average and it doesn't show you know then it sort of flattens out
whereas what on the right bar what you see is the the sort of uh the the reclassified and the the
current el students uh start below the state and then after 2006 go and exceed the state average
so that's the kind of of system performance for the students who have ever been uh considered
english learners that kind of get masked if you look just at the the english learner data
that's not to say that you should not look at the english learner the current english learner data
but you want to be able to look at this kind of system uh system improvement the final next graph
here and then i'll stop showing graph but this graph here um is just another plug for keeping a
long-term uh vision uh for uh for english learners and this is um you know it's it's really the the
best argument uh for uh the value of bilingual education programs uh and this is a district in
which the california district i don't know if i can mention it or not so i won't uh but it's uh
it's it's long-term data on kids who are in either english immersion programs
transitional bilingual education programs uh that you know replace english for the native language
a maintenance-oriented program that maintains the native language and then the dual immersion
program which is a program that includes participation of native english speakers as
a goal of bilingual uh bilingualism for for all students and what this shows is that if you look
just at the first uh grades up until middle school uh what you would conclude from there and this is
on um on uh on reclassification of the english learners who participate in these performance
programs kids who are in english immersion programs and transitional programs will outperform
the students who are in the bilingual or maintenance programs if you look though over the years and by
by middle school and high school the maintenance and the dual immersion programs overtake
the students who have been in the english immersion bilingual and transitional programs
so again you know how you conclude what you conclude about the value of the program really
has to do with just think about it as being kind of the window size of the the lifespan of the
development of an english learner student all right so uh next slide here this will get to more
the points that that led to the decisions about um about inclusion of of reclassified students
delia pompa from migration policy institute and pete goldsmith from cal state northridge
and myself were uh were recruited by the council of chief state school officers to
to essentially provide guidance advice kind of facilitation of states to um to
look at and consider it as they develop their state accountability systems we wrote some papers
which i know california used um we were like ping pong balls bouncing from state capital state
capital we visited between us i think 48 of the of the state capitals and talked to the teams and
so forth and to me it was a real um real dream come true in the sense that uh the conversations
that every state of course states varied but they were actually having conversations about english
language learners and how they would be included in their state accountability systems uh because
well because they had to but but they were having conversations and and and and what we really tried
to um encourage the states to do and we did this by uh by doing simulated data simulations and so
forth um and showing what the effects of of these considerations are uh is i'll mention the last
point the last bullet here is is that you know state context matters but you really should look
at your own data you should examine what's going on in your state as you create your your uh your
plan and uh and and really use that to guide your decisions and some of the things that you'll
discover in as you do that are what are the drivers of uh english language proficiency
development uh what's the growth model that makes sense in your state context what's your
theory of action for english learners uh choose a model that enables you to include as many schools
with english learners while maintaining the stability of the model so the end size question
comes up here quite a bit um this is especially true in uh in states where you have very small
english learn compared to california relative to the state uh relative to california but even
within california would be true for districts that have you know smaller uh numbers of english
learners so end size and so forth but we really encouraged uh looking at the data the next slide
uh shows for example you know if you looked at the the uh the uh academic performance as a function
of english language development level you'll see that that driver here the six on the far right
six is for reclassified students and you'll see that actually that that the you know the reclassified
students exceed the state average uh for um for uh english language arts and so forth um the next slide
well this is a bit of a looking at bats hanging off ceiling kind of graph it really should be
the other way around but my my friend pete who produced this this graph is um is uh thinks
of things differently uh and and it's sort of uh but anyway what what this shows
and and we demonstrated this and encouraged states to look at their own data and so forth
but in in our simulated data what we showed was for example that uh depending on your end size
whether you choose end size of 10 or 20 or 30 or 40 you're going to have different uh percent
of schools that are held accountable this would be true true for districts as well but
here i have schools um and uh and and so obviously if you have a large end size you're going to have
fewer schools that are held accountable uh so you want to have smaller end sizes but then you've got
all these other sort of confidentiality considerations and so forth so you know those
are important issues as well and then the different colors within each of those different
end sizes shows what would happen if you looked at current oh you know only the current english
learners versus if you included reclassified students for one year two years three years
or all the way up to you know to four years and um and that the percentage of schools that would
be held accountable would would vary and so that's you know i mean it's it's a logical
thing from the data but but we felt it was really important for states to think about that
but even more importantly think about what are the consequences of of making these decisions
uh in terms of you know is the is the is it is it important to uh look for uh percentage of of
schools that are held accountable is that an important consideration is is um you know that
the uh uh you know should you consider the needs of english learners
only as long as they're current english learners or not that's a state decision uh it's it's your
decision uh and uh and and it's it's uh how do the stakeholders feel about that
those are important uh considerations now having ping-pongs around the states uh there's current
analysis that's going on and where states states have have gone on this i'll give you the next
slide here as kind of a concluding uh point here what we know is that uh you know that that a lot
of states this is uh data from the migration policy institute um uh pompa and viegas are the
authors of this report uh in sugarman i think um that that the dark purple of the states that
went with uh inclusion of up to four years uh the next version is two years uh there were some some
that are not you know not clear and the gray are the ones that are that are um uh not don't include
reclassified students so there's there's variation there's current efforts to understand if there are
consequences of one or another it's going to provide a very very complicated uh story i'm sure
because states vary in so many different ways um but um but i wanted to kind of give you that
context as well on where california is uh what where california uh kind of uh uh uh
sort of does uh or what what california does sorry my grammar is falling apart these days
um what california does uh is really uh important nationally people look you know
obviously people look to california uh as as the the leading state unfortunately they look to us
for prop 227 um but but where uh what we do really matters and so that's why it's important to me
even as a sort of as a california resident for sure but as a as a state leader the the uh it's
the decisions are important but even more importantly i think are the deliberations that
go into this you know the thoughtfulness the what does this mean in terms of of communication
what uh you know what what kind of data should be on the dashboard that people look for
how do we show uh i mean to me i think having lived over through these issues over so long um
and seeing the swings back and forth you know we beat back 227 but you know this is like uh those
bad sci-fi movies these things have a way of coming back uh you know uh the current if you
look nationally you you can get pretty scared you know plyler is under threat uh arguably uh some
of the civil rights protections are are under threat threat um which is kind of the the lynch
of a lot of what we do and so um with that i'm gonna uh thank you for allowing me to share
sort of these these uh the the my perspective and uh so i'm i'm done but uh thank you very much for
your attention thank you very much dr hakuta and uh president darling hammon i didn't know if he
wanted to pause for clarifying questions on his presentation or just keep going through this
attachment i think some of the questions are going to be addressed by things that you're about to
show so if dr hakuta can hang in there with us till you get to the end of that maybe we
could take all the questions at once would that be okay i'll i'll find my me then all right good
thank you for for the history lesson this morning i i learned something through that
presentation for sure and i very much appreciate um your being here today dr hakuta so transitioning
over to the current system in california of the academic indicator and the el student group um
before i get into the slide deck one thing that i realized um isn't isn't really articulated in
the slides today that dr hakuta touched on was this n size of 30 and that was um it is defined
in our every student state succeeds act state plan so we have to we had to get that approved
by the u.s department of education it was a metric that the board decided on based on
technical analysis from the department as well as policy considerations and so i realized again
back in july it wasn't necessarily a focus of conversation but it's going to come up in some
of the slide decks you're going to slides you're going to see in just a moment so i just wanted to
make sure that i said that um very distinctly i'm sorry we have some noise in the boardroom so
hopefully you can hear me um specifically for the n size of 30 that covers every single indicator
so it's not unique to academics it's not unique to english learners it is universal in the dashboard
that in order to get a performance level or color determination you need to have that n size of
30 students not only over the course of the one year but the two years for to determine a color
so specifically around um this definition for academic indicator and english learners
we um again looked at national experts like dr hakuta and looked at the the research
and also looked at our own data and so the the definition that the board adopted back in 2017
and some of this language actually was taken from that board item so i will just lean on it a little
bit uh that the central premise of school and district performance reflects the effectiveness
of the entire english runner program so thinking about it as a continuum between initial designation
through successful reclassification so you're going to see um the following slide looking at
um uh that information so specifically some of the purposes around including rfps and why the
the board i think was compelled for that four years of reclassified students in the definition
are as fivefold first it removes disincentives for reclassification that districts had experienced
or once experienced second it allows us to see the actual and ongoing progress english learners
are making in a school district or in a school when we do not include our rfps uh the category
of english learners would likely show um would likely or almost always show low performance
we also uh cannot know whether uh recent reclassified students are continuing to progress
when you um when you take them out of that definition and then third uh the inclusion of
rfps allows us to understand the english runner development program success from again that
initial identification through the initial years of reclassification fourth uh it assists with the
stability of the student group and so i think it's important to note and there's actually i think
some some good information in the item as well as background is that since reclassification is
determined locally lea's have that that flexibility within certain parameters english learners and
rfp student populations may have different characteristics so it's not necessarily universal
that certain students are are reclassified at a certain point in time and so due to the the
variety of the criteria that is used although we are moving towards more standardization in the
upcoming years um you just you may see again different student populations within
the english learner student group as well as the rfp population and then lastly uh the uh
the inclusion of rfps increases the number of schools and lea's with this valid end size so
that's what i started off with is um since dr hakuta talked about uh that in the slide and
had a graphic around it um to receive a color for accountability purposes
we also uh the department also provided uh the board with um the sense around the
incentives for reclassification so we want to make sure that we continue to incentivize
reclassification and if we exclude rfps we may result in few schools being able to achieve
green or blue and we really um you know the outset and the principles talk about
making sure that um we have a a wide range of of performance on the dashboard and that's um
partially how or rather that was one of the the ways that cut scores were determined
is to make sure that we had student groups show up in each of those performance categories
um this may result in the unintended consequence of schools not reclassifying english learners
students as quickly as possible and when we did um analysis on schools with green and blue
performance um with english learner student groups we saw that those groups comprised
or rather that a large number of those el only students um rather were comprised of large
numbers of el only students who scored met or exceeded a standard on the statewide assessment
so that's what we saw in those very small schools that achieved the green and blue
when we excluded rfps and as mentioned in the last line in many other leas these students would
have been reclassified so again going back to that um standardization of reclassification statewide
we also uh brought to the board that we do see additional information about el progress
um when we look at looking at students who are in the english learner student group who have
performed in the red categories and so by identifying our english learner student groups
we may just simply be looking at one piece of it a language acquisition of the status of the
students it may not actually show or may not help districts eligible for differentiated assistance
to distinguish those strengths and weaknesses as they determine priorities and allocate resources
so by including rfps we're able to have really differentiation in the system i think that's a
real premise of what we're talking about today additionally leas with large migrant populations
um may actually find that the academic indicator no longer reflects progress of english learners
that was a point that was was made with the original adoption of the inclusion of rfps
because their el population would show disproportionately disproportionately large
numbers of new english learners each year so this is a population that continues to
have students come in and come in it and go out of it as they're reclassified
so i'm going to show you a couple of data tables i did leave out one of the data tables that was
included in the presentation but for our newer members when we bring forward policy considerations
we always try to bring forward the technical analysis that was done and try to provide that
transparency in that information so we've taken a memo that we gave to the board a prior board
back in i believe 2019 that was based on 2018 results and we've updated it with the most
recent information which was from 2019 so this first table that we're looking at which is table
three in your attachment shows the school comparison for english learner and english
learner only student group data on english language arts we're also going to look at this
information for math and then we're going to look at it for leas for both assessments so just to
orient you to this chart on the left hand side we see at the top english learners
and then the years in which RFPSR were considered so this was again something that the board asked
us to do after the adoption of the original definition to see how students were performing
and whether or not you know it was still important to include the reclassified students in the
definition which was a decision that the board has maintained since 2017 so going down the rows
we see the decrease of the years RFEP from four years to three years to two years and then if we
look at this as english learner only so i'm going to start at the top with the english learner plus
the four years RFEP and again you can see a very even distribution which is what we're really
looking for when we when we did the original cut scores so the red being 11 and then on the far end
four percent being in the blue with the concentration of our performance for english learners
on this particular measure in the yellow although you do see a dip on the orange so the original
adoption most likely had more more evenness there but that is with again four years of RFEPs
i want to make sure that we also spend a little bit of time looking at that total
so this is the total number of schools that meet that minimum threshold and size of 30 students
so they've had 30 students who are considered english learners plus four years of RFEPs
over the course of the two-year comparison so this is 2019 data compared to 2018 data
which results in a color this is the baseline year when we go down to the next line we then
take out one year of data for our our reclassified students we're only looking at students who had
reclassified within the last three years you see again the distributions start to shift
on the red and it goes up from 11 percent to almost 15 percent on the orange it increases
to 40 percent yellow decreases green decreases and blue decreases the thing to point out on the
total is we've now lost 199 schools so 199 schools no longer have an english learner
student group for the academic indicator because we've taken out we've removed one year of RFEPs
we've removed that that the students that were RFEP in their fourth four years out if we go down
to the next line for two years on the RFEP we see again an even larger shift on the on the red
side of the the data so we're now up from the original 11 percent with four years RFEP to 21
percent and the orange up to 41 percent and then on down to blue we've gone down to two percent of
schools again the difference between the baseline and having two years of RFEPs we've now lost 552
schools from the accountability system for this metric finally when we look at english language
only so excluding RFEPs altogether we've now increased our red to 38 38.6 orange to 44.8
which again is obviously over 50 percent of the population of schools and then on the far ends
the blue represents 0.2 the most important piece of this chart and we're going to see the same
trends for mathematics and language our LEAs or our districts is the loss of schools in the
accountability system so we've now decreased from 6,400 schools 1,700 schools have been
dropped out because of the end size issue they no longer have enough students to comprise
an english learner student group for the academic indicator so now you have only 4,666 schools
and that represents you know schools in california it's we're over 10 000 schools so just as a
as a point of reference that's the current population of our schools that we expect to see
data for so just we can go through these next ones i think very quickly since i've acquainted
with you with the chart this is shifting we're still on english language arts assessments but
we've shifted it to an lea comparison and again the information that we talked about the trends
we talked about between each of the removal of rfps all the way down to the bottom with only
having an english learner population english runner only population the bottom line is you
decrease the amount of school districts that are in lea's for lea comparisons by 67 which means for
this metric you would not even be able to use the assessment results for english language or
rather ele and math ele as a measure for differentiated assistance they fall out altogether
for mathematics the same is generally true the numbers are somewhat similar with again for
schools we see a decrease of 1765 when we take out all of the rfps and then finally for districts
similar to the english language arts we're seeing a decrease of 66 districts that would have
results for mathematics if english if rfps were taken out of the definition
so what does all this mean and what does this data analysis show specifically when we look back to
data that predates the dashboard which is 2016 up to 2019 which is the last time we've produced a
dashboard we continue to hold that more schools and districts would be accountable for the
effectiveness of the entire el program if you continue rather the definition continues to hold
including four years of reclassified students in the definition for the academic indicator
we also know that or we can see from the data that significantly fewer schools and lea's receive a
performance level for their english learner student groups when we when the inclusion of the rfps is
reduced any fewer than those four years that is in the current definition additionally just to
be very clear the english learner only student group does not include rfps and we would see
27 fewer schools and over 10 fewer districts receiving a performance level for english language arts
i wanted to point out and i actually heard from a couple people they had never looked at this
report so i just want to be really clear that when the board adopted the definition in 2017
they wanted to see this breakdown this disaggregation of students for every school
and every district that had they had enough students to meet that end size of 30 so the
department provides this on every school and district report that meets that that threshold
and specifically this is an example from 2019 i don't remember the district and if i did i'm
not going to tell you which one it is but specifically for this district when we look
at current english learners they have 3948 students that aggregation of data shows that
the current english learners are 81.6 points below standard for english language arts
but they maintained at a negative point 2.4 points they reclassified students on the other
hand i think this demonstrates dr kudu's point did exceptionally well at 25.8 points above standard
for the approximate 4200 students that were in that population at this district on the other
hand the english only students were only at 13.6 percent above standards which was an increase of
3.2 so you can see and dr kudu said this that research has shown or data shows that our
reclassified english learners continue to really do better in the long run for
um in the long run period um so i just wanted to make sure that i pointed out this information
is available one click away from the home page when you're on the academic indicator you click
on view more information and this information is there we also make this available in our
downloadable data files so anybody can look at it for the whole state excuse me
uh additionally um and you're gonna hear next from um in the next item about our assessment system
but under mal vang's direction dr mal vang the california assessment of student performance
and progress their web reporting site further disaggregates performance um and this is under
the english language fluency tab and so you can see the various categories that we can get
information about our english learners and the assessment data
and then just to close out um i mentioned briefly that english learners have their own indicator
um and we measure uh the progress of of um towards english proficiency through the english
learner progress indicator or lb and that's based on the results of students who took the summative
english language proficiency assessment for california or lpac
additionally um just wanted to point out the differences between our english language arts
and our mathematics indicators and the lp they do measure different aspects of el success
first that they make we're making sure that these students are making sufficient progress
before towards language acquisition to increase el access to curriculum and all content areas
and then second we are making sure that we are evaluating the strength of the entire el program
and academic performance again from initial designation through successful reclassification
and then finally for the english learner progress indicator or lp we want to make sure through that
measure that we are determining whether el students are making sufficient progress in
english acquisition in contrast again our academic indicators are measuring students
mastery of academic standards and elas have the ability to look at not only the academic indicator
data but lp and then the other student outcomes that we measure el then but specifically those
two metrics together allow for information around the success of the english language
development program as a whole
so with that i am happy to turn it over to president darlin for a conversation
off of mute and thank cindy and dr hakuta for all of that information you may feel like your brain
is full this is for us to talk through some of the questions that may have arisen
and so i'm gonna um let me get my participant banner up here i see hands up already so um
member escobedo and then member glover woods you can kick us off well i truly appreciate the
comprehensiveness of the presentations and um we've come a long way in california you know from an
exclusionary way of looking at english learners to yeah they're part of our the fabric of our
public school systems and that's not not always the case in some of the states that i work in
but as a former superintendent i i really appreciate the inclusion of of our feb
and because we you know we we can't mask the effect of great teaching that's happening
with our english learners um however you know when i was superintendent i did see
us uh about 10 20 percent of our english learners not progressing and i think dr hakuta showed
a very important slide especially those students that started at level one and many of them become
long-term english learners and what we as a district had to do is really bolster our
designated ELD for that particular population we saw some amazing results uh as a
because of that and i was just wondering um as we're looking at these indicators again
is there um a rationale or is there a possibility of looking at either at risk
uh long-term ELLs or long-term ELLs as part of how we look at the entire
english learner population and i know that we have a place in the system that does
record that information i want to ask cindy where that lives where those data live
yes so we are constrained by reporting that information through a specific definition
through education code i think it's 3.13 but let me make sure i i go back and look at my my code
section and that information is available on LTEL and at-risk enrollments through dataquest
and so you can find information about the population of students from the year prior
on dataquest it's always going to be a year behind because that definition requires us to include
performance on the assessments when we look at it it's not as simple um this is how many years
you were an english learner but that is where we make that available and we do make available a
student level file to schools and districts so they can look at information at the student level
if those students are still of course part of their school or district and haven't matriculated
yeah the issue is that when you're looking at long-term english learners you have to go
beyond one year um so just just a thought well i think that the uh when the one year pertains to
the fact that you have to incorporate in the state definition the achievement data as well as the
number of years they've been in the system but it doesn't it does go beyond one year does it
you want to give the definition cindy
the definition for for an at-risk or a long-term english learner how many years
they will have all have not been yet been reclassified there's some number of years
attached to that yes so for at-risk it's i believe five or four or five and then we
hit um long-term at at six plus but i do not have the exact definition in front of me so i want to
make sure i bring that up so this is a data point that tells you how many long-term english
learners have been in el status for six years or more and have not yet met a certain bar on the
status i think one of the questions we may want to come back to is how people access that data
because it's important data and these data sit in different places um and so that's a really
important point to um for us to so i do have the definitely do you have the definition
sorry i can i can read this um an english learner at risk of becoming a long-term english learner
the definition is an el student to which all of the following apply number one is enrolled on
census day the first wednesday in october in grades three through twelve inclusive and number
two has been enrolled in a u.s school for four or five years and number three has scored at the
intermediate level or below level three or below on the prior year administration of the l pack
great yes cindy i know you have a wonderful you showed me and some others a wonderful table
that you can get from data quest which shows all the categories of english learners and how they
are progressing if if we want to share that that might be very helpful for people to see
do you know the one i'm talking about i do you'd like me to get online and share it right now let
me make sure that i can um yeah i'll i'll i'll take member glover woods's question while you're
finding it okay so that we um can keep things moving member glover woods thank you president
darling hammon um to a point that you may know just a couple of moments ago there seems to be
not seems to be there is a wealth of english learner data that can be disaggregated in so
many different ways but it sits in many different places i think part of uh the concern and concerns
that have been expressed is not necessarily the access to the data but again how that data is
displayed and also when i think more importantly how lea's are held accountable for the progress
of their english learner students i have a clarification question and then just a very
brief statement and cindy i know you're looking for another slide in another chart so i apologize for
giving this question to you but i wanted to be sure that i understood tables three through six
in the presentation you shared that showed uh the number of schools and the number of lea's
that were in a sense lost out of the um accountability box if you will
when the definition of uh english learner was changed from including the four years of rff all
the way to not so my question is just to be sure that i'm understanding correctly when we're looking
at the number of schools that no longer would receive a performance level and the number of
lea's that would not it does that mean that those schools and lea's would not have uh at least 30
students identified as english learners per the criteria on that row that's correct
okay thank you cindy thank you very much for for that clarification um and i just i kind of go back
to thinking about our principles and thinking about our goal of looking at the english learner
program in full which would be from initial designation through reclassification to see
see how the program itself is supporting um what we want to look at as it relates to having more
schools that are receiving performance levels and and do we risk while looking at more schools in
the program as a whole missing large larger number of students that might be sitting in schools
that might not be identified or schools or lea's that may not be eligible so um i appreciated dr
hakuta's presentation and one of the things i jotted down as he was talking about the
yale definition and state accountability system uh that one of the goals was to include as many
schools with english learners while maintaining the stability of the model um but again i i go to i
think some of the concern is that in doing so there are large number of schools and lea's that
have english learners that are not eligible for differentiated assistance and that differentiated
assistance is looked at as a way to in a sense hold both schools and lea's accountable for their
english learners so i'm just kind of pointing that out is what i'm understanding the concern is and
again just interested in continuing to hear more and hear more about conversations that would take
place to perhaps mitigate that particular issue thank you um cindy do you want to show that other
very um elaborate table that you had located thank you so much this is this is a data wonk's dream
this session more data than you can shake a stick at um just so i um allow everybody an opportunity
to see where i um how i got there under our data statistics tab uh we do data reports by topic and
our english learner data all of the data we make available is here as well as these downloadable
files and the various um resources that we we have but this is the last report called at risk
in long-term english learners which was released um i believe in in august just this last month
so this is based on 2020 2022 school year you can filter by charter schools non-charter schools you
can look at the county it defaults to the state report you also have the opportunity um to look
at within um these student group this student group rather these students whether or not they're
socially disadvantaged whether or not they're migrant foster homeless and so you will see
obviously um different um enrollment information but this is really simply the enrollment reports
statewide for um first of all english learners um and then um for our um populations of rfx as
well as our everiel so to acquaint you to the chart um this is a grade level chart because we
know that of course if you're a kindergartener you shouldn't be an altel right you have not
been in the system for six plus years so that's why the chart barely distinctly shows you know
where we see entry in the largest population of our english learners is is absolutely in those
first couple of grades um we also see a lot of progress to rfx in those grades as well
so you can see el's by zero to three years the at risk definition that i mentioned and then the
altel definition which is six plus years plus the assessment um pieces that are included in that
the glossary i want to make sure i point out it's very thorough it talks through each of
these metrics and it does have the education code section quoted here it's 3.3 which was
what i mentioned but it's 0.1 a you can see the the piece here so that is um the uh to member
point about how do you know who's in this you know that in well if you had these the same population
of students in in in fourth grade you knew that they were third graders the prior year which is
the data we are looking at they were looking at on those charts that they would have most likely
taken that they would have been required to take the assessments and so that is just again one more
piece of information around english learners that the state
supports and providing to the field and to the community as a whole
so
president darling hammond i don't know if you wanted to pick up or is she frozen
i think she might be frozen yes she might be
it appears she is uh i see that member yosha monotowery may have a question
thank you
i had a question that built off of vice president glover wood's question and
do we know and if not today can we find out the number of students the number of english learners
and the number of reclassified students that are attending schools that have 29 or less
english learners in them in other words they're not being identified or counted on the dashboard
i think we today we got the number of school the number of schools
to clarify you want to see this total student population that would not be represented or that
is represented that isn't represented is not represented they're right there's a number of
of in both classifications current el's and reclassified who are not represented because
they're at a school that has 29 or less english learners i i know it might not be possible to get
that information right now but i'd be curious to know that yeah i definitely cannot do that on the
fly but we can look at the 10 000 schools and see which ones are not part of this and then
which ones of them actually have english learners and what what that total end size is for the state
that would be great thank you and um my other question was um
and i think you made a really clear case for why our feps need to be included with el's
um what i wanted some clarification on is is there a way that we could do that in which
the needs of current el's aren't masked with the the rfp so in other words still maintaining
the larger number of schools shown on this chart but also doing it in a way that disaggregates
the data
so i i think that's what was already to do guys a 2017 decision and this this chart is there
something beyond this chart that you would suggest this is on a different screen right on
the additional el data screen it's not on the additional el data screen it's actually on the
disaggregated screen for um for each indicator so when you're still on the dashboard you click
view more view more information that's where you find all the information about all the student
groups but specifically for el this is the only one that we dig in further for any indicator on
the dashboard so this is a very specialized report it's housed on the dashboard and it is
you know intended to be used to inform conversations about current english learner
performance versus the rfp performance so as you said earlier it's one click away
on any indicator you just click one more time to get to it
are there other i know we have more content in this session on other topics as well and
this is a very important issue but i want to see if there's any other questions or comments on this
at this point and i want to thank dr hakuta for having hung in there with us as we ask these
questions you know excuse me if i just comment while this very interesting slide is is up here
um i think uh that um that english the current uh english only uh or i'm sorry the current english
learner performance uh disaggregated in this way is is really valuable uh i think uh making sure
that this is what people should be looking for if they're interested in current english learners
and knowing that it's available is is you know kind of a communication issue but it's it's really a
important one but the other thing i would encourage you to do is to think simultaneously
with how those current english learners are doing on the on the elpi on the english learner
performance indicator because that's going to be the best predictor of their future performance
and would give you important information on the kind of differentiated support those students
might need that is if they're mostly you know at at a low level versus many of them are at a more
higher level it'll give you the the sense and that may also answer some of the the ltl concerns um
how are we doing around early indicators and so forth the uh the one that board member escapado
mentioned uh is is of concern and so just having strategies to help uh you know kind of the
stakeholders as well as the board uh drill drill down through this so thanks for letting me insert
that i think that's really where my question was uh aiming towards yeah so it's certainly we have
a lot of data that we need to figure out how to help it be well used i think is the the challenge
that we have um member rodriguez um yes i want to thank uh professor hakuta um kenji thank you so
much for the wonderful presentation and that uh walk through memory lane with all the policies
that i lived through and um you know was it was traumatic uh and and i want to say that having
grown up on a border town we were all bilingual everybody spoke english and spanish and it was
just very natural when i moved 12 miles north it was english only and so it was a real shock to me
luckily i had already passed my formative years which you know when we talk about um the altals and
students who are struggling uh it occurs to me that with all of what california is doing especially
with tk i think that that's very promising for um supporting a lot of a lot of the students who
uh struggle because of you know it could be vocabulary and english and or spanish or other
languages so again thank you so much uh professor hakuta really uh love this presentation i'm very
proud to share all the battle scars with the id okay um well i'm glad we had this really rich
conversation and just to kind of put one more frame on the big issues that dr hakuta helped us to
recognize uh when we were only using the el category of course you know as soon as students
become more proficient they leave the category so the category can never improve as a as a
category if you eliminate english learners on an accountability basis as soon as they become
reclassified if you're particularly in a migrant community you're always going to have new people
coming in and they will always be bounded and that as part of the big picture under no child
left behind there was sort of a an identified by researchers there was a diversity penalty
identified that schools that had more groups and particularly at english learners with that
definition that they could never see improvement in the accountability system had the effect of
encouraging push out let's get rid of the kids you know encourage them to drop out it had the
effect of discouraging integration of schools because if you let the el's in they're going to
bring your you know accountability metrics down and be in the category even if the kids were
improving you could never get credit for the improvement in those schools so it dr hakuta
mentioned the ways in which our current policies around multilingual education which we are really
leaning into right now are under threat across the country in a variety of states and even in
the federal judicial branch because pilar may be made vulnerable at this point and and in some
ways public education is under threat in many places so the view that english learners never
progress which was fed by that way of measuring ill group progress for accountability purposes
feeds the public perception that they can't be taught or that schools are doing the wrong thing
it feeds the perception that we could go should go back to english only programs and so it's
important to have a way to look at english learner progress that in fact gives districts
credit for the progress that they are enabling people to make allows us to see what that progress
is but then also does identify the problem of long-term english learners in a way that we can
address it and invest in the resources that they need so i think at the end of the day we need to
get to a place where we take all of these data and make them available in the right ways and
encourage a recognition of both the progress that multilingual learners are making on the one hand
and that schools are enabling them to make and the problem of long-term english learners who need
more investment who need more support in a way that gets readily recognized so we'll continue to
need to work on this this agenda and figure out how to use all of the data that we have in the
ways that get the results that we want and with that i just want to hand it back to you cindy for
i think there's yet another topic that we we need to take up there is another topic but you're going
to get a break from hearing from me and you're going to hear from one of my colleagues kimberly
muntank who is going to be presenting the next three attachments which i think will they are
for action so let me just phrase that appropriately there they're for action and she'll take you through
what's before you for a decision
good morning board members yes today you've just gone through event of information however the
following three attachments do have actions attached to each one of them so i will walk
through and i will pause after each one for questions just as we did here but we will be
able to then get through the rest of the presentation so this morning i'm going to
walk through differentiated assistance using the 2022 dashboard and as the theme of 2022 is
things are a little bit different we're close to being back to normal but not everything is
where we used to be back in 2019 so first let me clarify what exactly differentiated assistance is
um differentiated assistance eligibility determinations as i just referenced
were last made in december of 2019 using the 2019 2019 dashboard results
sorry about my mask um due to the covet 19 pandemic and lea's eligible for differentiated
assistance back when we made those determinations have remained in differentiated assistance since
then and based on those results and back then there were three uh 333 districts and
county offices of education that and 23 charter schools that were eligible for differentiated
assistance and have remained in that assistance level since 2019 now when i mention levels of
assistance this is what i mean um the system of support provides three separate levels of
assistance level one which is support for all level two differentiated assistance or da which
some of us also refer to it as and level three intensive intervention level one support for all
is what every district charter school and county office of education receives as everyone is
eligible for general assistance within the system of support level two differentiated assistance
provides districts charter schools and county offices of education who have been identified
as eligible to receive this level based on their performance in each local control funding formula
or lcff state priority area and finally level three intensive intervention which i want to
point out has not been activated within the state yet is a specific level of intensive intervention
for persistent performance issues over a period of time
today we're going to walk through the eligibility requirements and how we look at
eligibility for 2022 differentiated assistance now this second tier again one off from the general
level level one assistance is where um one or more agencies are required by statute to provide
support to lea's that meet certain eligibility criteria and this assistance as cindy kind of
mentioned in her um uh her presentation earlier is really customized and based on the needs of
the lea it isn't a one-size-fits-all approach hence the word differentiated um and so some of
the following are kind of some of the examples of types of support that can be offered to lea's
within differentiated assistance so for example there can be training and support to engage in
plan do study act cycles and use improvement science tools throughout the a range of you know
looking back at previous data and looking forward at new data and especially some you know looking
at facilitating communities of interest so gathering multiple districts and charter schools
that qualify for differentiated assistance and providing communities of support and then
subcontracting with trainers and consultants to support lea needs and so the identification
as we walk through it you can be identified for different differentiated assistance in multiple
ways for multiple different indicators and so when you're looking at the level of support that's
provided back to you that can also be differentiated specific to those needs and the reasons for why you
were identified for that support now differentiated assistance eligibility determinations
are made annually and this follows the release of the dashboard each year and just to clarify
and it's a little bit different than our federal assistance and previous years of identification
for support differentiated assistance isn't a status so districts and counties offices of education
and charter schools don't exit from assistance because you have level one's assistance for all
schools and opportunities even though you're if you're previously identified and you say you know
x you no longer meet the eligibility criteria you are still eligible for level one support
throughout everything and you still may have access to some of those same supports that were
available for you under differentiated assistance they may still exist under level one support as
well. Now both state and local indicators go towards the determination for differentiated
assistance eligibility and the results for each priority area are reported on the dashboard
and used to determine this eligibility for both districts and county offices of education
and I'm going to walk through the following tables to identify the student group criteria
for each priority area that's used to make the LCF have eligibility for assistance determinations.
There are 10 priority areas and I will walk through how what this looks like
for priority areas one through 10. Our first three priorities one two and three basics
implementation of state academic standards and parent and family engagement these are all local
indicators so as you can see the criteria for becoming eligible for assistance is that you have
not met for two or more years your local performance criteria. For priority numbers four and five we
have pupil achievement and pupil engagement. I will as you can see priority area four is quite
involved the criteria for it involves two different state indicators both our academic
indicators as well as our English learner progress indicators and the criteria in 2019
and as adopted by the state board is that you would receive red you'd be eligible if you receive red
on both the English language arts and math tests or red on the English language arts or math tests
and orange on the other test or for English learner progress indicator if you received a
status of very low and I just want to note that only LP status was available in 2019
so that is why the criteria for this was a status level and not a color level.
For priority number five people engagement you need to receive either a red on your graduation
rate indicator or a red on your chronic absenteeism indicator.
Here you see the final five criteria listed for priority number six school climate you need to
either receive a red on your suspension rate indicator or a not met for two or more years
on your local performance for the school climate area so this is the one priority area that combines
both a state indicator and a local indicator performance. Priority number seven access to
a broad course of study is not met for two or more years on local performance.
Priority number eight outcomes an abroad course of study you need to receive a red on the college
slash career indicator in order to be eligible under this priority and finally priority numbers
nine and ten coordination for services of expelled pupils and coordination of services
for foster youth those are both only qualify for county offices of education those are both
local indicators and therefore the eligibility criteria is that you have not been not met for
two or more years on local performance. This giant matrix that I just showed you that obviously you
can see on powerpoint doesn't quite fit on one nice neat little graph when I printed out I printed
out a legal paper just that I can see all of it in one place. There's three different ways that you
can be identified using the combination of these indicators. One is that you look at just state
indicators only and so that's method one. What you need is across all of those priority areas
one student group needs to meet the eligibility criteria across two different priority areas.
So for example your Hispanic student group may qualify may make your LEA
eligible for differentiated assistance if they had both a red in chronic absenteeism and a red
in suspension for their student group and that would be across two different priority areas
area five and priority area six. Additionally you can qualify for differentiated assistance
just through local indicators so if you receive a not met for two or more years criteria in at
least two different priority areas so example priority areas one and two then you would also
qualify for differentiated assistance and then finally we have the combination of state and
local indicators or method three and this is where you would have one or more student group
meet a criteria in one priority area so for example students with disabilities receiving
a red for graduation rate in priority area five and then the LEA or county offices of education
meets the not met for two or more years on only one local indicator in a different priority area
so for example parent engagement on priority area three. Now this table we're going back three years
and we're going to be looking at what differentiated assistance looked like in 2019 and this outlines how
utilizing those three different methods that I just spoke to LEAs were eligible for differentiated
assistance now as you can see overwhelmingly 331 LEAs were identified for differentiated assistance
based on state indicator performance therefore that meaning one student group met the criteria
in at least two or more priority areas people often ask what if we have more than one student
group that qualifies us for that doesn't get you further into differentiated assistance in this area
it just means that you know you have more than one student group that has made you eligible and
again within the differentiated assistance process you'll be able to have support provided for all of
those student groups that met that criteria we had two LEAs that did qualify under the local
indicators method method two and we did not have any LEAs that qualified under method three so this
is how we arrived at our total of 333 LEAs that qualified for differentiated assistance
how this breaks down by student groups that provided and this eligibility criteria are as
follows for black and african-american students student groups there were 53 LEAs that met
differentiated assistance criteria utilizing this utilizing the state methodology American Indian
and Alaska Native 28 Asian American and Filipino there were no LEAs identified under these student
groups Hispanic had 42 Pacific Islander eight white 31 and two or more races nine
for our program groups homeless students qualified LEAs for 98 or 98 LEAs qualified
with the homeless students English learners students had 57 foster youth students 101
students with disabilities overwhelmingly had the largest share with 187
and socioeconomically disadvantaged students had 62
now quick brief mention of this while charter schools were identified back in 2018 this year
they are not eligible to be identified in 2022 that is because changes were made to the eligibility
criteria following the 2019 identification process so in assembly bill 130 it set forth some parameters
around changing the criteria for differentiated assistance and charter schools and so
they now need two years of data going forward so therefore charter schools will begin eligibility
for identification again under this this newly revised criteria following the release of the
2023 dashboard results now the action before you today is walking through and adopting
changes to the differentiated assistance criteria that I just presented for the 2022-23 school year
now why do we need to change the differentiated assistance methodology for 2022
well as I started this out with as a result of the limitations of 81 30 the CDE is limited
to our differentiated assistance eligibility criteria's determinations and we can only use
status levels from the 2022 dashboard so all those colors I brought up and everything I mentioned
that is null and void we don't have colors so we need to modify the criteria today in order to be
able to provide identifications based on the 2022 dashboard additionally because we are limited by
status we only have available to us method one for identification we cannot identify any LEAs
based on local indicators because they need two or more years in order to be able to qualify and
be eligible so therefore we can only use state indicators for these determinations and then
finally adding one more little hiccup to our plan there's no data for the college slash career indicator
on the 2022 dashboard it will return in status only in 2023 however we don't have that so that
will be one more indicator and as you could if you look back on your chart one priority area
that does not have a state indicator associated with it
now earlier this year we were able to do some technical evaluations and looked into for our
SA determinations about if it was okay technically for us to use status as a proxy for color
and when we did this we found that the lowest status levels so either very low or very high
and that would be for our chronic absenteeism and suspension indicators is a reasonable proxy for
red we also found within looking at this information that other status levels such as low
medium and high weren't suitable proxies for their other corresponding colors so for example
low and orange or high and orange were not good proxies and for each other and they increased
the level of error in the eligibility determinations through our investigations
so here was the determine what we found when we looked into this so schools with a color in 2019
for chronic absenteeism for example we found that 79 percent of them had correlation across
very high and a red determination and at the bottom you can see 84 percent earned very low
and blue so we saw you know strong correlation across the top and the bottom category
categories however as you can see with 45 percent earning high and orange 19
earning medium and yellow 62 earning low and green there's a very mixed bag of
correlation between those statuses and colors so therefore as a result of looking at this across
all the indicators we found that we determined that very high seemed to be a decent proxy
for red in this in this situation and we felt comfortable
proposing that as a replacement for the color red moving forward
so here in front of you is the criteria that we are proposing for the 2022 differentiated
assistance methodology it is limited to four priority areas and not 10 as you can see from
before because these are the only priority areas with indicators available in the 2022 dashboard
for priority for pupil achievement we are proposing that you will be eligible for
differentiated assistance if your student group receives a very low on both english language arts
and the math academic indicator or they receive a very low on the lp for priority five pupil
engagement with the proposed criteria is very low on the graduation rate indicator
or very high on the chronic absenteeism indicator and finally for priority six school climate
our proposed eligibility is very high on the suspension rate indicator
we went through and modeled what this data would look like using this proposed criteria
what that would look like if we did that on our 2019 dashboard so in the table in front of you
are the results of that data simulation we talked about before in 2019 that the differentiated
assistance method one results identified 331 lea is eligible for differentiated assistance
if we take out the cci as it will be available on the 2022 dashboard and we adjust that in 2019
we can see that the number of lea's eligible would be reduced to 297
if we utilize only if we utilize status rather instead of colors and use all the criteria that
i just proposed on the previous slide we would see 399 lea's eligible for differentiated assistance
utilizing status for priority areas four five and six
how this breaks out by student group is available on the next two slides
so you can see across all of the student groups except for hispanics the number of lea's that are
eligible for differentiated assistance utilizing this new criteria for 2022 increases across every
student group so you can see black african-americans goes from 53 to 80 american indian alaska native
goes from 28 to 41 asian americans are identified for them where they were not previously there's
still no filipino student group hispanics reduces from 52 to 31 pacific islander goes from 8 to 10
white goes from 31 to 33 and turma races goes from 9 to 16 we did include in the center column
the adjustments for what it looks like without cci is as you can see for hispanic student group
and others you can see that the numbers reduce right for multiple student groups that were
identified utilizing the cci criteria when we look at our program groups these numbers also
increase across the board homeless students go from 98 to 149 english learner students decrease
from 57 to 46 foster youth students go from 101 to 144 students with disabilities go from 187
to 283 and socioeconomically disadvantaged students go from 62 to 73
i've been told we're going to move forward and we'll take clarifying questions
at the end so i will walk through the other two proposals for action
on today both of these concern adding things to the 2022 dashboard
attachment four talks through adding teacher assignment data and how that would fit into
the 2022 dashboard following the state board approval of your teacher assignment definitions
state plan the california commission on teacher credentialing the ctc and the cde have been
working together for two years to bring data sets together for the creation of teacher assignment
monitoring outcome reports and we are very proud to present to you that these data were released
on dataquest on june 30 at the 2022 and additionally this data was made available for inclusion in the
2020-21 state accountability report report cards or the sarks as well and you can find all of that
data available for download and looking at today on dataquest how this fits into the dashboard
is that in 2019 senate bill 75 updated ed code to require that no later than january 31st 2021
local indicators shall reflect school level data to the extent that the department collects or
otherwise has access to relevant and reliable school level data for all schools statewide now
that we have started building this data out and have released the first year of data this
section of ed code pops in and we need to start moving forward with action to see how we can
comply with this education code section with regards to this new set of data with teacher data
priority one is where um local um uh local indicator priority one is where this all fits
and so here you can see the criteria of basics teacher instruction materials and facilities
so as you can see here this local indicator addresses the percentage of appropriately
assigned teachers students access to curriculum aligned instructional materials and safe and clean
functional school facilities and there are three separate components here the first one
misassignment of teachers deals with that set of information that we just released on june 30th
additionally there are other components to priority one the second being percent of
students without access to their own copies of standards aligned instructional materials
for use at schools and at home and finally three instances where facilities do not meet the good
repair standard including deficiencies and extreme deficiencies previously on other dashboards this
information was self-reported and now and on the 2022 dashboard will continue to be however
misassignment of teachers is information where we now have state level data that we've been
collecting and providing and we will trying to figure out how do we incorporate that information
into this three-part local indicator moving forward
um for the dashboard we need two years of data prior to implementing anything um
and and publishing it forward on the dashboard especially for accountability uses
so therefore since we only have one year of data as released in june 30th we were thinking
that for the interim we could possibly add a link for the published data quest reports within
the dashboard in order to get halfway to where we want to be fully when we have two years of data
so therefore we are proposing on the 2022 dashboard to link directly to that teacher data
spoke about and this would mean adding a link to each lea's 2021 or 2020-21 teaching assignment
monitoring outcomes by full-time equivalent fte report on data quest within the priority one
reporting section on their 2022 dashboard now as i just mentioned before the uh all of the lea's
are currently actually entering this data into um their local priority one information
through their self-reporting during the local indicator submission window which is august
through september so they'll continue to do that this year however we would be able to facilitate
a link to this information in order to support these efforts of meeting this obligation we
convened an ad hoc work group on august 31st to provide feedback to the addition of this teacher
assignment data to the 2022 dashboard and this work group consisted of education practitioners
and advocates additionally we also spoke to and presented this information in this proposal to
cpeg members at their august 2022 meeting and they expressed appreciation for the accessibility
to robust data available through data quest as well as linkage to the data directly through the
2022 dashboard the ad hoc work group that we convened supported the cde proposal as well
and also further discussed the development of resources that could be translated into
different languages to assist the public with reviewing these data quest reports
now what comes next the 2023 dashboard will look to include the second year of data and we will
re-engage that ad hoc policy advisory group along with technical experts to help develop criteria
for the state board to consider pursuant to ed code section 52064.5 for use on the 2020 2023
dashboard so we will be able to once we have that second year of data engage in those further
conversations and technical analysis to see how we can incorporate this information into a local
indicator moving forward our final piece of action for today is attachment five the california
science test cast and the 2022 dashboard similar to what i just presented what we were going to be
looking at is how we can incorporate this information on this year's dashboard as well
because in march of 2022 you requested us to review options for reporting the status
science data on the dashboard for informational purposes without having to be used for
accountability purposes for example to be used to determine differentiated assistance for leas
or for school support under sf now implementing the cast is a really important piece of our
accountability system and what we're looking forward to looking forward to and what the state
board has reflected in their priorities we recognize that cast is an important component
within our assessment system and within casp itself however multiple years of current assessment
data are needed before we can evaluate the addition of cast formally to the dashboard
for use as a state indicator within the accountability system now there have been
multiple difficulties in implementing the science instructional materials
which were adopted by the state board in november of 2018 and as a result the full implementation
of the california next generation science standards have it has not occurred throughout
the entire state we think that adding a link to the dashboard this year in 2022 to the cast
results from this prior school year is the first step to prepare the field for adding this metric
to future dashboards therefore our proposal is similar to the last action add to add a link to
the 2022 cast results for each school and lea through the 2022 dashboard we have two options
to do so one would be a general link to cast results in their whole and two would be a specific
link to the school or lea through the additional reports button so let me show you what those two
different options look like for a general link we would be looking at the top bar of the dashboard
and we would be able to add a link to the more information tab at the top of the dashboard
and link to the cast results simply through that link
if we're looking at the adding something to the additional reports button this would provide a
specific link to the school or lea results through the additional reports button so at the top corner
top right corner of each dashboards lea or schools dashboard reports it'll say view additional reports
if you clicked that and then through a sub menu at the next screen you would be able to get to
and the next screen you would be able to get to those specific reports for your cast results
cast results for that school or lea
at the august 2022 meeting we presented this to cpag and several cpag members expressed their
support to include a link in the additional reports button comments were also made about
the importance to communicate the availability of such a link and the need to provide instructions
on how the data should be used or interpreted
those are your final updates for action moving forward
to sum up everything today i'm going to walk you through a quick update
on where we are with the 2022 dashboard and we will revisit in november to show you just what
we're up to specifically with a few more images and walking through before publication later this
year now people keep asking me what's on the 2022 dashboard and we've created this beautiful chart
that essentially shows you that every single year of the dashboard has not been quote-unquote
normal in 2017 when we first published the dashboard as you can see we were missing the
chronic absenteeism and college career indicators from the dashboard in 2018
the english learner progress indicator disappeared because we had a new test
that was debuting shortly and college and career showed up as status only in 2019
we almost had every indicator english but the english language progress indicator only had
status for 2020 and 2021 or 2020 there was no dashboard of any sort with any indicators
in 2021 the local indicators reappeared and now in 2022 we will have status only
for all of our indicators except for the college career indicator
we have taken the identity of having a status only dashboard and we have moved forward with making
sure that everyone knows that 2022 is a special year and that it looks different and that it was
reflected differently than the colors that you see available however while it doesn't have complete
information to create a color there is still information that's important to get out to the
field therefore we created a cell phone bar for each of our status levels and we've created a
graphic that will show how schools and lea's are performing utilizing these cell phone graphics
additionally there will be one color for all status levels that color being purple so you
will see purple all over the dashboard and it should very visually click that this is not
a normal year and that this information looks different we will also retain the equity report
at the bottom of each single baseball card that will show you how student groups performed across
each of the status levels however this time it's just status levels instead of across colors
additionally we've been very busy providing and creating resources to navigate the dashboard
and as president harman spoke of communicating and making sure that things are clear to the
field and everyone can navigate to these things we've been developing multiple resources to assist
lea's and schools with the return of accountability in 2022 specifically with the development of a
toolkit with flyers webinars and talking points a redesign of all of our web pages to support lea's
access to general and technical information about the dashboard we're going to be reinvigorating our
outreach efforts through social media and additionally providing dashboard activities
to support lea's and schools throughout the fall and winter we're proud to say that in august of
2022 we just released our dashboard toolkit and normally this is information that we release with
the dashboard in december and january however we released it in august nice and early so that
people have access to this information and additionally if there's something missing
that we can work to provide that prior to the dashboard being released it specifically includes
lea flyers parent flyers which are translated webinars for each indicator will which will be
debuting shortly for the public as well as talking points around the data and information provided
in the 2022 dashboard results we'll be providing these resources at in-person conferences throughout
the fall through twitter at our accounts at cde dashboard and multiple cde listservs throughout
the rest of the year when we're talking about our accountability website design we have devoted
considerable time and effort to just completely restruct and redesign the school dashboard and
system of support web pages and specifically to create distinct pages for each and every
dashboard indicator additionally so that with those pages we can highlight the availability of
resources flyers technical documents and informational materials and we can cross
link and provide direct links across cde and our web page web pages with our other divisions
to link directly back to these indicators we're really proud of them we hope that it's a much
easier way to access all of this information and i encourage you to click on the link and
check them out and see all of the different information that's available for each of the
indicators additionally we will be presenting fall webinar presentations to support lea's
for the dashboard release we know there's a lot of new folks in the field we know there's a lot
of new folks to accountability in general so we want to reacquaint and reorient those folks as
well as bring everyone up to speed on why 2022 looks a little bit different we will also have
preview support for the dashboard as we do each and every year so lea's will have access to a
private preview of data prior to the dashboard release they'll be able to look at their data
make sure that everything looks fine that we've published everything and we've done our due diligence
as well and they'll be able to see that information prior to it being published
and then finally our we have public release support and we have decided to clean house a
little bit and we have a new dashboard email address which is simply dashboard at cde.ca.gov
this is your one-stop shop to get in touch with anyone concerning anything around accountability
and we've seen that it's very easy to talk about and get a hold of us so if anyone needs any
needs any resources of any sort you can contact us there and that's your first stop shop and we
will get your answers back to you and find the resources that you need to be able to do your
jobs in the field as well and with that the recommendations for today do you want to go
through the city okay i will read through all of the recommendations for these three actions
the state the california department of education cde is seeking approval to
one use the lowest status level as a proxy for red as reported on the 2022 dashboard
to determine county offices of education and districts eligible for differentiated assistance
two to include a link on the dashboard to the teacher assignment data that is supported through
dataquest and three include a link on the dashboard to the science results that's
supported through the cask website
president darlingham and i think you're on mute if you're speaking
i think i i'm on the phone because i was having computer trouble can you hear me
we can great so we call this our mega accountability item and this is a mega mega
accountability item this morning and so what we'd like to do is see if there are clarifying comments
or questions just the brief kind of clarifying questions you might have about the presentation
you just heard with respect to the dashboard that i'm going to break us for lunch for a half an hour
and then we'll come back for public comments and our discussion and our vote so that we can be
mindful and thoughtful when we are having our opportunity to hear from the public and take our
vote so if there are any clarifying questions just about the facts of what was just presented
we can take those now before we go to lunch we're going to hold the answers in our heads
and come back after that for our discussion comment discussion and vote are there any clarifying
questions don't worry about the fact that you stand between us and lunch it's okay
so i'm not seeing any at the moment and i'm going to call on our vice president for her framing
comments after we get back from lunch so we'll be able to remember this as we go forward
all right that being the case i want to thank cindy and her team for the amazing presentation
very thorough very thoughtful i want to alert the folks who are going to call in for public
comments that we're going to reconvene at about 12 20 it's 11 50 now so we'll take a half an hour
for lunch we'll come back at 12 20 i also need to ask you to actually disconnect from the meeting
at this point because there's an it problem that needs to be addressed while we are away and sign
back in at 11 20 all right we'll see you then thank you
welcome back uh in order to establish a quorum i'll ask brooks to call the roll
president darlin hammond here member escobedo here vice president glover woods
here member lewis here number mcquillin present member olken
member orosco gonzalez here member patillo branson here member porter here member rodriguez
member rodriguez here member yoshimoto tarry here
all right terrific uh so we are continuing um our work on the mega assessment item a
mega accountability item and we are now uh ready to uh enter our sort of public comment and then
board discussion phase i'm going to ask vice president glover woods if she would like to make
framing comments before we go to public comment as she is our liaison for this item
thank you president darlin hammond and i'd like to first start my comments by thanking cindy and
her phenomenal team for the presentation we received today and all the work that went into
preparing this item and today's presentation so thank you cindy and thank you to everyone who
shared with us today and all those who were working behind the scenes uh just a few things
that i'd like to share as we get ready to go into public comment and that is that you know as we
know the areas that are covered in this particular item are very important as we align ourselves to
that principle of continuous improvement so what we want to always be sure that we're doing is
continuing to take action that's going to strengthen our accountability system so that
our lea's receive the data and the support that they need to best serve students so as we're
looking at the recommendations that were before us regarding providing links to the current science
assessment results and the teacher assignment data we know that's an important first step
to including access to these important sets of data on our dashboard and in addition ensuring
that our differentiated assistance eligibility criteria is utilizing the most current data that
we have for the 2022-23 school year is essential and needing to go to status only to ensure that
we can do that again is very important while our conversation regarding the definition of the
english learner student group for the academic indicator was for information only i believe it's
important to remember that we want to have as many schools as possible receiving a performance level
so that we can be sure that the el program in its entirety from initial designation through
reclassification is identified and reviewed for how it is best supporting english learners
equally important however is further exploration on how we can ensure that our lea's are able to
access and utilize the wealth of disaggregated english learner data that is currently available
with the goal of ensuring that we are identifying and meeting the needs as it relates to our long
term english learners as well as current english learners that are not progressing so i do look for
further discussion and information around how we can be sure that those needs are met and addressed
as well lastly before we go into public comment i just want to lift up the fact that communication
is key towards the end of the presentation and in the board item there is information about the
dashboard toolkit and it is very very important and i do hope everyone all the lea's and everyone
avails themselves of the flyers and the presentation slides and whatnot that are included
in the dashboard toolkit so that parents families community members are able to know how
the dashboard is structured for this year how to best access the data that they need so that they
can continue to be the educational partners they would like to be with our school system so with
that being said thank you again president darlin hamman and i look forward to public comment as
well as the board discussion that will follow afterwards terrific thank you so much i do
understand there are folks in the line for public comment we encourage you to please state your name
and affiliation for the record obviously using the phone number and participant access code
shown on the screen please remember to turn down the speaker volume of your computers if you're
following the live feed speakers will be limited to one minute each so we have our first caller
yes we currently have about 15 people in the queue i will open the phone lines now good
afternoon please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time
starts now caller you are live please start your public comment now
this is susanne couey of the charter schools development center cscc is extremely troubled
by a key point where the memo presents dashboard principle for value high values high performance
and growth equally we are extremely troubled that the accompanying description asserts that the
dashboard currently does reflect growth on all indicators this is not at all the case as you
members well know only lp is a growth metric change is not a growth metric and often doesn't
resemble growth at all the fewer students in the indicator the more growth differs from change
such as for student groups and small leas and schools failure to correct this ongoing confusion
of change with growth will undermine confidence in the dashboard and will undermine quality
decision making we urge the state board to provide direction to treat growth as growth
we should be measuring what matters and it is growth that matters we should also
discontinue the test and punish name and shame that is the primary basis for charter renewal
at this point thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the
record you have one minute your time starts now good morning my name is ruth barajas and i'm from
californians together i'm calling in to ask for more disaggregation of data for the academic
indicator while it is true that if we look at el's and rfp separately we will have lower numbers
with valid end sizes so less will receive the performance level for their english learner only
groups the truth is that performance level an lea or school may get under the current system
is meaningless since it hides the actual needs of el this is especially apparent when we look at
grades six through eight where more than half of english learners are not making adequate progress
learning english and they are also invisible let me repeat that more than half of english learners
are not making progress towards learning english and they are also invisible so if these students
are invisible identifying more leas or schools does not help to improve accountability without
visibility of the two groups how do they address the needs in their el caps el's generate funds
but they may not be allocated to meet the needs of el's this is wrong let's fix this thank you
thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you
have one minute your time starts now
caller ending in the last four digits 8820 you are live please start your public comment now
thank you good afternoon i'm carla santa cruz formerly known as iqc member carla herrera
i request the segregation of el and rff data for the academic indicator this will support lea's
including family's understanding of both progress and urgencies to establish priorities and allocate
resources i appreciate dr hakuta's presentation and share battle scars from decades as a bilingual
teacher and district el program specialist when i headed my district el assessments with
classification and monitoring procedures our team was always related with our rff students
high performance consistent with state trends however not all el students readily class we
classify at the same rate and need acceleration to avoid becoming long-term english learners
the current definition seems contrary to dashboard principle 2 it is neither fair nor equitable to
give credit while masking urgency to enhance el support let's celebrate reclassification but
not these eels based on the dashboard thank you thank you next caller please state your name and
affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
yes president darling hammon board members shelly spiegel colman californians together
in the name of continuous improvement your principle 10 we urge the board to revisit the
el definition of the academic indicator and the lp cut scores while we understand the rationale
that led to these decisions there's evidence that change is needed only two districts have
to include a goal for english learners in their 22 23 l caps only 46 lea's would be eligible for
differentiated assistance not even one district per county only nine school districts were very
low for the lp indicator there is a clear need to review the computations formulas and definitions
that diminish the urgency to close gaps and address goals programs and services
for english learners which delia pompa recently agreed to with us none of this was intended but
if we ignore the results then the equity intent of lcff and the dashboard principles being
considered by this board will not be reeled by thank you call your time is up next caller
please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
hello my name is crystal and i am with californians together and i'm calling in
to list a few recommendations the academic indicator must be revised to report english
learner only and we testify for an english proficiency proficiency separately for accountability
revise the lp cut scores convene lp community to review and advise the board and require
differentiated growth targets and sell caps to set expectations to close opportunity and
achievement gaps thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record your time starts now you have one minute
good afternoon my name is lucero chavez with the parent institute for quality education or bk
as a family engagement in education non-profit serving el populations across california we work
to empower parents to engage in the children's education and part of that engagement includes
having accurate information about the academic standing of the students to better target support
and advocate for funding today we want to emphasize the importance of disaggregating
english learners and reclassified english learners the academic indicator aggregating scores masks
real incomes and needs as an arfas myself i also know that students need to change as they become
proficient and tracking when they do help us better understand their journey to proficiency
and their potential need for support in the future we hope that you will ensure that the outcomes of
and needs of el students and other populations are clearly articulated so we can work together
to provide them with the support they deserve thank you for your time thank you next caller
please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hi patty chavez with seal sobrado early academic language thank you for the discussion and all
the presentations and focusing on the english learner subgroup for academic indicators this is
truly mega accountability and so proud of our state for that lens we do have opportunities though
to better serve el effectively and equitably for example 79 percent of el's and grades three to
eight have been with us for more than three years and only 16 percent are at the lowest english
language proficiency level we recommend that the state disaggregate the el only and the rfep data
in the academic indicator by including an el only subgroup we capture many students who can
demonstrate academic knowledge and incentivize districts to pay attention to students at risk
of becoming long-term el's as was discussed today by including a separate rfep group we also
recognize the progress lea's are making in reclassifying students and we can't forget our
parents they too have high expectations want their students to succeed but need data that is not
thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one
minute your time starts now hi i'm Todd Collins i'm a school board member here in Palo Alto
and also serve on your practitioner advisory group i shared more detailed written comments
with you earlier which i hope you have a chance to read and maybe even reply to
my main point is despite obviously good intentions our dashboard does not actually help school board
members and parents like me answer the most important questions about our districts where
we stand and whether we're actually improving i asked i've asked a large number of district leaders
board members and families from all over the state that they found the current dashboard
important in guiding their work and decision making i'm sorry to report that a large majority
say no a system of 84 separate color-coded measures is too complicated and confusing
it's well intended but impractical for regular people to use looking back over the documents
and listening to dr darling hamid it looks like we may have overreacted to weaknesses in the nclb
a composite measure does not have to be putative i know we can do better if we try thanks for the
opportunity to address you and thanks for your service to california's six million students
thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you
have one minute your time starts now
hi good afternoon my name is tara clark i work for the current county superintendent of schools
and i think one unintended consequence of the current system that we have is that two
three districts are required to set goals for el and few are designated for differentiated
assistance based on el performance we know that this identification does not match up with the
actual needs this year in current county where i live and work 83 percent of el did not meet
work 83 percent of el did not meet standards in math or science and 68 percent did not meet
standards in ela yet only two of the 48 districts within the county have been identified for
differentiated assistance for el which is less than five percent of all districts one school in
the county has been identified for atsi for el performance but no schools have been identified
for csi the data shows a clear gap in the quality of instruction provided for el and at kcsos we
have a knowledgeable dedicated multilingual education team eager to provide support for
districts and improving outcomes for el but unless the districts and schools are identified
updating support they will not take advantage of the resources we the county office can provide
without intentional changes to the district have in place the performance gap between el's and
el's will not close thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hi shay fairchild iqc alumni teacher on special assignment and case executive board member and
i'd like to thank the cde and state board for your passion and commitment to the students of
california your voice and action is critical to providing equitable opportunities for our
students in creating scientifically literate citizens we deeply appreciate your voice of
support and now we're asking for some action by placing a science icon on the dashboard
there's a precedence with college and careers that multiple years of data is not needed to
have the icon this single action will dramatically affect the trajectory and true implementation of
science across the state of california a large component of the else pack test is science and
if our students have not had science instruction how are they going to be successful with the
single action a shift will focus the shift will change between districts and site administration
to create opportunities to require scientifically literate students by graduation the future and
success of our state is dependent upon scientific literacy thank you thank you next caller please
state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hi i'm president of the california association of science educators i'm speaking on behalf of
a large coalition of science educators and organizations who submitted a letter to explain
our thoughts in detail we're grateful for the support of science indicator on the dashboard
expressed by president darling hammond and members rodriguez and lewis at the past two
state board members we're excited that science test data will finally be linked to the dashboard
we are asking that a science icon be placed on the dashboard that links to science data
this will send a clear signal to districts that science is a core subject area and ensure that
districts plan for science in their l caps varying science data in a drop down menu or tab will not
indicate that science is a priority having a strong science education for all students is vital to
provide equitable access for student career pathways it's also critical that california has
a science literate workforce and citizenry as president darling hammond expressed earlier
the need to understand climate change is especially critical thank you thank you next caller please
state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
my name is martha Hernandez representing californians together and we know that the
intent of the accountability system was to support continuous improvement and move away
from the punitive branding of schools with high numbers of english learners as failures
however after nearly a decade of lcff in examining the dashboard and analyzing l caps
it is clear that el accountability must be re-examined it is our hope that the board
reconsider the el definition for the academic indicator to disaggregate english learner only
and our best and provide them a color on the dashboard i direct your attention to the letter
submitted by dr pete goldschmidt who concludes that to recognize success and direct support
where needed it is best to disaggregate elos and rfx we also need to reevaluate the lp cut scores
to ensure we have high expectations for annual english proficiency growth we appreciate the
renewed attention to this issue and are hopeful that this attention will bring about improvements
that create more accountability for el thank you your time is up next caller please state
your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hi this is manuel bonrostro with californians together and i am calling in support of the
disaggregation of english learner only and rfx data in the el indicator and i also want to talk
a little bit about the issue of the stability of the english learner only group and things
that can be done and already built into the group that makes it a little more stable than
than folks might think first for english language arts we know that newcomer students and students
have been enrolled for 12 months or less currently take the test but are not included in the
calculations moreover the proportion of english learners enrolled for zero to three years
is around nine percent when we look at sixth grade and it's around that percent or lower when
we look at the at the upper grades we also understand the concerns about how disaggregation
might not accurately capture achievement however it is important to note that for for a lot of the
subject matter tests and here i'm going to talk about math specifically students that speak
spanish do have options to take the spanish math thank you your time is up thank you
next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time
starts now
hey my name is sheree scarer from the sabrata early academic language or sabrata sometimes there are
unintended consequences as we develop our accountability system the great news is that
we are practitioners of continuous improvement which means that we can revisit and make adjustments
based on new learning so what have we learned with our current system there are a few districts
being identified as for differentiated assistance however i was an administrator in a district
who went through federal program monitoring or fpm and decided we had a huge disconnect for
our english learner students even though our draft board results would indicate otherwise
in partnership with our leadership we took the time to disaggregate our data and look at where
some where some of the real issues were that we needed to face and went through the LCAP process
this was a courageous step in trying to close the achievement gap when based on the dashboard
leadership could have easily communicated we were doing fine having an accountability system that
is transparent may take additional steps but ultimately delivers the best sustainable solutions
and isn't that what we want for all of our students thank you thank you next caller please
state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon dr darlin hammon and board members diana bu on behalf of the association of california
school administrators actually would like to thank cd for their work on the communication
toolkit for the 2022 dashboard as cd continues developing the toolkit we would also request
additional resources on identification methodology for this differentiated assistance in regards to
the definition for english learner student groups actively including rx then the definition
showcases a holistic view of the of an leh el program and a wholesome account of the
el program and hold them accountable for supporting all of their el students furthermore
lea's have the ability to disaggregate their el data at a local level they can focus resources
on students that need it the most including rx as part of the definition the academic
academic indicator does not prevent this but does provide the state accountability and oversight of
the school school and district's el program if the state would consider changing the el definition
i actually want to ensure that the influence practitioners who directly oversee el programs
and interact with the students are included thank you thank you next caller please state
your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
madam president members this is eric premack with the charler school center
we're pleased to hear that california has gotten away from the archaic name and shame approach but
unfortunately it remains a central feature of the charler school renewal laws following ab 1505
and 2019 this ill-considered legislation was championed by the news and administration and
superintendent thurmond and we believe it's incumbent upon the administration the superintendent
and this board to work with us to fix this mess we're also concerned that the dashboard
is inappropriately punishing charter schools that are using their legal flexibility on
teacher credentialing and assignments and opposed placing this inaccurate data on the dashboard for
charter schools and hope that you will direct the department accordingly thank you thank you
next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time
starts now good afternoon this is sally fox representing the california association for
bilingual education when i was a district el resource teacher and later a county office
administrator i learned the definition of el for dual federal and state purposes
however now it's time to acknowledge that some consequences of the current definition
are having a negative impact in california one deficiency leads to a failure to identify districts
in which el's are not having sufficient success this is caused by district data dashboards that
conceal the performance of el's so districts mistakenly overlook the el student group that
in turn leads to missed opportunities for focused attention and resources since the dashboard is
used to complete the l cap surprisingly few districts are being identified for assistance
under the current definition there's a lack of urgency and perhaps a misconception that el needs
are being met when they are very likely not therefore cave urges the state board to find a
way to revise the el definition to more accurately represent conditions and more clearly inform and
guide our educators thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon board members john afro from public advocates public advocate supports the inclusion
of our febs in the measure of el accountability and agrees with the concern that a system that
only focused on the el-only population risks being over inclusive however we believe that
california's current system has swung the other way and is being under inclusive in identifying el
programs in need of differentiated systems our experience and that of our partners on the ground
indicates that there are more than just a handful of leas in the state that are not progressing their
el's quickly enough we urge the board to improve the accuracy of identifying for support and
assistance all the leas that are making inadequate progress ideas worth studying could include
building in student growth data perhaps reducing the number of years of our febs in the measure
separating the lp out as its own state indicator adding an ltl component to the model etc.
thank you has the obligation to break down the barriers to access for el's and we think we can
do that thanks next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have
one minute your time starts now
hey hi my name is mark lewin i'm a member of the california
the science educators legislative and environmental literacy committee
and currently the categorical programs coordinator for corning union or elementary school district
in rural far northern california as a science educator for more than 25 years i recommend that
science should be included on the main dashboard similar to how the english learner progress
is included clicking on the icon should lead directly to cast results i feel this is important
because in rural california where teachers often teach all subjects multi-grade administrators
and math training over science professional development with this change for the dashboard
will indicate and drive more attention to science teacher professional development training
and support for rural teachers to teach science well teaching science in rural areas will also
lead to thank you caller your time is up next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record you have one minute your time starts now
jessica saco on behalf of children now i refer you to the lcff equity coalition for our complete
comments regarding the proposed dashboard principles i urge the board to specifically
consider and modify principle 2 to address the closing of the achievement gap and principle
3 to ensure equal weighting of indicators does not become a barrier to the inclusion of future
state level indicators regarding science i thank you for taking this first step towards
the return of science to our state's accountability system we look forward to the coming years work
accountability system we look forward to the coming years work on the development of this
important indicator i'd like to give kudos to the team at cde and ctc for their collaboration
which made the teacher assignment monitoring outcome data possible including the links proposed
in this item regarding how english learners are reflected in our accountability system
i align myself with the comments from californians together and i urge the
board to continue to dig into this and consider the implementation implications of the current
definition finally the proposed cell phone bars we are concerned with this proposal as
full cell phone bars generally figure a desired result however this is not applicable for suspension
rate and chronic absence rates which made it confusing for the public thank you thank you
next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time
starts now hello madam president this is brian rebus calling on behalf of the education trust
two issues for you we agree with our colleagues in the lcff equity coalition about adding gap
closure to the dashboard principles we think that needs to be explicitly acknowledged and would be
useful whenever you and your colleagues consider changes to the dashboard to refer back to that
and it needs to be a reminder so that we can see accelerated growth for students who are lagging
behind their peers secondly we support the recommendations from our colleagues and partners
the california association of science educators to elevate the prominence of science results on
the dashboard we're disappointed by the level of implementation of ngss and science achievement
scores are low particularly for african-american and latino students and that shows up as a barrier
frequently needing access to a through g completion thank you thank you next caller
please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon president darlin hamlin and board members liz guiana public advocates for the lcff
equity coalition we object to the department's proposal to merely provide a link from the
dashboard to the data quest teacher reports this data quest report is definitely a treasure trove
but it may be confusing to dashboard users and further explanation to the dashboard user is
definitely needed depending on the size of your computer screen the summary table at the bottom
is more than a click away it is why we recommend that the department do more than provide a link
from the dashboard to the data quest report but actually cut and paste or copy the data quest
teacher summary report into the dashboard we also recommend that the board articulate a plan and
schedule for updating the priority one teacher standard early next year so that it fully reflects
all three components fully credentials properly assigned for the subject properly assigned for
the student population the statutory definition from the williams settlement we're very appreciative
departments to make all these data available and now we must begin using it for continuous improvement
thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one
minute your time starts now
hi this is leticia garcia on behalf of the riverside county superintendent of schools
and the 23 school district superintendents in riverside county we support staff's
recommendations to help identify eligible school districts for differentiated assistance for 22
23 school year only in addition we also continue to believe that the current definition for the
english learner student group which includes rfets best balances the needs of the students
in school district programs by ensuring that students are identified for support and rfets
continue to demonstrate proficiency all the while incentivizing school districts to work
towards achieving green and blue performance levels if they reclassify students thank you
for your time to make a comment thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for
the record you have one minute your time starts now good afternoon president barry hamlin and
members of the board liangela reid on behalf of the small school districts association i'd like
to thank the board and cindy cassandis and her team for a great discussion of the dashboard and
our accountability system was extremely helpful ssda would ask that as you move forward and further
developing the dashboard you continue to include our rfep students within the english learners
and don't disaggregate for small districts with small english learner populations we're concerned
that further decreasing the number of students will cause problems with inside and data accuracy
thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you
have one minute your time starts now my name is jenny snider chair of the curriculum and
instruction steering committee with success calling to support the cde's recommendation for this item
regarding the definition of the english learner student group discussion discussion we would like
to weigh in from a practitioner's perspective which is that we believe including rfps provides
a holistic picture of an lea's entire lea program through the work that we do facilitating improvement
coaching with districts we continuously observe that this work takes time and even though a student
may be reclassified the work needs to continue which aligns with dr hakuta's research shared
this morning including rfps in the definition helps lea evaluate the effectiveness of their el
program to ensure that when reclassified every english learner will continuously demonstrate
the knowledge and skills needed to succeed through graduation and beyond we respectfully request the
state continue to provide ample opportunities for lea input before changes to the dashboard
are made we would like to thank the cde staff for such a comprehensive presentation and their
leadership for the past two years without a dashboard thank you thank you next caller
please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hello my name is dr anya hurwitz executive director of field sabato early academic language
using a bell curve to set cut scores on the english language proficiency indicator does not
serve english learners and does not create an accountability system that is equity focused
research and state data tell us that it typically takes an english learner four to seven years to
reach a sufficient level of academic english proficiency to be reclassified that is why we
have six levels of progression on the lpac calculating performance based on students
moving up at least one level per year if the state's expected growth is at least one level
a year why would we be okay identifying districts as high performers if only 55 percent of their
el's are making that growth the cut scores scores are too low and are not aligned with the research
nor the state's interest in creating an equity focused system moving this forward means we
continue building systems that deny english learners the education they deserve thank you
thank you that concludes public comment for item number two
so we've had a robust public comment and discussion on some of these items i'd like to
ask cindy to put the resolution or the proposed recommendation in front of us again and i'd like
to suggest that this is going to some of these items are going to be long-term
items that we need to be talking about we do need to focus a little bit on this approval request
for the 2022 dashboard how to identify schools for schools and districts eligible for differentiated
assistance whether to include a link to the teacher assignment data and whether to include
a link on the dashboard to the science results so those are things that we need to make have a vote
about shortly there is still a lot of discussion to have about other items and but i'd like us to
focus on this i'd like us to ask the department to come back again in november for continued
discussion around the english learner representation of data i want just want to flag a few things i
heard in public comment that might focus some of what we look at in november in particular the
comments that were made by public advocates about the multiple ways in which we might be able to
identify eels who are not progressing fast enough for example adding lp as a an indicator
that is on the dashboard adding l tells in some fashion as an indicator i think i also heard the
concern about the definition of the category being associated with who needs to address el needs in
the l cap and set goals for eels and so there's a separate set of policies we have around
what needs to be taken into account in the l cap that also may be something we want to talk about
so just to sort of say there's a whole category of work to do there and to continue to
explore but if we could focus especially on the decision we have to make here first i think that
would help us keep the agenda moving along and with that i'd love to open the floor to board
discussion
i do want to say and i will call on member of the school gonzalez in one second that just to frame
these particular items that we need to talk about obviously there's interest in getting the data
from the teacher assignment data and the science visible and the proposals for a link that's one
thing that we they want to talk about the other is not being able to use progress or change data
this year and using the low status level as a proxy for red which i would think we want to take
up very explicitly as an interim step not as something we would be continuing in the future
once we have this data the change data again member of us gonzalez you can kick us off here
i just had a quick clarifying question i see that the item three include a link on the dashboard
to the science results that is supported through the casp website i know a lot of support came in
for science to be included as a graphic on the main dashboard is that something we can revisit
in november
i think the question might be cindy
what are what can you tell us about the decision to what whether it's possible to have an icon so
that we would know whether it's useful to agendize that of course so the proposal before you today is
is to add links to the assessment results we have reserved the use of an icon for things that have
been vetted on the technical level and because we don't have two years of data to establish
not only what we look for to establish status is we're usually looking for a baseline and then
an additional year so absent that additional year of data the department would not recommend
adding an icon because it means something more than what we're able to provide at this point in
time it is absolutely you know on our radar for future dashboards so i would say this is the first
step in a very long process the difference between this and something like the lp is the lp had
established data so we were able to really support the technical aspects behind it that work has not
been done on the science results whatsoever and we would not be able to do that simply because
of lack of data and also just the timing even if we did have it for november so
i think the the import of the questions that i heard or the comments is that people want it to be
visible so i guess the a key may be how i we i don't we don't know what it would look like but
that it'd be obvious even even though it may not have a traditional icon yet of course and i think
you know what what kim talked extensively about and i know that member glubber woods also really
tried to elevate is that we have a toolkit that we are rolling out and we will absolutely have
something that is specialized for science and so if it means that we need to highlight it through
our webinar series which i'm sure we will you know be including those are other ways of of getting it
out i don't have a way to show you the link on the dashboard at this point in time i'm happy
to bring that piece back in november but we are really at this point really running out of time
and i'm providing you options that are feasible within the time frame that we need to get this
information out to the field and the dashboard is usually released in december so when cindy refers
to time that's the time frame she is referring to yeah and i think it's a good idea to start
just at least introducing it in the webinar series like you mentioned cindy so i think
just so that educators have an access to it or at least are aware how to navigate the system
to be able to then look at the data that is available for them to then use it for their
instruction thank you any other questions or comments especially focused at the moment on the
recommendation
uh member glover woods um if there is no further discussion i am ready to make a motion
uh sharon do you member oaken do you have a further discussion you want to have before the motion
yes thank you you saw me trying to find my yeah find my icon for some reason when when your
seal is on the left your hand is right in the middle of it so it's a little hard to see
yeah i messed up yeah i'm sorry about that no worries no um so i um thank you for
it was i really appreciate all the public comment and um it's clear how the more we try to measure
um which is important because we want to have multiple measures of student and school success
the more complicated this gets right and so it's um i appreciate the many perspectives about all
that we're trying to elevate um and also in terms of our um in terms of our dashboard and also
wanting to make sure that the data is really um vetted and ready so it's i i hear the i hear
that tension um i wanted to just comment on um the implications um of these proposals the potential
implications of these proposals for um charter schools and i i my understanding of this is it's
really a potential implication um so for example there are two things i wanted to just elevate um
one is the using red for a proxy or using using um the height sorry using the lowest status level
as a proxy for red um so um that makes sense and i'm i'm i'm i appreciate us getting back
getting back to a place in this state where um we can provide the support
where for school for schools and districts and counties that need it um i have some concern
about the implication that could have on charter renewal through the new 1505
process um and i think that's just an outstanding question about how that how that would affect
charter renewal um and then similarly the link to the teacher assignment data um charter schools
at this point have some flexibility um because of new rules that were implemented as part of 1505
and so that data will be public and on the dashboard through a link before charter schools
are being actually held accountable for it while we're still in this grace period
and i want to i i have some concerns about the potential impact that could have on both charter
renewal and perception of schools as they're working through this process um i feel like that
those two issues are important to raise um but i also think the data that we're talking about is
important to highlight so i just wanted to put those forward and maybe i could ask if there
any thoughts at this point about how to mitigate those potential concerns
so that's going to be a long conversation i'll give cindy a chance to offer any short
answer she'd like to to that it could be if and i'll just note that uh even as uh as it exists now
uh charter schools do have the opportunity to use other measures in their charter renewal um
processes um including diagnostic tests and other things like that that on which they can show
growth as well as status and that is part of the charter renewal
affordances um so the dashboard exists but it is not the only thing that is used
cindy do you want to add anything to that sure um i just more i think along the lines of um
the communication around charter schools for 2022 we are working internally to develop
a letter to the field from myself and from the charter school division director stephanie farland
to just talk about the 2022 school year and the release of the dashboard we have gotten several
inquiries especially from places that have a lot of charters to to look at and with the absence of
performance levels um pieces of 1505 cannot be implemented so uh you know in the absence of
state data there are metrics in 1505 that provide um districts the ability to look at um you know
local data and so we will be getting out of communication uh this fall specifically around
around those those pieces and and how to help both the charter school community and um and
districts who are looking at charter schools for renewal on the larger issue around the teacher
teaching assignment monitoring outcomes data if you look at those reports there is some specific
language there around charter schools that were put put into that um that report to specifically
address this issue i would um would say that when we look to 2023 and looking at charter schools and
the inclusion of priority one um the there is not an exception exception within that piece of
legislation which is different from 1505 so the williams reauthorization did not include an
exemption for charter schools and so that's um on top of you know this piece of legislation that
is impacting um priority one there's just there's a lot going on in this space and so we will
absolutely been be um working with um the the charter schools associations on on steps from
moving forward but it is absolutely something that is on our radar so we will continue to
monitor and elevate that um those issues thank you so much or i just know that i'm just go ahead
member i was just gonna say i also appreciate that the the guidance is i mean we're all this is new
for all of us on every level right and so i appreciate that in all of in all of these things
we're talking about that the ongoing education and guidance is really going to be crucial so
thank you so much for that work that you're doing and i was just gonna note that the board
prior to the arrival of our newest members did receive a briefing about the multiple measures
that can be used by charters and we approved a list of measures that are alternative measures
for measuring for looking at growth as well as status so that's somewhere in the
board history and i'm sure that somebody could produce the um the data on that i mean the
conversation on that for those who are interested um great the other thing i want to just say about
this first piece which is using the lowest status levels of proxy for red is not what any of us
would like to have to do it is really not in the spirit of our accountability system to
ignore growth and progress as something we'd like to do but we just don't have that and the
department of education requires us to continue to implement our you know this aspect of the system
for differentiating assistance etc i'm gonna just take a moment and quote from a letter we
got from dr cardona miguel cardona secretary of the us department of education yesterday
reminding everyone who is looking at these data this year to who report and interpret student
outcomes this year that assessment data should be used constructively to help inform parents
and families about students schools and ensure they receive necessary resources to help support
students and support our communities encountering efforts to use the results by applying them
punitively so we're all aware that this is not an ideal moment for you know preserving all of the
intentions of the system but we want to be sure that we are using the data to give information
and to support the future progress from from this point in time and the ability to measure it again
next year any other comments or questions if not maybe we can go back to vice president
glover woods for a motion well thank you i don't see any other hands up for board discussion and
i just wanted to underscore president darling ham in a statement that you made earlier around
us really having an opportunity in november to delve more into the english learner data
and how we are insured how we will ensure that our english learner student performance is
accurately shown and addressed within our system i think there are a lot of great ideas and you
highlighted a couple and i look forward to that discussion so that we can be sure that we're
able to meet both goals if you will of our accountability system so i'd like to now move
forward and present a motion to the board i move that we approve the cde recommendation as follows
that we approve using the lowest status level as a proxy for red as reported on the 2022 dashboard
to determine the differentiated assistance eligibility for county offices and districts
also that we include a link on the dashboard to the teacher assignment data that is supported
through data quest and also include a link on the dashboard to the current science results
that's supported through the cast website
i second that thank you very much any further discussion
oh we'll call the roll oh is there further discussion yes yes i just wanted to thank
cd for all of the work on this topic and i appreciate revisiting the reclassification
in november and thank you for everything and the toolkit is fabulous i appreciate that being in
there as well props for the toolkit all right bricks can you call the roll for a vote
president darlin hammond aye member escobedo aye vice president glover woods yes member lewis
yes member mcquillan yes member olken yes member arosas
member patilo brownson yes member porter yes member rodriguez yes member yoshimoto taury yes
a motion passes unanimously
All right, thank you, and we are going to move on to item number four.
We're going to take up the California Assessment of Student Performance and Progress System
and English Proficiency Assessments for California Update, and the item will be presented by
Mao Vang of the CDE, but we will first hear from Cheryl Cotton, and please begin.
Superintendent Thurman, President Darling-Hammond, Vice President Glover-Woods, and board members.
I'm Cheryl Cotton, Deputy Superintendent of the Instruction, Measurement, and Administration
Branch.
To assist with this item, I have Dr. Mao Vang, Director of Assessment Development and Administration
Division to co-present, as well as Vigdis Asmunson, Science Office Administrator of
the Assessment Development and Administration Division, and Chad Portney, English Language
Arts and Mathematics Office Administrator of the Assessment Development and Administration
Division.
In addition, Marianne Arcila, Executive Director for the Educational Testing Service, and
Tony Alpert, Executive Director from Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium, are here
to present or to assist with questions for this item.
The item before you today is an action and information item.
Today's presentation will cover the following.
We will provide an overview of the California Department of Education's recommendation
for approval, the proposed California Alternate Assessment, or CAA, for science threshold
scores, the Smarter Balanced Summative Assessments for English Language Arts Literacy, or ELA,
and Mathematics Adjusted Forms Blueprints, and the 2022-23 California Assessment of Student
Performance and Progress, or the CASP, and the English Language Proficiency Assessments,
or California, the LPAC, Student School Reports, or SSRs.
Then we will go over some of our CASP and LPAC updates, as well as an update on national
and international assessments.
In this section, I will provide an overview for the CDE's recommendation for approval.
CDE recommends that the California State Board of Education, or SBE, approve the following.
The SSPI's proposed threshold scores for CAA for science, the continued use of the
Adjusted Form Blueprints for the Smarter Balanced Assessments for ELA and Mathematics, and
the CASP and LPAC SSRs for 2022-23.
Now I'll have Vigdis S. Munson, Administrator for the Science Office, present the request
for approval of the proposed California Alternate Assessment for Science threshold scores.
Thank you.
Hello. Hello, President Darling-Hammond, Vice President Glover-Woods, and Board Members.
My name is Vigdis S. Munson, the Science Office Administrator of the Assessment, Development,
and Administration Division. I'm very excited to be here with you today to ask for approval
of the CAA for science recommended threshold scores.
As mentioned, joining me today to assist with any questions you might have is our ETS colleague,
Marianne Arsilla, the Executive Director of ETS California Programs.
The CAA for science was developed to comply with the following requirements. It's administered
pursuant to the California Education Code, Section 60640, and is part of the Every Student
Succeeds Act of 2015, the ESSA. It's aligned with alternate achievement standards. They're
called the Science Core Content Connectors, and they are linked to the performance expectations
from the California Next Generation Science Standards, the CA and GSS, using the SBE-approved
alternate general achievement level descriptors and the score reporting structure.
The work accomplished during the CAA for science standard setting process was guided
by these board-approved achievement level descriptors and will be provided to the U.S.
Department of Education as part of the federal peer review of this new assessment.
The CAA for science is part of the CASP system of assessments. It's designed to measure
what students know and can do in science. This helps identify and address gaps in knowledge
or skills early so that students can receive the support that they need. Only students
with the most severe cognitive disabilities are eligible to participate in the administration
of the CAA for science. To be eligible to take the assessment, the student's individualized
education program, their IEP team, must determine that the student should take that alternate
assessment. The CAA for science actually consists of four embedded performance tasks that are
each administered online throughout the year, shortly after the student receives instruction
on that related science content. The test is administered one-on-one to the student
by a test examiner who knows them best, and it is administered to eligible students in
grades five and eight and once while they are in high school. That could be in grade
10, 11, or 12. The recommendation that we are bringing to you today represents the work
over the past years leading up to this request for approval of these threshold scores. In
July 2016, the development for the CAA for science began with the SBE approval of the
high-level test design. The SBE then approved the CAA for science blueprint, general achievement
level descriptors, and reporting hierarchy in January 2018. In the 2019-20 school year,
due to the COVID-19 pandemic, all California testing was suspended, which did cause some
delays to the development of the test. In the 2020-21 school year, LEAs administered
the CAA for science operational field test year one. The 2020-21 administration was intended to
be the sole operational field test. However, the number of students who completed testing
wasn't sufficient to reflect a typical instructional year that would provide the necessary impact
data to establish the recommended threshold scores. Therefore, the finalization of the
threshold scores was postponed until we could collect and use the more robust impact data
from the 2021-22 CAA for science administration. In August 2021, the CAA for science standard
setting workshop with California special education and science educators was conducted.
In 2021-22, the CAA for science operational field test year two was administered. So this brings
us to today's request for approval of the CAA for science recommended threshold scores.
As described in attachment three of the item, the panelists comprised a diverse group of 28
experienced California educators, most of them had more than 10 years of teaching experience,
who represented science educators across California teaching students who take the CAA for science.
They represented varied ethnicities from across California, and they included the perspectives
of classroom teachers and LEA or county employees. Lastly, they brought their final approval of the
CAA for science performance task items. The panelists then reviewed the general and range
achievement level descriptors, the ALDs, in order to define the knowledge and skills of each
threshold student. I'll give you a further description of that on the next slide.
Based on these threshold student definitions, the CAA for science performance task items were
identified as the CAA for science performance task items. The CAA for science performance task
items were identified as the CAA for science performance task items. Based on these threshold
student definitions, using the modified and extended Angoff methods, which are the best
practices as defined by the standard setting literature, the panelists made two rounds of
judgments on the likelihood that students at the threshold would answer each item correctly
with discussion between rounds. For the CAA for science, similar to the CAAs for ELA and math,
there are three achievement levels. Level one is limited understanding,
level two is foundational understanding, and level three is understanding. Therefore,
two threshold scores were needed for each grade level or grade span. Using the ALDs, panelists
defined the knowledge and skills of the threshold student for levels two and three. In other words,
they explained what does achievement look like for a student who is just into level two or just into
level three. That is the solid pink character here for level two and the solid blue character
for level three. Those threshold student definitions are also referred to as threshold ALDs.
These descriptions are extremely important tools that the panelists use to make their
recommended threshold score judgments. The panel recommendations based on standard
setting judgments are presented in table two of attachment two of this item.
After the CDE's review of the panelists' judgments, the CDE consulted with select
CASP technical advisory group, our TAG members, and assessment interest holder groups who
represent California educational associations. These reviews resulted in minor adjustments to
the panelists' judgments and yielded the proposed state superintendent of public
instructions recommendations provided in table one of attachment two.
The data on this slide represents the state superintendent of public instructions recommendations
for the threshold scores on the overall score for the CAA for science.
During the process of establishing threshold scores, we used a temporary standard setting
scale. Following SBE approval, these thresholds will then be applied to the reporting scale,
which are the values that are presented on the student score reports.
The threshold scores were applied to CAA for students for science student performance data
from the 2021-22 operational field test administration. To maintain fidelity with the
work of the standard setting panel, the state superintendent of public instruction recommended
thresholds are within one conditional standard error of measurement of the panel's recommendations.
All adjustments are within that natural error variance of the panel's recommended thresholds
and that only reflect slight modifications of those judgments.
The percentage of students is a percent of students statewide who would be placed at this
achievement level on the basis of the results of the 2021-22 operational field test administration.
And the standards setting scale threshold is referring to the minimum standard setting
scale score needed to achieve this achievement level on the basis of the results
of the 2021-22 operational field test administration.
Upon the SBE's approval of the state superintendent of public instruction's recommended CAA for
science threshold scores, the CDE will next notify LEA superintendents and charter school
administrators of the approved threshold scores and the timeline regarding the CAA for science
student score reports. The CDE and ETS will perform a quality control process to evaluate
the data and ensure that the information on the CAA for science student score reports is
reported accurately. And finally, when all of that is complete, the student score reports
will be delivered to LEAs to share with parents and guardians in December 2022.
Next, I will hand this presentation over to Chad Portney.
Hello, Superintendent Thurman, President Darling-Hammond, Vice President Clever Woods,
and board members. My name is Chad Portney. I'm the English Language Arts and Mathematics
Office Administrator in the Assessment Development and Administration Division.
I will present for your approval the continued use of the Smarter Balanced
Adjusted Form Blueprints and revisions to the 22-23 student score reports.
In November 2020, the SBE approved the initial use of the Adjusted Form Blueprints for the 2020-2021
administration. In September 2021, the SBE approved the continued use of the Adjusted Form
Blueprints for the 21-22 administration. The CDE now recommends that the SBE approve the use
of the Adjusted Form Blueprints for 22-23 and subsequent administrations until the consortium
approves any further changes to the blueprint. The proposed 22-23 blueprints, Adjusted Form
Blueprints, are identical to the blueprints used in the 21-22 administration.
The Adjusted Form Blueprints offer several advantages over the full-form blueprints.
With the Adjusted Form Blueprints, the computer-adaptive portion of the test
of each assessment is reduced by approximately 50% in each claim compared to the full-form
blueprints. This reduces the testing time of this portion of the test by approximately 50%.
It should be noted, however, that the performance tasks, also known as PTs,
are not adjusted and remain the same. The Adjusted Form Blueprints reduce the overall
testing time for students in schools while providing a valid measure of student achievement
in ELA and mathematics. Other benefits of the Adjusted Form Blueprints include increased
instructional time, more flexibility in scheduling and administration of assessments,
and reduced risk of network and connectivity issues.
The Adjusted Form Blueprint has fewer items than the full-form blueprint. The details of
each blueprint can be found in the tables included in the item. The fewer number of items does impact
which subscores can be reported for the Smarter Balanced Assessments for ELA and Mathematics.
Due to the fewer number of items on the Adjusted Form Blueprint, student-level claims are not
available on the Student Score Reports or SSRs or in the California Educator Reporting System,
also known as CSRS. Aggregate claim results are available only for student groups of 30 or more
in public reporting. Target reporting will continue to be unavailable in CSRS and Smarter
Balanced is working with WestEd and Member States in the development of composite claim
reporting for the Adjusted Form Blueprint. Although individual claim results for students
in ELA and Mathematics will not be available on the summative assessments, student claim information
is provided with the results of the Smarter Balanced Interim Comprehensive Assessments
that are available to all LEAs. Next, I'll present for your approval the revision of the 22-23
Student Score Reports for the CASP and the LPAC. The main change to the CASP and LPAC
Student Score Reports is the update to the academic year. Examples of Student Score Reports
are provided in Attachment 4. For the SSRs for the Smarter Balanced Summative Assessments in ELA and
Mathematics, the CDE proposes the return of comparison language on the SSRs for the Smarter
Balanced Summative Assessments for ELA and Mathematics. This language compares a student's
current year performance to their performance on the assessment in a prior year. In addition,
due to the Adjusted Form Blueprint, claim results will continue to not be reported on SSRs.
The CDE proposes removing information regarding claim categories in order to remove information
regarding subscores that is not being reported and improve clarity to parents and guardians.
Other updates of the SSRs include school and state averages will remain suppressed on CASP
SSRs. Traditionally, these averages have been calculated using a three-year rolling average.
Due to the suspension of testing in 2019-20 and low testing volumes for the CASP in 2021,
using a three-year rolling average still does not provide an insightful measure from which to analyze
22-23 data and student achievement. Korean will be added as a new reporting language on all CASP
and LPAC SSRs. SSRs will also continue to be available in English, traditional Chinese,
Filipino, Spanish, and Vietnamese. All CASP and LPAC SSRs with updates are attached to the item.
Now I'll turn the presentation over to Mao Vang to cover the additional program updates. Thank you.
Thank you, Chad. Good afternoon. I'm Mao Vang. I'm the director for the assessment development
and administration division at the California Department of Education.
Deputy Superintendent Cheryl Cotton, President Arlene Hammond, Vice President Glover Woods,
and esteemed board members, thank you for this time for me to present these additional
assessment program updates for you in regard to the assessment programs.
I will cover some new professional learning resources, some science and LPAC interim
assessment timeline, and our national and international assessments for the year.
First off, I'd like to give you a quick update on a new set of professional learning resources
that's available through the Tools for Teachers website. This series is titled Effective School.
Home Partnerships was developed by Learning Heroes in collaboration with the Technology
Access Foundation and the California Department of Education. The series has been added to Tools
for Teachers to assist our teachers and other local educational agency staff in communicating
with students and their families about student data. So it consists of four modules that are
designed to be used by individual educators and as part of our professional learning community.
Module one is titled Building Trust with Families. It focuses on authentic strength-based
relationship building. Module two is titled Sharing Data with Families. This module focuses on
communicating data in ways that are respectful, honest, and actionable. And module three
is titled Multiple Measures and Goal Setting. This module focuses on using multiple measures
to have a shared understanding of progress in reaching co-created goals. Then module four
is titled Navigating Difficult Conversations. It focuses on building trusting relationships
that allow for productive communication. So each module includes a learning guide
and a facilitator video notes to help facilitate the embedded small group activities and
self-reflection and a set of videos demonstrating examples of less effective and more effective
communication styles. And this professional learning series is available for all LEA or
local educational agency staff through the Tools for Teachers website as I mentioned.
And of course the Tools for Teachers offer many resources for educators to help implement the
formative assessment process and support and improve teaching and learning in the classroom.
Next, during this school year, the 2022-23, the CDE and its testing contractor ETS are developing
the interim assessments for both the LPAC, the English Language Proficiency Assessments,
for California and the science programs. And these two sets of interim assessments
for each of the programs I just mentioned. So the first set will be developed for this
school year and then the second set will be developed for the next school year, the 2024-25.
The interim assessments will provide educators with a means of measuring student progress to
support teaching and learning which is aligned to the interim assessments that are already approved
and provided for English Language Arts and Mathematics. So each set of the LPAC interim
assessments will include individual domains, domain tests for each grade or grade span.
And then the science interims has three science assessment blocks per grade band
which will be offered as well.
So another highlight is that I would like to update you on the upcoming national and international
assessments involving students in our California public schools this school year. The following
national and international assessments will be administered. One is the National Assessment of
Educational Progress or NAEP. We have many acronyms but we'll spell them out for you.
The International Computer and Information Literacy Study or we call it ISOL. The Program
for International Student Assessment or PISA. And the Trends in International Mathematics and
Science Study or TIMS. All these assessments are administered by field staff contracting with the
National Center for Education Statistics. And in this table of the national and international
assessments for the 2022-23 school year it lists the assessments in their administration windows,
the age or grade level of students to be assessed and the number of California public schools
that are being sampled. So first for NAEP, they will administer the long-term trend assessment
this fall to 13-year-old students in approximately 55 California public schools. NAEP will also
administer a field test in spring 2023 to students in grades 4, 8 and 12 from 45 schools.
And PISA is coming this fall to assess 15-year-olds from about 30 schools.
And then next spring ISOL will assess a sample of eighth graders from about 25 schools.
And TIMS is also coming next spring. A sample of students grades 4 and 8 from about 65 schools
will be assessed. And school sampling is mindful to prevent schools from being sampled for more
than one of these assessments. And the student sample size from each school ranges from about
50 to 60. And that kind of brings us towards the end of our presentation. I'd like to remind you
that if to follow our assessment Twitter account at CDE assessments. And at this point I'd like to
stop to see if you have any clarifying questions. And I'll turn it back to our
board president, Linda Darling-Hammond. Thank you very much. Appreciate the presentation.
We are going to put up, let's put up the public comments slide so that anyone who wants to make
a public comment can queue up by and get ready to call in with the dial-in number that's listed
there using the participant access code that is listed there. And while we're waiting for people
to get ready for public comment, I want to call on my colleague liaison member Arusco Gonzalez
if there's any initial comments. If there are clarifying questions, we could take those and
then we'll go to public comment. Well, I think that one of the things I've been
just reviewing some of my notes from our meetings that we've had and I'm just pleased to see the
benefits of the adjusted form blueprints. For instance, I think the reduction of testing time
will definitely ensure that we have a reduced risk of network and connectivity issues. At my
school, even in Montebello Unified, we had sometimes problems with wi-fi and the students
felt very frustrated by that. So I think that by reducing the time, it's going to be beneficial
to our students. I also like the reducing of number of questions in the computer adaptive
portions of the test. It shortens the overall length of the test and reduce testing time.
The shorter testing blocks will also give teachers and schools additional flexibility
on how they administer these state tests. And there's just quite a few things that I think are
so beneficial from this presentation and this item. I really like the home partnerships
that were developed for the four modules focusing on building trust with families,
sharing data with families, and just overall building trust and partnerships in our community
is always key to the success of our students. And I think that this is the right step in the
direction of making our assessments meaningful to our communities and to our students and
for teachers to use to guide instruction. Thank you. I see a clarifying question coming from
member Patil Brownson. Hi. So I wanted to ask one question around sort of the time frames.
So when this item came to us previously, it was a one year extension for the Adjusted Form
Blueprint. And the language of the recommendation ties this to ongoing work with consortium. So
we can hear a little bit about what the consortium's expected timeline is around changes
and sort of the rationale for tying it to the consortium's decision making.
And then the second question is around the suppression of the data around state and school
averages. So in the many hats that I wear, I am also a parent. And I've definitely seen
parents and teachers and administrators and counselors use this data in order to talk through
course placements, in order to talk through areas for improvement and development and exactly the
sort of data sharing with families that was described in Learning Heroes. So part I think
of what I'm trying to understand is the data that a student gets that comes home is one year data.
And so I think the rationale that was described for not having
statewide or school comparison data is that three year comparative data isn't available.
But the data that the student is getting, in fact, is not three year data, either. I'm delighted
that there's going to be an inclusion now of past year, sort of a student can actually track
progress, growth, or a downward trend, because that's, I think, very helpful.
But we'd want to hear a little bit more about what the rationale for
requiring three years versus one for the state and school averages.
All right. Mal, two questions to you.
Yes. As Chad mentioned, I'll address the average, the three year average first. And then I do have
Tony Albert here. Perhaps he can say a little bit about the adjusted blueprints and the work
involving that. So in terms of the averages on the student's score report, the three year averages,
it is because, as Chad mentioned, we don't have any data for 2020. That year the testing was
suspended. So there's no data there. In the 21 year, there's a small percentage of students
who test it. We have some 20-some percent in English and math versus the 90-some percent on
a normal year. So the averages would not be very meaningful. So that's why we're recommending just
taking that portion out of the student score report and showing it on the student score report
so that it doesn't confuse our reading. Mal, I think the question is, if we're using one
year of data for students, could we use one year of data for state comparison also? Is that right?
Yes, for states and other schools. I can't remember if it was other schools or other districts.
I think it's district maybe. Anyway, I think your question is, if we're using one year of data for
the student, why can't we use one year data for the other? Why couldn't we use the one year of
state and or district data for comparison? The issue here is that the student score reports are
produced before the entire year's data is computed. We start putting student score
reports out two to three weeks after a student completes testing. We don't know the school and
the statewide averages until later in August when we get all the data from ETS. By that time,
we've already started putting score reports out into the field. Yeah, and I certainly know a lot
of people have gotten their score reports for their students. I think that's that one answer.
And then, Member Patia Bronson, do you want to just clarify what it is you wanted to know about
the reduced form? About the consortium's role in making a recommendation for future changes
and if there's a timeline that they're already forecasting in terms of when changes would happen
to give us a sense of whether we're signing off for this to be the new format for five,
ten years or whether this is like the one year extension and the consortium has this on their
agenda to look at the short form? Hello, for the record, this is Tony Elpret, Executive Director
for the Smarter Balances Assessment Consortium. We don't have a plan to change any of the adjusted
blueprints at this point. We are just receiving the data from California and other members of
the consortium. At that point, we'll be able to do the detailed analyses that we had hoped to do
in prior years, but testing was not consistent and didn't provide enough data to make any evaluative
judgments about the efficacy of the blueprint. Any such changes would be presented for a
consortium-wide vote for which California has a strong role. Any state can stop an action.
All the consortium's actions are based on consensus and if it did pass, then we would be
providing information to Mao Vang and her assessment staff in support of
this body's deliberation on those proposed changes.
Thank you. Any other clarifying questions? If not, we will go ahead and move to public
comment and then we'll have plenty of time for discussion when we come back.
Member Yoshimoto, Tari, is it a clarifying question?
It's a brief clarifying question. I believe it was Chad mentioned the use of the interim
comprehensive assessment that gives results at the claim or the target level and the shorter
form of the summative assessment not doing so. Chad, is it true that the ICA is at the original
length of the original summative assessment, so it's actually at the longer form still,
or has that been shortened also, or are there plans to shorten it?
No, you're correct. The interim comprehensive assessment is still based on the full blueprint.
The other thing is that, of course, when you have multiple students, you can still provide
data to a district about how students performed at the claim level. So if you wanted to know,
for example, if there are very many claim categories, but if students were continuing
to progress on problem solving in math, you could see that at an aggregated level.
All right. Let's move to public comment and then we'll come back for discussion.
Do we have any public comment? Yes. We currently have three people signed up
in the queue for public comment. I will open the phone line now.
Caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Yes, this is Shelly Spiebel-Coleman from Californians Together. We would just like to
thank the department for continuing to develop the student report forms in multiple languages and
appreciate the adding of Korean and look forward to other languages being added. And then we
particularly are grateful for the work on interim assessments for the LPAC, which has been so,
so needed for teachers and schools to be able to see how students are doing learning English
along the year and not just at the end for the LPAC. So thank you very much.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Michael Jubba and I'm a classroom teacher representing
the California Teachers Association. CTA strongly supports the CDE's recommendation
to continue to use the shorter adjusted blueprints for the Smarter Balanced Summative
Assessments ELA and Mathematics for the 22-23 administration and beyond. The CDE's recommendation
will provide several benefits for students and teachers. First, reducing the number of questions
in the computer adaptive portions of the test will shorten the overall length of the test
and reduce testing time. Second, shorter testing blocks will give teachers and schools additional
flexibility in how they administer the state assessments. And finally, we believe that the
most accurate and actionable indicators of an individual student's mastery of standards
will come from the multiple local measures used by teachers that are embedded within the classroom.
Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You
have one minute. Your time starts now. Good afternoon. Jessica Sacco on behalf of Children
Now. I refer you to the LCFS Equity Coalition letter for our complete comments on this item.
Firstly, we urge the board to reject the proposed action to continue administration of the
abbreviated version of the Smarter Balanced Assessment for the following reasons. First,
as expressed by member Patilio Brownson, students, families, and educators need accurate and detailed
results, including claim scores in order to inform information about a student's learning.
Secondly, the implications of the suggested blueprint on the growth model is still unknown,
particularly how the reduced position of this assessment will affect the calculation of a
residual gain score amongst small groups of students. The state has taken significant
measures to ensure that this growth model increases accuracy and we are concerned that
the suggested blueprint works counter to that. And finally, we are concerned that less testing
time may actually lead to more testing time as local districts and schools are not obtaining the
detailed information that they need in order to make decisions about students and may therefore
be forced to administer additional assessments. Thank you. Thank you. That concludes public
comment for item number four. Thank you very much. Appreciate all of the comments and now we
want to open this up for board discussion. And if you could put the resolutions, the recommendations
up on the slide again, that would be helpful. So we have the threshold scores for the California
Alternative Assessment for Science, the use of the adjusted form blueprints for Smarter Balanced,
and the Casp and Eel Efficiency Assessments Student Score Reports. And we'll start with Member Porter.
So thank you so much to staff for this detailed presentation and your work to measure students
performance. So to add a student perspective from someone whose peers have taken the CASP test
before the adjusted blueprints in 2019 and experienced the 2022 adjusted version,
I am very appreciative of this recommendation to continue using the adjusted blueprints. I can
attest that many students often felt fatigued after sitting in front of a screen for hours,
which reduced our attentiveness as well as our performance. And in relation with technical
use, I think what Gonzalez was saying was evident. And thank you for your attention
to students' mental health and continued commitment to measuring students' performance
efficiently. Thank you. Any other discussion? Member Patio-Bronson? Yeah, I think I'm very,
I think sympathetic to the rationale around wanting to have less testing time, especially
on the heels of so many school closures and lost direct instructional time. And it makes sense as,
and previously made sense on the prior two votes that this board has taken,
to prioritize scarce time, precious time that we have with students for learning time and
instructional time. So again, thinking of it as a pandemic measure in many ways made a lot of sense.
I think hearing that both there's an effort to still understand the efficacy of using
the shorter form blueprint and also realizing how much we have compacted the information that's
available to families and to communities gives me a lot of pause about having this recommendation
be not a one-year extension related to the pandemic, but it continued use until the date
uncertain. Part of why I was asking about the consortium timeline for consideration, I think
Mao's answer was primarily around the process for what the consortium might consider, but not
really what the timeline would be. And at a moment when many families are trying to figure out how to
help accelerate learning for their children and how to move past the pandemic, I think families
need more information, not less. And so the two pieces I think that pick out most prominently for
me is not having point in time, same as you have for student data, one-year information around
school district averages and state averages, which we talked about a little bit. And I don't think
I really heard much of a rationale for why a three-year average is powerful for school districts,
but not for individual students or is the necessary metric to consider.
And more importantly, I think knowing what the long-term efficacy of the short form
would be strikes me as relevant information before we adopt this as a continued and permanent part
for our CASP system. So I would be very open to, and I'm not, I guess I'm proposing potentially
two amendments to query whether it would be possible to add back in and ask and work with
our test administrators to get us, for example, school district average information so that it
could go out with family assessment reports in the next administration of the test. I think we've,
I mean, I at source reported school district level data of CASP scores, so I think there must
be some early indications of what school district level data is looking like that we could draw from,
again, to help better inform the decisions that families are needing to make
about what, for example, junior high they apply to for their kids' school or what high school.
And these are important and scarce resources that I think parents are looking for.
Let's take those two issues and divide them up so we can handle each of them. And then I will come
to member Glover in just a moment. Mao, can you speak to the question of whether it would be
viable to begin to get the state and district comparison data onto the same score report as the
student data? I know there are some timing differentials. You might have to slow down
one in order to incorporate the other, but I'm just curious if you could give us a sense of
what would be needed to get to that. Not for this year, obviously, that's water under the bridge,
but for next year, or whether it's the plan to be able to publish those together again by next year.
Yes, let me just clarify that it's not our intent to withhold anything. It's because the data is not
available. As Chad mentioned, even the current year, we've already rolled out those student score
reports early on because we want to get that into the hands of parents and students, and we're just
excluded from the current time or the current year that we're bringing forward to. But in the future,
when the averages become available, we will bring those reports back to you on an annual basis and
then we will add whatever data is available that makes sense. And it is your area of responsibility
to be able to review those reports and approve them on an annual basis. And also, does that help?
I'm still personally not quite sure I understand. Are you saying that the
average, that when you do a comparison on the score report, it will always be lagged data
for the district and the state, but current data for the student in order to have them at the same
time? Yes, that's what I'm saying. And so the average was used because you were using
a rolling average of prior year data, not the current year data. That's right. So let's say,
for example, if we were going to use it for this year, it'd be the 2020,
the 1920, the 2020, and the 2021. Because the current year, we haven't reported them out yet,
so we couldn't put the prior year one. And in June, starting on June 28th was when we
rolled out the student score reports for the last school year. So we'll always be a little
bit behind in that way. Can I ask, is that a vendor issue or is that an in-house
calculation as to why there's such a, why there's a lag between getting district and
averages so far after student score reports go home? It's a timing issue, right? In terms of,
but like we haven't even finished verifying all the aggregate data in the public website,
right? We have not even released our statewide results. So it's only after all the data has
been verified, checked, and released publicly that you could use those averages on a student's
report at a future year, right? So it's a timing issue. Yeah, the other thing that I'm aware of
is, and you can check me if I'm incorrect on this now, is that districts test at different times,
and so they can get their testing data back at different times for their students. Because the
testing window goes from like February to July or something like that. It's a big window. And so
there's a rolling reporting process for individual students. Yeah, and I do have the Marian Arcella
from ETS here. So they are our state's assessment contractor. She'd like to clarify
a little bit about the process to help you understand. Good afternoon. Marian Arcella,
executive director at ETS for the California statewide assessments. Thank you for your time,
board members. To reiterate what Mal mentioned, we do not, we would not have the statewide averages,
the school averages for the same administration year when we start releasing the student's score
reports. So there are a few years ago, or at the beginning of the CASP assessments, the decision
was to have a rolling release of the student's score reports and not wait for the school year
as was happened in the previous testing program, the STAR program. And so in order to
release the student score reports early and provide enough information, we do have to use
a previous year's data because the current year's administration averages are not available.
So we've made a trade-off in favor of getting data sooner to students and their parents,
which then requires lagged data to be the comparison from the state or even the district.
And so if we were to try to line them up, our choices would either be to hold back data from
students and parents or wait until we have some kind of lagged data for the state or the district,
which I think I understood Mal saying we would be able to reactivate this coming year.
Is that right? Yes. Let's say this year, the 2022 data becomes available sometime this year,
right? We could use those for next year's report. We may not have all three years, right? Because
the 2020-21 is still the same, but we could have at least one year on there. And then it'll
be cumulative over the next couple years as well. So I'd like to suggest that if this is an issue
we want to delve further into, we put this on the November agenda because we can't solve it today,
but speak to these items now. The other question,
I remember Petia Bronson that you were asking about was, is this a one-year
extension of the Adjusted Form Blueprint? And I would simply say that assessment is always in
flux. We've seen that as we go through our board items, we're always making adjustments. We made
a big one with the pandemic, but whatever we vote today can always be rethought in the future.
So if we want to again dive more deeply in the coming meetings into the data that is coming out
about the Adjusted Blueprint and how to think about future decisions, we will be able to make
future decisions. I think nothing here will bind us for life, so to speak. It will be something
that is under continued study. The issue about the data that comes from the claims,
I'll just say I was in conversation with some assessment experts in conversation with the
Department of Education. One of them was our own Ed Hardall, who's been advising us for many,
many years here in California. And their perspective was that the expectation that
the state tests would provide useful claim or sub-score data was probably not an appropriate
expectation. That it was an aspiration at the beginning of the design of the current era of
assessment for ESSA, but that they're highly correlated. The sub-scores and claim scores are
usually both highly correlated with the overall score, so they don't usually add as much
information even though they add length to the test. And that they, in addition, come at the end
of the year when it's a little bit late to be able to use it for guidance of instruction,
which is what you want to do with more detailed data. So we should, I think, dive into these
questions as we're thinking about where we want assessment to be and go in the state.
I'm grateful that we have the increasingly useful interim assessment data from Smarter Balanced
because they've been, we went through this a little bit last year, bundling items in a
variety of ways to do deep dives on particular skills and concepts and claims that are increasingly
used in the state, too. So I do think this is an important issue for us to learn more about,
and maybe we could agendize that. Member Glover-Woodson and Member Yashimoto-Tauri,
and then is there someone else who had their hand up for a moment? Linda, can I just actually
respond to that and say I would absolutely welcome that opportunity to figure out how also to
utilize the interim assessment data and ensure that that becomes something that's open,
it's currently structured for districts, for teachers at the helm of classrooms,
and also to think about, particularly as I think about P to 3, where parents
play such a critical reinforcing role, especially on early literacy lines, that there's a way,
there's an intentional strategy around ensuring that families have access to a digestible form
of these interim assessments. Well, of course, then the interims don't even, the Smarter Balanced
doesn't even apply below grade three. So that's a whole other assessment conversation we should
have because we are about to start to get on a road to, you know, what is the kind of supportive
and diagnostic assessment that would be helpful. Absolutely true, and also I think it's still
relevant for grades three and four in elementary, where parents are just as much partners in engaging
literacy and reinforcing it at home and need to know what they need to address. Yeah, and I do
want to get to our other comments. I just think this is such an important topic. I really do want us to
agendize a deeper conversation about it. Many states are now trying to redefine their
testing systems to provide through course assessment, as it's being called, to be sure
that there are ways by which we can be collecting data during the school year when it's helpful,
that can both contribute to the summative information, but also to the formative
process of teaching and learning. So I think this is really important. What you're bringing up is
something we should delve into on all those levels, and the early childhood piece of it is very
important. Districts are of course using other assessments as well, developmental reading
assessment, a variety of diagnostic tests. So we're at a moment where it's a good idea to sort all
this out. So thank you very much. Member Glover Woods. Excuse me, I look forward to that
conversation also. I was concerned about the kind of indefinite nature of the recommendation
for the adjusted blueprints, so I'm happy to know that we're not locked into not revisiting
this particular aspect. It just seemed that there's still not enough information to be able to make
a decision that we will just continue to use it until, because we don't really have a definite
timeframe of when some of the until aspects would be addressed. I did have a couple of questions
from Mao or whoever could respond to these, and one is what percentage of schools in our state
are actively using the interim assessments, and so that if they wanted to at that level get the claim
level data that is important in that kind of interim phase, I just would like to have an
idea across the state how many schools are really using that, what percentage of schools are using
that, and we'll have access to that level of data. And the second question is that in the item it
was shared that of those in the consortium, we are one of seven states out of the 14 that have
chosen to continue to use the adjusted blueprint, and so that led me to believe that there are seven
states that are not using that. So my question is what has been the reasoning for those seven
states in the consortium that are not using the adjusted blueprint to continue with what I'm
assuming would be the full form? Yes, I do have to, I'm going to call Tony up again to help address that question.
For the record, Tony Alpert, there are states that are using smarter balanced
defined blueprints and states that are not using the smarter balanced defined
blueprint. So every state has the opportunity to use the item bank and collect their own validity
data based on a differing blueprint that better meets their needs. So for example, there are a
couple of states that have decided not to include the performance task in the summative assessment,
and that's against our recommendation and I think it's against the direction that California wants
to go, but every state is able to make a choice like that. So among the states that are using
smarter balanced blueprints, there were two that opted to continue using the full blueprint and
they haven't revisited that decision. Of the remaining states that did use the adjusted blueprint
and only one has decided, Idaho I believe is planning on going back to the full blueprint from
otherwise having used the adjusted blueprint. I'm not privy to the rationale for that,
but it may very well be the analysis of that wanting to provide that claim level data
despite having access to the interim as well. Thank you.
And I'm sorry, President Darling-Hammond, I was wondering if I was going to get an answer to the
percent of schools that are actively using the interim assessments to be able to access
that claim level data. We're checking on that. I don't have that handy right now,
but that's certainly something that we are checking into. Okay, thank you.
All right. Member Yoshimoto-Towry. Yes, the reason I asked about the length of the interim
comprehensive assessment earlier is because I'm also sensitive to the time assessments take
away from instruction. And at the same time, a really good assessment actually saves time
because it helps us understand what to teach, what not to teach, and where to differentiate for
students. And there are, so I'm in favor of saving time. I'm also in favor of ensuring that
educators have the level of information that they need. And yes, interim assessments, diagnostic
formative assessments are going to give that timely data. Although I'll say with lots of
local decision-making, I think this was the one report that families could rely upon that they
knew they would get some detailed information about their students' progress, at least annually.
And so I guess from my perspective, there's, I just had a couple of questions. One is,
is it an either or? Is it a 50% shorter test doesn't give us the claim level data or the 100,
you know, the regular form? Or is there like a test at 60% the length of the regular test
that would actually now give us claim data? So just to be clear about the percentages,
the California assessments include the sort of multiple, the computer adaptive form of it,
and performance tasks in both EOAMS. When we shorten this component of it, we're only shortening
the total by 20-25% because we still have extended performance tasks. So our assessments are quite
long because we have valued having the more rich data from performance tasks,
which cause students to have to problem solve and, you know, demonstrate their knowledge in
more than selected response format. And so we are not reducing our total test length by 50%. We're
reducing our total test length by maybe about 25% at the most. By the time kids get to senior year
there or by 11th grade when they take their high school assessments, the ELA test is about
three and a half hours long, I think. And the math test is a couple of hours long. So our testing
times are still pretty long, even with this adjustment to this component of the assessment.
But the other piece is that you made the point, and as you know, LA chose not to use Smarter
Balance during the pandemic, but used a diagnostic assessment that, you know, you want to have data
to inform instruction. And by the end of the year, when you get the results back from the
state-level test, it's too late to use it for instruction. And so part of the question for us
is how do we create the system in which we have fine-grained data that's useful when it's useful
and use our testing time, you know, in the right ways at the right times. So I think this is the
bigger conversation. 100% agree. 100% agree. Bigger conversation is really important. And
I think it's the indefinite nature that just raised a question in my mind. And then the number of,
if there's a lot, what kind of engagement happened, given this is my first meeting,
I'm just curious what kind of engagement happened before going with the recommendation for Schroeder.
We did hear from a lot of the groups that, you know, were commonly touched base within the
educator community, and all of them favored sticking with the, you know, the administrators
association, the teachers associations, the state, the school boards associations and so on,
favored sticking with the somewhat reduced length of the test. People have had a lot of difficulty
with connectivity issues. Even though we now have a lot, every kids have individual computers,
the fact that kids have Chromebooks does not give a secure site for giving the test. So you still
have to figure out how to get them access to computers that are wired in the ways that are
needed and secured in the ways that are needed for the assessment. Member Arasco Gonzalez.
I just want to add about the importance of, you know, I think that this reduction,
like you mentioned, Dr. Darling-Hammond, is about just 20 to 25% is considerable in the sense that
it gives back some time for students to not only take their time through this test, through the
shorter test, but there's so many other assessments we use in the classroom. And something that Miss
Porter said, too, is as a student, I am in the classroom, I teach second grade, but I know when
I sit with the third or fourth or fifth grade teachers, and I help out for some of these
assessments, even when we prepare performance tests, because we do it continuously throughout
the year. And it's why we do so well as a school is that we're continuously monitoring our
instruction. We're giving these formative and even some summative assessments for each unit of
instruction. And our curriculum plan has several assessments that we relook. And I just think that
that is where the real work is. And I understand that the yearly progress of these assessments is
key, and it's important. And we definitely do use them, even as a mother who has two children who
learn in two different modalities. One is an expert test taker and was almost nearly perfect score
in both English and mathematics. And the other one who struggles and has a 504 punt, because
even though he actually hits straight A's, he just can't sit through those tests. And so
being an educator and having children with two different learning modalities,
I understand that it could be exhausting. And with Wi-Fi issues, I think the reduction of these
computer adaptive portions is going to not only still be a really great measure for educators in
our communities and families, but also lend itself for students to have that time to focus
and to do. And I'm glad that we're reducing the amount of time for these tests, the amount of
content, I should say. So trying to move us along, I think we can, I would offer us the opportunity
to have a motion and a vote with the understanding that the decisions about the assessment are not
terminal. They are not infinite. They are in this moment. And that we will promise to have a deep
dive on assessment for the board very soon, so that we can start to look at all of the questions
and considerations that we want to have on the table as we're recovering from the pandemic and
looking ahead to supporting our students instructionally, as well as we possibly can.
With that, is there anyone who would like to make a motion?
Board President, sorry. This is Myo Vang. May I interrupt? I did check out the euroms question.
Yes. Thank you.
I'll just report briefly that this current year, we have not so much schools, but over
about 1,600 local educational agencies. These are districts who administered over
six million interim assessments. So that's about at least 80% of the local educational agencies
out there using at least some interim assessments. That's pretty impressive. Thank you.
You're welcome. Yes. So is there anyone who would like to make a motion?
I would like to motion Dr. Hammond to follow CDE's recommendation to one,
the state superintendent's proposed thresholds for the California alternative assessment,
two, to continue using the adjusted form blueprints for the smarter balance assessment
for ELA and math, and three, for the CASP and English language proficiency assessments
for California students score report for 2022-23. I'd like to second that.
Thank you very much. Any further discussion? Brooks, can you call the roll for a vote?
President Darlin-Hammond.
Aye.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Aye.
Member Olken.
Yes.
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez.
Aye.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Yes, and looking forward to the future conversations.
Oh, Member Porter.
Aye.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Yoshimoto-Towery.
Yes, thank you.
Motion carries.
Thank you. You've earned recess for 10 minutes. We'll take a break from 2.30 until 2.29 until 2.40.
We'll come back at 2.40. Don't leave. Just turn off your mic and your video and we'll see you back in 10 minutes.
Welcome back. Brooks, can you please establish a quorum by calling the roll?
President Darlin-Hammond.
Here.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Here.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Member Olken.
Here.
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Here.
Member Porter.
Member Rodriguez.
Here.
Member Yoshimoto-Towery.
Everyone's present to account for.
All right. We are going to take up item three, which is the update on the dashboard, alternative school status, request for a waiver pursuant to section 8401 of the Elementary and Secondary Education Act of 1965.
And I'm going to hear, I'm not going to reveal the recommendations, Cindy, because on this we'll be presenting this for the CVE.
Cindy, are you there?
Please begin.
Hi. Sorry for the bad surprise, but it'll be Joe Sines.
Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond and esteemed board members.
My name is Joe Sines.
I'm the federal policy liaison for the government affairs division with the CDE.
And with the support of my colleague, Cindy Kazanis, I will be presenting on item three, the update on the dashboard, alternative school status, or DAS, request for a waiver
pursuant to section 8401 of the Elementary and Secondary Education Act of 1965.
So this slide gives you an overview of the topics that we're going to discuss during this presentation and in relation to this item.
So we will cover the background of the DAS program.
So this will look at the origins, intent, history, and current landscape of the DAS program in our state.
We also look at the timeline of the DAS program and go into the communication with the U.S. Department of Education, which will lead into the next point, the impact of the denial of the DAS waiver.
We will also be looking at the flexibilities under the Every Student Succeeds Act, or ESSA.
Cindy will then be covering the considerations for the 2022 dashboard and beyond.
And lastly, we will again state the recommendation for the board.
So just in review for the item recommendation, the California Department of Education requests that the State Board of Education provide direction to the CDE in terms of short-term and long-term steps as to how to meet the requirement to include all schools in its system of annual meaningful differentiation using the same academic achievement and graduation rate indicators for dashboard, alternative school status, and non-DAS schools by the end of the year.
The CDE further recommends that the SBE delegate authority to CDE subject to approval of the SBE executive director to engage in discussions with the U.S. Department of Education about the DAS program and beyond.
The CDE further recommends that the SBE delegate authority to CDE subject to approval of the SBE executive director to engage in discussions with the U.S. Department of Education per the SBE's direction to resolve issues prior to the release of the 2022 California school dashboard.
So to understand the historical background, we will look at the origins of the DAS program.
California Education Code Section 52052D allows the establishment of the DAS program.
The program is intended to ensure that California's accountability system fairly evaluates the success or progress of alternative schools that serve high-risk students.
With the adoption of the dashboard in 2017, the SBE acknowledged that the system did not address the success or progress of students in alternative school settings.
The SBE subsequently directed the CDE to develop indicators on alternative schools that evaluate the success and progress of these schools based on the LCFF state priorities and accountability requirements in ESSA.
The intent was not to develop a separate accountability system for alternative schools, but rather to include modified metrics for indicators on the California school dashboard that fairly evaluate the specific needs of alternative schools and their progress.
DAS schools receive performance levels on all state indicators similar to traditional schools.
So which schools are DAS? So we'll do a little bit of a refresher here.
Schools are automatically assigned a DAS status because the school type is identified in education code.
So for example, this would be a continuation school, county community, juvenile court, and others.
Or it can be a district-operated special education school that has at least 70 percent of students who participate in the California alternate assessment in grades three through eight and grade 11.
We know that the California alternative assessment is given to a very select number of students, but they are highly concentrated in district-operated special education schools.
Additionally, we provide an opportunity for schools to apply for DAS status. For this, it must be validated that at least 70 percent of the school population is comprised of high-risk student groups.
So in this table gives you a look at the makeup of California's DAS schools.
Approximately 80 percent or 835 schools are automatically assigned by school type. 39 are from district-operated special education schools, and 170 schools through the DAS application process.
DAS students represent about 2.5 percent of the total number of students in California schools.
They serve 151,000 DAS students out of six million total students.
This is significant for our accountability system, as we have over a thousand DAS schools, which far exceeds any other state in the country and the number of students served in this alternative setting.
So DAS schools receive performance colors on every state indicator. However, to fairly hold DAS schools accountable, we identified three indicators where we could implement modified methods.
Specifically, these were the graduation rate indicator, the college career indicator, and the academic indicator.
So going through the timeline of how we got to where we are now, 2017 was when the state board requested the development of the DAS program, and the work that went into this program was robust and done in partnership with the alternative schools community.
Additionally, the state board requested the development of the DAS program, and the work that went into this program was robust and done in partnership with the alternative schools community.
Additionally, there was a lot of work done with CPAG, the state board, the alternative schools task force, and other interest groups to develop and vet these proposals.
In 2018, the state board approved the use of modified methods of state indicators for DAS schools.
Indicators for DAS schools. And in 2020 is when California received a letter from the U.S. Department of Education stating that the use of modified methods to calculate state indicators for DAS schools is not permissible.
Specifically, the following is prohibited. Establishing different cut scores for DAS schools for the academic indicator and the use of a one year graduation rate, which is what our modified method is in California.
In December 2020, CPAG received an update on the letter, and CDE staff received feedback on the modified measures for DAS schools. Also, the board received an information memorandum on this letter from Ed.
Following that, in 2021, the state board approved amendments to California's SS State Plan to bring the DAS modified methods business rules for calculating the academic achievement indicator into compliance with federal law.
However, in January 2022, we received two letters from Ed in response to California's SS State Plan amendments. In February, the SBE received a memo with a copy of the responses from Ed.
In March, the board approved submission of a waiver to Ed requesting the continued use for DAS schools to maintain the DAS modified methods.
Unfortunately, in late July of this year, the waiver was declined by the U.S. Department of Education. In the letter, Ed expressed that the waiver did not sufficiently demonstrate how the request will advance student academic achievement.
Furthermore, Ed stated the following. The state has not demonstrated how schools will continue to provide assistance to the same population served by the Title I Part A program, particularly in schools that would otherwise be identified for support and improvement.
Also, that California's proposal would result in low expectations on academic achievement for those schools serving great proportions of high risk students, as defined by California than in other schools. Setting different lower expectations for some schools and students is against the purpose of Title I.
The denial impacts the following. Our graduation indicator DAS schools will receive the four year cohort rate. In terms of academic indicator, DAS schools will be held to the same cut scores on the five by five performance level grid as non DAS schools.
It also impacts the ESSA school eligibility determinations. Ed requires that we make CSI determinations based on low graduation rate and low performance of Title I schools and additional targeted support and improvement eligibility determinations using data from the California school dashboard.
So that provides a history of how we got to where we are, and now I will pass it to Cindy so she can highlight the considerations for the 2022 dashboard and beyond.
Thanks, Joe. Cindy Kazanis, Director of the Analysis, Measurement and Accountability Reporting Division. And the other hat that we wear is supporting with the ongoing implementation of the Every Student Succeeds Act.
And so very happy to support this conversation today.
So since this item was posted, what was that, 10, 10 days ago, 13, 14 days ago, we had an opportunity, the department did, along with representatives from the State Board of Education to meet with U.S. Department of Education staff, really our counterparts, to talk about some options for moving forward.
One of the things that we wanted to see is if we could actually extend the implementation a year, and that was not, not really, it's not, it's not an option on the table.
And so we have put together some ideas about looking at short term 2022, what is possible, knowing that we have a very short timeframe ahead of us to implement something. And then what can we look about in out years?
I should note that the same staff that helped prepare the mega item that I presented on this morning would be doing this work. And so that is the context for making sure that we're able to support all things around the accountability system, but knowing that we have to come into compliance with,
with ESA or risk state administrative funds under Title One. So the items that I'm going to put forward in the next couple of slides just wanted to make reference that these have come through letters from U.S. Department of Education related to this issue, and then the conversation that we had by phone on September 7th.
So one of the key things that we've heard from the field since this denial was sent to the department and to the board was really this outcry that we still need, regardless of whether or not DAS is allowed to be a part of our federal accountability system, we still need to make sure that accountability and in the alternative school setting is present and is present in our school system.
And so there are, we believe, and we've actually got a chance to talk with a group of alternative school educators that run county run programs this past Friday. And we heard very clearly from them that simply saying that there's an affirmation or there's a reaffirmation that the state is committed to the accountability, accountability system for alternative schools, we want to make sure that they're, they're present on the desk, and we want to make sure that they're present on the desk, and we want to make sure that they're, they're present on the desk, and we want to make sure that they're, they're present on the desk, and we want to make sure that they're, they're present on the desk, and we want to make sure that they're, they're present on the desk, and we want to make sure that they're, they're present on the desk, and we want to make sure that they're, they're present on the desk, and we want to make sure that they're, they're present on the desk,
and we want to make sure that they're, they're present on the desk, and we want to make sure that they're, they're present on the desk, and we want to make sure that they're, they're present on the desk, and we want to make sure that they're, they're present on the desk, and we want to make sure that
when we do, maybe not as easy as, but not that easy.
only looking at a four and a five year graduation rate and we know so many of these students
come into these schools credit deficient or come in on a short term basis and so allowing
for progress to be seen in a positive manner is really important simply to make sure that
the program continues but also that these schools are being seen as you know helping
with student outcomes which they are serving really some of our most needy or at promise
students. So the first suggestion is to continue to report our modified methods and non-modified
methods so going to the four and five year graduation rate or combined graduation rate
on the dashboard. I want to note that when we think about how we go about identification
for comprehensive support improvement that Joe just talked about we have to use the non-modified
methods for that calculation so we don't have options moving forward at least for the
short term to change that calculation. We also had a suggestion and this actually came
from US Department of Education there's another state that does this and that you
don't have to necessarily have this label attached to that they're in a CSI or they're
a low performing school we can call it something else we still need to report back to the federal
government on this information so one idea that came forward is DAS schools that meet
eligibility for the low graduation rate which of course is 68% or below or the low performance
becomes a DAS community of practice and so we say very clearly that we're distinguishing
that these schools are very unique and the students that they serve are valued in our
accountability system. The other short term idea that we have or rather that we're suggesting
that the board consider is to look at ways of providing differentiated improvement activities
and so this is allowable under ESSA this was actually in one of the letters from US Department
of Education and it's specific to schools that predominantly serve students returning
to education after exiting secondary school so if they didn't get a regular high school
diploma and they're off track on their academic credits these are the student populations
that could potentially have differentiated improvement activities if they are deemed
eligible for CSI, ATSI so just that's a context issue that you don't treat every
single school that's in CSI the same that we're meeting them these schools where they're
at. So beyond the current dashboard year and the impact of this denial on DAS schools there
is interest and I hope that the board is supportive of the department exploring some additional
flexibilities specifically there has been on more than one occasion US Department of
Education has continued to say you can use a multi-year graduation rate and so what does
this mean because California already takes advantage of the five-year graduation rate
but this is the six and seven-year graduation rate and we had done some preliminary work
on this in the early days of the accountability system and while it may not impact you know
a large number of students it does send a signal that we do we do want to give credit
to districts and to charter schools that are supporting students well beyond their four
years in high school and so this is one way to you know give credit for those that are
taking a little longer to graduate with a regular high school diploma so that is absolutely
on the table we can look at in future years the other is use of a multi-year that same
that same graduation rate information for determinations of who is in the low graduation
rate eligibility determination so if you've got six and seven-year graduates that would
hopefully you would get above that 68 percent threshold to allow for schools not to be identified
under low graduation rate eligibility requirements the other suggestion for exploration is now
that we're going to have a current set of data that we have not you know really had
access to in over two years start to perform some simulations around the 2022 determinations
for future years of looking at the CSI lowest performing so again those are title one schools
that were not eligible under the low graduation rate looking at it by school type so potentially
elementary middle high and alternative high schools and so I think that's more going
to be more of a policy question but we would be able after this year be able to bring to
you current year data based on the eligibility determinations that we're going to do for
current year our current year dashboard additionally a couple other options there is and this is
again something that's allowed under ESA we need to dig into this a little bit more
to see what other states are doing but explore the option to exclude students who have not
attended the same school within an LEA for at least half a year and this is something
that we are permitted to do with the exception of the graduation rate indicator you never
you never get out of the graduation rate indicator is the moral here but that the performance
would still need to be reported out on our state and local report card so this is something
that is again a flexibility allowed under ESA again I'm not sure if this is something
the board is even interested in exploring but we wanted to make sure we brought it forward
to your attention for consideration for long term solutions around this and then the other
which is definitely a long term solution or not long term option rather because it does
involve the administration and the legislature is exploring differentiated funding allocations
for schools determined eligible for support right now there is the easiest way I can describe
it is there's a bucket of money and there's a number of schools that are identified for
CSI and we divide that back of money equally among those schools for support so unlike
differentiated assistance when you're eligible for CSI you do receive the school does receive
funding federal funding to support those improvement efforts so this is the recommendation it's
still still stands based on the what we put in the item but just know that we have had
a chance to talk with the U.S. Department of Education since this item was published.
At this point I think we're ready to go to public comment and if you could put that slide
up but before we do I'm going to ask liaison member Escobedo if he has any initial comments
and then we can see if there are any clarifying questions then we'll go to public comment.
Thank you. Thank you Dr. Ham. Yes this whole issue on DAS schools has been how could I
say there's such a variability of the type of schools we have throughout California as
you can as you saw in the statistics over a thousand schools and it just seemed to relationship
between districts and schools is very variable so I think a long line is how we measure the
school is how do we measure the criteria and relationships between those feeder schools
those district schools and the DAS schools because one of my concerns is the disproportionate
number of students of color in DAS schools. In highly functioning systems I've seen the
district utilize DAS schools as a way to recover the credit and then bring them back to the
school. I really don't want to see systems using these schools as a place to remove students
just because they don't fit the mold. So definitely we need to look at different accountability
systems however I think we have to really examine the whole structure because I'm deeply
concerned on the type of students that are referred to DAS schools. And I will just add
as the other liaison on this issue that the expansion of the number of DAS schools happened
in the era of accountability when we were only looking at a four year graduation rate
and schools and when schools were being penalized for test scores and when schools would look
at students who were struggling who were not going to make it in four years which would
be a hit on their accountability ranking and their score ranking they would push them out
and DAS schools became the place to catch those students who were for one reason or
another struggling or had been incarcerated or out for pregnancy or other reasons you
know all kinds of reasons I mean kids go through a lot some of them have to leave school to
work they you know have all kinds of things going on. So when there was not a even a five
year graduation rate you know it was easy for schools to just give up on those students
because they were nothing but a quote drag on the rating the school rating. And so that
actually was one of the accountability spillovers that occurred I think one of the things that's
very promising in addition to being sure that we give credit to these schools that are
graduating students within the year because we want an incentive to support them and get
them graduated but also getting to a six or seven year graduation rate which is used
in New York and a number of other states that have high numbers of immigrant students and
students who come sometimes having not had much education or having a variety of challenges
to overcome will give greater incentives to our high schools to continue to work with
students and to continue to support them and so I think there's many dimensions of this
challenge both for the DOS schools themselves and as member Escobedo said for the relationship
between the eater schools so to speak and that system. We have many possibilities to
consider if there are small clarifying questions at this moment we can take those and then
we'll go to public comment and then we'll come back for a fuller discussion. Member Glover
Woods. Thank you. Just a quick clarifying question on slide 20. What is the difference
between number one and number two? Just wanted a little bit more detail there. Absolutely
and I'm sorry it's not clear I did try to restructure it based on a conversation I had
last week with this group who it was confusing to them as well so really what number one
does is it feeds into number two so number one is the indicator that you see on the
dashboard. Number two is saying you can use that indicator in the methodology to determine
who's eligible for low graduation rate so who's eligible for CSI you can use that multi-year
graduation rate indicator. It's really it's a feeder into number two so hopefully that
makes sense. That helps thank you. And are there any other clarifying questions at this
moment? Member Olken. Thank you just to follow up on that same question or that same area
that would then there would be for all schools the proposal would be that for all schools
we would move to an extended multi-year graduation rate so it would be for everyone. Correct
so when the five-year graduation rate was adopted the requirement under ESSA is that
you have to increase it above the 67 percent you have to you have to really have to have
a higher target. I need to look back at that language to see if we'd have to raise the
target again if we also included six and seven year but it would apply to all schools. Thank
you. And I don't see any other hands up so if there are no other did Brenda's hand go up
Remember Lewis? You're on mute. Still on mute. Can you get that to go off? Okay can you
hear me now? I'm sorry it says my internet is unstable so I hope I don't freeze but just
I don't want to belabor this question. You mentioned in the presentation it's the
multi-year graduation rate is six or seven years and that would have an impact on the determination
of whether or not they go into CSI so how does that work like six or seven years so
they stay continuously enrolled for six and seven years and then when does that impact
the CSI eligibility if I'm understanding what number two is saying? Correct those are fantastic
questions that I don't have the answers to. I do know that once a student exits out of
the system that's credit deficient they may be going to one or more schools to come back
to get that high school diploma and so part of it is tracking down students who reenter
the system and then determining which cohort they get put into so those are I think you're
raising some great technical questions that we need to dig into and so it's not something
that we'll be able to put again put in place or put before you until 2023 at the earliest.
Right so we will be making a short term decision about how to handle DOS schools this year
and a longer term and we're informing a longer term exploration on the part of the department
into other options. I will say other states that use the six and seven year graduation
rate do not require continuous enrollment. They the students in fact many of the students
who end up graduating you know within six or seven years have stopped out for a reason.
Not all of them but that's as Cindy said the questions of how to think about the cohort
and then how to do the tracking are things we would look into with the benefit of other
places that have already done it as well as our own system of data that we have available
to us. I have seen by the way huge incentives for keeping immigrant students in school and
getting them to graduate and huge differentials in some schools for students who have that
extra sometimes a couple of years because they may come in at the high school level
already you know not having had as much education so there there can be important differentials
in some schools for having that ability to track to stick with and track their students.
Member Glover Woods I think your hand is up. Is that a new hand?
It is a new hand. I'm sorry one more clarifying question as it relates to how this would be
handled for the 2022 dashboard and the 2022-23 school year. I know we were having conversations
about the extended year graduation rate but my understanding is that doesn't impact our immediate
and so I guess my question is or my clarifying question is in relation to slide 15 which
outlines with the denial how it will impact the DAS schools so is the information on slide 15
how we will be handling the DAS schools for the 2022 dashboard and for the school year?
That is correct although I'm realizing we have left out information on this slide. DAS schools
would receive the four and five year cohort rate. We do we are permitted to have it is in our approved
as a state plan to have the four and five year cohort rate so that is how it will be used to first
look at the first step in the process. I'm going to skip to the next slide is that we have to look at
any school that doesn't meet the graduation rate requirement which again for California is 68 percent
if you're under 68 percent you're and there is an average that we're allowed to do between more
than one year we are you're automatically in you're automatically eligible rather for CSI any
schools that are still standing and not identified for CSI under the low graduation rate and are
receiving Title I funds then get looked at for low performance of Title I schools and so that's where
the graduation rate picks up again as well as the academic indicator those modified methods cannot
be used per that denial letter from the U.S. Department of Education. Thank you Cindy. The
upshot is that because a lot of students have already missed the four year mark and some have
missed the five year mark as well many many DAS schools perhaps most maybe nearly all will likely
fall into that category. The good news is they will get CSI resources if that is the case.
The bad news is they won't get unless we decide we also want to publish the ongoing one year
graduation rate that we have published they would not be getting feedback about how they are doing to
get the students who are there out so I think we probably want to give them that useful informative
information even if we need to use the four or five year graduation rate to identify them for CSI.
Member Olken? Yeah you just hit on what was my question. Slide 19 it looks to me is also a set of
potential things we could do this year which include continuing to publish on our dashboard our own
modified methods but we'd also just have to include the new ones and perhaps because you just
mentioned that the majority of DAS schools would be eligible for CSI we could call it something
else is that and and what ultimately we're being asked is do we are we willing to recommend that or
we do we agree with those recommendations is that right? Cindy? That is the recommendation that we
before you although we've indicated it's reaffirming California's commitment because the
recommendation itself that's in the motion is this is not this specific. Yep great so yeah just so
looking at slide 19 is helpful for us. Thank you. Thank you.
I feel like because of my comments largely I started to push us into the discussion mode rather than
the clarifying mode so I want to be sure we get to public comment now and then we will come back and
have fuller discussion so public comment call into that number do we have commenters?
We do there are seven people in the queue I will open the phone line now. Great. Good afternoon please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute your time starts now.
My name is Sean Morales legislative representative County operated student programs committee.
On behalf of the California County Superintendents we'd like to thank the state for unwavering support of alternative education programs and our students.
As outlined in our letter we are standing by in the spirit of service and support to discuss how we can maintain the original
intention of calculating and reporting our DAS student outcomes.
As outlined in our letter we are standing by in the spirit of service and support to discuss how we can maintain the original intention of calculating and reporting our DAS student outcomes in a meaningful way.
Comparing DAS student outcomes to non-DAS student outcomes is invalid, inappropriate and will not effectively support the improvement of student outcomes.
We must find a way to continue to display modified measures on the dashboard to support effective LCAP development and continuous improvement work.
Not doing so would result in an issue of inequity.
While we acknowledge and are disappointed by the response from the U.S. Department of Education we also need to provide our students staff families and educational partners with achievement data that authentically measures the academic social emotional
and behavioral growth that takes place while students are enrolled in our schools.
We'd like to thank the CDE and SBE staff for your support and partnership on this topic and look forward to working together to do what's best for all of California's students.
Thank you. Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
This is Suzanne Cooey of the Charter Schools Development Center. We support the fullest use of DAS modified metrics on the dashboard.
DAS charter school authorizers really struggle with a lack of data and renewal decisions.
DAS modified metrics don't solve the problem but they help a little.
For the board's background there are now four different sets of charter renewal standards.
One is for DAS schools and three are for non-DAS schools.
So this FYI that's the test and punish part because a non-DAS charter schools renewal standards get determined by not very robust comparisons of performance levels to state averages on academic indicators.
And that may be followed by extremely restricted use of academic growth data.
The larger point is that for DAS and non-DAS charter schools appropriate use of data is key to sound decisions.
The CSDC urges the state board to examine these issues with care and to increase, not limit, data analytics available to support higher quality charter renewal decisions.
Thank you. Thanks for your time. Thank you. Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon President Stauding-Hammond and members of the board. My name is Dr. Rudy Cuevas and I'm the superintendent of Uphill Charter School of California.
Our school is a participant in DAS and has appreciated the opportunity to have this equity base.
The following are my few points for the board to consider.
We've always been grateful to the state board and to CDE staff for several years as a foresight to convene an alternative accountability task force to develop all of the various stock metrics that we're responsive to alternative schools and the students we serve.
Related to the model responsiveness of this ideal democratic collaboration between government agencies and stakeholders, it would be unfortunate if DAS and its corresponding metrics were canceled during a pandemic with no further input from this task force that was responsible for authoring these metrics.
This would specifically be unfortunate if this was canceled at a time when the federal and state and local governments across the country have been showing incredible and historic empathy brought about by the pandemic.
Thank you. Your time is up. Thank you. Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, Dr. Darling-Hammond and board members. Diana Boo on behalf of the Association of California School Administrators.
As you heard, DAS schools represent about 10% of the total number of schools in California and their students account for 2.5% of the California 6 million students.
DAS schools act as a safety net for these students who are not well served in traditional comprehensive high schools by providing them with the flexibility, attention, and services they need to succeed.
DAS schools act to commend CDE and the board's commitment to add promise use and alternative schools that educate them and look forward to collaborating with the state on long-term solutions that reflect the unique needs and nature of the students enrolled in alternative education schools while maintaining rigorous and equal expectations to improve their learning outcomes. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, this is Leticia Garcia on behalf of Riverside County Superintendent of Schools and the 23 school district superintendents in Riverside County.
We thank CDE and SBE for seeking the waiver for DAS and share our disappointment in the denial of the request.
We expressed our support for staff's recommendation in seeking both short-term and long-term solutions.
As practitioners, we are ready to partner with CDE in future discussions to determine long-term solutions to hold alternative schools accountable while recognizing the unique merits of their re-engagement programs and celebrate the accomplishments of their re-engaged youth. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, Jessica Sacco on behalf of Children Now. I refer you to the LCFF Equity Coalition for our complete comments on this item.
Firstly, regarding 2022, we suggest that you first consider identifying DAS schools using the CSI measures, which would likely lead to a large number of DAS schools being identified.
Then as a second tier, look at the additional accountability measures, including the modified measures that have been rejected as a part of the waiver request, high school chronic absence rates, which we believe to be a stronger measure for this group in schools, and potentially other indicators in order to customize and recommend differentiated treatment for these schools.
Over time, you may also want to consider looking at the incentives that traditional schools have to transfer students to DAS schools and consider continuing to count the transferred students to the transferring schools accountability measures.
We do believe that there is room for a broader set of measures to be reported on for alternative schools and we look forward to your collaboration. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond and members. Eric Premack with the Charter School Center. We have dozens of our member schools in the DAS system and commend the CDE staff for their many years of hard work to create the one year graduation methodology.
We actually think that it's worth considering taking a firm stand with the feds here and seeing if they have the guts to cut the money or not.
We're very serious about this. It may sound radical, but when you put this in perspective and realize that federal Title I monies are less than 2% of our total K-12 system funding and that after you factor in all the red tape and hassle, it's probably about 1%.
It's really time to stop treating this money like fiscal crack and instead really take it to the feds on this and see if they have a backbone or not.
I think it's time for us to have a backbone and stand for sound data and sound methodology and take the feds on on this. Thank you very much.
Thank you. That concludes public comment for item number three.
I will note that we have gone back to the feds a couple of times on this and made a strong case and they have heard us but believe that the law constrains their saying yes.
We'll see what unfolds with the next reauthorization.
At this point, we're open for discussion if there is further discussion and if we could then consider the motion.
Member McQuillin and member Oakland is your hand up again or is it still was it up from before? Okay.
Yes, thank you. I know what we're talking about doesn't represent a huge amount of students but the DOS schools when I think of the schools we're talking about, I think of students who are from lower socioeconomic status.
I think of students of color. I think of some of what was already discussed about students who may have stopped out because of pregnancy.
Even students who might be still impacted by the pandemic may end up in that type of school.
I like what one of the caller said like to know the pros and cons of reporting the student from this origin that they stay with us and get reported from the school of origin where they came from.
I like that to entertain that idea. I also like the idea of encouraging the reporting for fifth year and sixth year, maybe even seventh year that encouraging and recognizing those DOS schools that do, you know, maintain the students in that fifth and sixth year.
Thank you for some thoughts. Thank you. Thank you very much. Member Escobedo and then member Glover Woods and then member Rodriguez.
When I reviewed the last task force report, I believe it was done in 2020. It was an interesting recommendation they had which was to incorporate what they call a positive transition rate as a local accountability indicator.
And it really has a lot of, I think, very worthwhile implications and how this positive transition rate will focus on the students continued path to further their education.
It could be going into a GED, it could be going into some type of comprehensive adult school, could be joining the military or job corps.
And I think thinking outside the box, creating some type of what they call a positive transition rate might be an interesting measure on how we look at incremental improvement in this school and these schools.
Thank you.
Interesting. Member Glover Woods.
Definitely looking forward to our future conversations on the long term decisions that we'll make in regards to this. My question is in regards to again impact for this year.
We just earlier today approved a new methodology for differentiated assistance eligibility. My question is, do we know the impact, now the change in methodology that we'll have to use for DOS schools for 2022 dashboard, how that will impact the number of LEAs that will now be eligible for differentiated assistance.
Yeah, the short answer is no. I don't know how it will impact. We know that there have been enrollment shifts for alternative schools, so that's something we are also watching.
But keep in mind that differentiated assistance is determined based on an entire district's performance, or if you're a charter school, you would, but charter schools are not in differentiated assistance for 2022.
So it is a great question, and until we can start our data processing and really dig into it, I don't have an idea of that impact.
But it is one component, unlike this high bar that is set with the federal system in determining school eligibility, differentiated assistance really has this holistic view of a district, not a school.
So if you're in a comprehensive district, maybe on Riverside Unified, you have so many schools that are contributing to that aggregation of the data for district and school performance.
And a DAS school may contribute some, but your traditional schools were more likely to have a greater impact.
So that is some of the differences between the federal accountability system and the state accountability system requirements.
Member Rodriguez.
Thank you.
I'm definitely in favor of delegating authority to the CDE.
On behalf of DAS schools, I started my teaching at a DAS school, which is why I'm so passionate about redesigning schools, because our students' needs aren't met in traditional schools.
And so you have students who want to continue with their education, and in smaller environments, they get that support.
And so my experience being connected to DAS schools here in my community is that they're the saving grace for a lot of our students.
Sometimes somebody mentioned the pandemic, and I had a few students, actually, who went to our continuation high school to catch up on some of their credits and came back and said it was a lovely environment.
I hated to leave because they do get so much more support than we can give them sometimes.
My classes have 35 students each, and so if they have literacy needs, learning difficulties, language processing, they really need a lot closer attention.
And I see my colleagues who are so passionate at our DAS schools here in my community just really dedicated to improving the futures of students who gave up on a system that sometimes I think gave up on them too.
And so I'm not in favor of having schools send students to not bring their tests down, their test scores, to send them off.
But I am definitely in favor of supporting the great work that our DAS educators and administrators are doing and anything that we can as a state board to support that effort.
Thank you.
Thanks. That is a great segue, thank you, Member Rodriguez, to what we need to decide for today, which I believe as Member Olken had intuited back on was slide 19 where we were talking about what we need to do this year.
I think we've given the department staff a lot to chew on to both deal with the current situation and then the longer-term possibilities, and we'll come back around on those.
And I think the thing we probably need to, it would be good to have a motion on is the question of continuing to report modified methods and non-modified methods on the dashboard, because we need to do the latter for the federal government.
But I think we will take a vote, I think we should take a vote on whether we want to do the former as a state matter.
Cindy, do we need a motion on all three of these?
I moved it to the item recommendation because my understanding from counsel who's not physically in the room but has provided guidance is that if you are in agreement with the short-term and long-term steps we've identified that this original item recommendation should cover those bases.
I have not heard to the contrary that there would be interest in moving away from those short-term recommendations, but just wanted to make sure that you were aware that this recommendation could be used. You wouldn't have to substitute something.
That's a little bit more vague, because it says provide direction in terms of short and long-term steps, but then it doesn't say what the steps are.
The long-term steps are a set of options, and so we've given you some feedback on those options that you produced.
And oops, go back. There's a delegating authority. I'm trying to read, I'm trying to see everybody on the screen, see the participant list, and see the slide all at the same time.
And then of course the ongoing discussions with CDE. So I think what I would like to know is the sense of the group about displaying both the existing non-modified, our existing DAS indicators on the dashboard alongside what we need to display for the federal purpose.
I think that is the one thing that we need to know that we agree on right away, even as we give you feedback on explorations to come.
So can we just get the sense of the group? Can I just ask that we go around, since we don't seem to need to vote on that specifically, but let's get the sense of the group so that we can then vote on the recommendation.
Member Rodriguez, I'm going to call on you.
Sorry, I still had my hand up. Sorry about that.
That's okay.
There's interest in being more direct with this item recommendation. The recommendation from your executive director is we take a quick five minute break and we come back with a slide that represents what you're asking us to do.
Okay, then do you understand what we're asking you to do so that you can do that?
I believe so. I believe what you asked us to do is to take the short-term recommendations and be more specific so we can literally copy those from the prior slide, this slide, and we would then leave the final version, the final paragraph here, that there's a delegation of authority to resolve these issues.
That sounds great. So if you could do that, I'm going to give us a 15-minute break because it might be the last break we get for the day.
So it is 3.36. I'll give you 14 minutes until 3.50. We'll see you back then. Turn off your mic and your video and then come back ready to work because we still have a couple of items after this.
All right, welcome back and Brooks, can you reestablish the quorum?
Of course. President Darlin-Hammond.
Here.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Here.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Aye.
Member Olken.
Here.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Member Patillo-Bronson.
Here.
Member Porter.
Member Rodriguez.
Here.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Present.
Everyone's present to account for. We have a quorum.
All right, and now we have a revised item. Do you want to read that off to us, Cindy?
The item recommendation is being taken from the prior slide in which we talked about specific short-term solutions, and here it goes.
The California Department of Education, CDE, recommends that the State Board of Education, SBE, approve the following short-term options for the 2022 Dashboard.
Reaffirm California's commitment to the DAS program by, one, continuing to report modified methods and non-modified methods on the Dashboard.
Two, label DAS schools that meet the eligibility for CSI low graduation rate or low performance as a DAS community of practice to distinguish the uniqueness of the schools and the students served.
Three, develop differentiated improvement activities for schools that predominantly serve students.
Returning to education after having exited secondary school without a regular high school diploma or who, based on their age, their grade or age, are significantly off track to accumulate sufficient academic credits to meet high school graduation requirement.
The CDE further recommends that the SBE delegate authority to the CDE, subject to approval of the SBE Executive Director, to engage in discussions with the U.S. Department of Education per the SBE's direction to resolve issues prior to the release of the 2022 California School Dashboard.
All right. Thank you very much. And with the addition of that S on requirement, I think we have a pretty clear recommendation to act on. Do we have a motion?
I'd like to motion the revised recommendation, as just stated.
I second. I second. Sorry, maybe. No, go ahead. Go ahead, Brenda.
I second. All right. Very good. Any further discussion?
If not, Brooks, please call the roll for a vote.
President Darlin Hammond.
Aye.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Aye.
Member Olken.
Yes.
Member Roscoe Gonzalez.
Aye.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Yes.
Member Porter.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Yoshimura Tauri.
Motion passes unanimously.
Okay, we are going to forge on through now. We're going to go to the consent items.
We'll take up first the regular consent items, items five through eight, and we will open the phone line now for the queue for public comment on consent items five through eight.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment on consent items five through eight may do so by calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the slide that is shown now.
We'll give it just a little bit of wait time in case there's a lag to see if there's any public comment.
It's live on the...
Sorry?
The slide is live on the screen.
Yes, the slide is live.
Okay, we currently have one person in the queue, although they could be for the next item, but I will open the phone line now.
Okay.
Good afternoon, caller. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello, I'm calling about item number six in the consent agenda.
Hello, State Board of Education members. My name is Lorraine Richards and I am a classroom teacher representing California Teachers Association.
California Teachers Association strongly supports efforts to eliminate gender bias and ableism from state testing and our schools in general.
And we support CDE's recommendation to adopt the emergency regulations, which will help to modify the California physical fitness test by eliminating the body composition subtest and the related body composition healthy fitness zone.
Additionally, CTA strongly supports eliminating practices which negatively impact students' personal body perception and endorses practices that support students' emotional and mental well-being.
Physical fitness is an important aspect of students' growth and development and should lead to lifelong healthy habits, not feelings of shame, isolation, or inadequacy.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you.
That concludes public comment for the regular consent items five through eight.
Okay. Given that there's no further public comment, I'll ask for a motion on consent items five through eight. Do I have a motion?
So moved.
Thank you. And do we have a second.
Thank you.
We'll now hold the roll call vote.
Brooks, please call the roll.
President Darlene Hammond.
Aye.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Member Olken.
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez.
Aye.
Member Petillo-Bronson.
Yes.
Member Porter.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Yoshimoto-Taurin.
Motion carries unanimously.
Thank you. And we're going to move right on ahead to item number nine.
Item number nine is the appeal of the denial of a position for the establishment of a
classroom-based charter school pursuant to California Education Code Section 47605-K2,
consideration of evidence to hear or summarily deny the appeal of Caliber High School, which
was denied by the Vallejo City Unified School District and the Solano County Board of Education.
This item will be presented by Craig Heimbigner of the CDE.
Craig, please begin.
Craig, are you all set?
I apologize. I was muted.
Thank you, President Linda Darling-Hammond, and I will be presenting this on behalf of
our charter schools division.
So I'll go right into it.
Item nine is the decision to hear or summarily deny the appeal of Caliber High School.
And for some background on that, excuse me.
Okay.
The Caliber High School petition, or CHS, proposes a new grade nine through 12 charter school
opening in 2022-23.
Caliber High School submitted its petition to the Vallejo City Unified School District,
or VCUSD, pursuant to California Education Code or EC Section 47605A, and the district
denied the petition on December 15, 2021, by a vote of five to zero.
Caliber appealed the district's denial to the Solano County Board of Education, SCBOE,
pursuant to Ed Code Section 47605K1AI, and the county denied the petition on April 13,
2022, by a vote of six to one.
Caliber High School then submitted its petition to the California State Board of Education,
SBE, on May 13, 2022, pursuant to EC Section 47605K2.
The recommendation of the California Department of Education is as follows.
CDE recommends that the SBE summarily deny review of the Caliber High School appeal based
on the documentary record.
CHS or Caliber has not met their burden to rebut the fact that while in state receivership,
the district is unable to absorb the fiscal impact of the proposed charter.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools recommendation was made on August 11, 2022,
in their meeting, and ACCS, the commission, put forth a motion to recommend that the SBE
hear the Caliber High School appeal to determine if the district and or county abused its discretion.
That motion, there were two motions, this was the first one, that motion failed by a vote of three to five.
And then the ACCS entertained a second motion to adopt the CDE's recommendation that the
SBE summarily deny review of Caliber's appeal, and that motion passed by a vote of five to three.
A little background on state receivership, because that is very important for the context here.
California has created a process for schools experiencing financial distress under specific
conditions to receive emergency apportionments from the state per Ed Code sections 41.320
and 41.326.
This process is commonly referred to as state receivership.
A school district that is not positioned to absorb the fiscal impact of a proposed charter school
due to being under state receivership may deny a petition for the establishment of a charter school
pursuant to Ed Code section 47605C8.
Referencing that Ed Code section, the school district is not positioned to absorb the fiscal
impact of the proposed charter school in this C8 section.
A school district satisfies this paragraph if it has a qualified interim certification
pursuant to EC section 42131 and the county superintendent of schools in consultation
with the county office fiscal crisis and management assistance team, or FICMAT,
certifies that approving the charter school would result in the school district having a
negative interim certification pursuant to EC section 42131.
Or, it has a negative interim certification pursuant to EC section 42131, or finally,
it's under state receivership.
Charter schools proposed in a school district satisfying one of these conditions per this
Ed Code shall be subject to a rebuttable presumption of denial.
Regarding the district's background, Vallejo, the district, entered receivership status
in 2004 and received an emergency loan in the amount of $60 million.
Currently, the district is one of only four school districts in the state of California,
that is under state receivership.
The district has assigned a trustee and at the time the appeal was submitted had an outstanding
balance on the loan of approximately $9.5 million.
The role of the SBE in charter appeals, just a quick reminder since we're still in the
first few of these appeals, pursuant to EC section 47605K2E, the role of the SBE is as
follows.
The SBE shall either hear the appeal or summarily deny review of the appeal based on the documentary
record.
If the SBE hears the appeal, the board may affirm the determination of the governing
board of the school district or the county board of education or both of those determinations
or may reverse only upon a determination that there was an abuse of discretion.
If the SBE decides to hear the appeal, the hearing will take place during the November
meeting.
If the SBE decides to summarily deny the appeal, the decisions of the district and county board
of education will stand and there will be no further hearings on this item.
Review of Caliber's appeal.
Both the ACCS and the CDE recommend the SBE summarily deny this appeal based on the lack
of evidence presented by the petitioners to rebut the presumption of denial under Ed
Code section 47605C8.
The petitioners failed to establish that the district would be able to absorb the fiscal
impact of the proposed charter while under state receivership.
The department reviewed all of the evidence presented by the petitioners as well as evidence
provided by the district, the county and FICMAT.
Both the county and FICMAT are intimately familiar with the district's budget and were
clear that the district could not absorb the fiscal impact of this proposed charter.
After a review of all of the above-mentioned evidence, the department determined that the
evidence that the petitioner put forth did not refute the presumption that while under
state receivership the district could absorb the fiscal impact of the proposed charter
school.
Now importantly, FICMAT had a role here.
Pursuant to Ed Code section 47605C8, the Solano County Superintendent of Schools consulted
with FICMAT regarding the Caliber appeal.
FICMAT found that the district is under state receivership and is not positioned to absorb
the fiscal impact of the proposed charter school.
According to FICMAT's letter dated February 28, 2022, there is only one relevant factor
appropriate for consideration, and that is that the district remains under state receivership.
Until the loan is fully repaid, the district is not positioned to absorb the fiscal impact
of the proposed charter school.
If the board wishes more information on that, I want to let you know that the executive
director of FICMAT is on the Zoom call and will be able to answer any specific questions
that you may have regarding their letter and or state receivership.
And that letter is attachment 5, pages 22 to 23.
In conclusion, the CDE recommends that the state board summarily deny review of the Caliber
High School appeal based on the documentary record.
The district finds that the CDE finds, excuse me, that the district is under state receivership
and satisfies requirements of EC Section 47605C8.
Caliber High School has not provided sufficient evidence to rebut the presumption that while
in state receivership, the district is not able to absorb the fiscal impact of the proposed
charter.
Therefore, Caliber has not met their burden to rebut the presumption for denial under
EC Section 47605C8.
The ACCS at its August 11, 2022 meeting moved to recommend that the SBE summarily deny the
Caliber High School appeal.
And that motion passed, as we said, by a vote of 5 to 3.
If the SBE decides to summarily deny the appeal as recommended by the CDE and ACCS, the decisions
of the district and county board of education will stand and there will be no further hearings
on this item.
And that concludes our presentation.
Okay.
Thank you.
So legally, the state board is not required to hold a public hearing in this matter, but
we would like to ensure that the parties have an opportunity to present to the state board.
Therefore, following this, the charter school will have 10 minutes to make their presentation.
That will be followed by the district and county board of education, who will both have
a total of 10 minutes to make a presentation.
Following the presentations by the parties, there will be an opportunity for public comment
from members of the public who are not part of the initial presentations.
And members of the public will have one minute.
Petitioners representing the charter school, please begin.
Thank you.
I'm going to try and screen share here.
If you give me just one moment.
It's not letting me.
I cannot start while someone else is sharing.
So we'll need, there we go.
If I could get an indication from somebody that they're able to see that, I would appreciate it.
They can see your slide, yes.
Wonderful.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Good morning.
Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond and State Board of Education members.
My name is Marcus Malarkey, and I'm here today to speak on behalf of the hundreds of caliber
families who signed our petition to open a high school in Vallejo.
I want to start with a simple question.
Why are we here today?
Many of Caliber's detractors will tell you, erroneously, that a charter petition should always be
denied if a district is in receivership.
Even the CDE staff report to the ACCS a month ago made this error and recommended that our appeal
not be heard solely because VCSE is in receivership.
But that's not the appropriate question to ask in considering our appeal.
Our petition isn't subject to an automatic denial just because the district is in receivership.
Instead, as the CDE's more recent report seems to make clear, we should be afforded the opportunity
to rebut the presumption that the district can't absorb the fiscal impact of the school.
And VCUSD has an obligation to carefully consider our rebuttal before making a decision to approve
or deny the petition.
So I ask again, why are we here today?
To put it simply, we're here because the VCUSD board didn't fulfill that obligation.
Had they conducted a thorough and objective analysis of Caliber's rebuttal and had that analysis
come to a fact-based conclusion that the district can't afford to approve the new school,
we would have respected their decision.
But that's not what happened.
In fact, the district staff report explicitly did not include any factual finding to support the
denial of the petition on the basis of a fiscal impact.
This quote is taken directly from their report.
Denying our petition without any factual basis and without seriously considering our rebuttal
was an abuse of discretion that must be addressed.
Their board's resolution denying our petition did not offer any factual findings.
You may hear today that it was the VCUSD's board's prerogative to simply come to a different conclusion
than their staff did.
But I ask you to consider whether they had any factual basis for such a conclusion or if it was based on other motives.
Is it credible that the board felt that they were smarter than the staff or had more information about the district finances
or that they had new information their staff didn't have when they did their report?
Neither of those are credible, nor are they supported by the documentary record.
In fact, the only facts in the documentary record after the staff report were those provided by Caliber
showing the district able to absorb the impact of the charter.
This slide from our ACCS hearing summarizes that analysis showing that the district had ample resources in blue
to absorb the impact of the charter in green.
So if the board didn't have any new information, why not simply follow the staff recommendation?
We believe the obvious explanation for their about face is that they simply didn't want to approve the petition.
And when given inaccurate advice that they could deny it without further analysis because they're in receivership,
that they eagerly took the advice and denied the petition without seriously considering the rebuttal provided by Caliber.
That explanation is not only more credible than any other, it is supported by the documentary record as we pointed out in our appeal.
Unfortunately, it's also contrary to that board's responsibility under Ed Code, and it represents an abuse of discretion.
So anyone who tells you there's no need for an SBE hearing is simply missing the core point of our appeal.
There is a key question at issue.
Why did the VCUSD board reject their staff report and does their about face represent a possible abuse of discretion?
The CDE's report today, as you'll hear momentarily, doesn't provide adequate details on these issues,
nor support the recommendation of a summarily denying our appeal.
It leads to conclusions without providing the basis for them.
That's why we need a hearing.
And I'd like to invite Janelle Rooley now to summarize the factors that we believe need a review by the SBE in particular.
Thank you, Marcus, and good afternoon, Board President Darling-Hammond and board members.
Janelle Rooley with the offices of Young, Minion Corps.
We appreciate the state board's time today.
We implore you to vote today to hear Caliber's appeal.
I will address two reasons why Caliber students and families deserve the chance for the merits of this charter appeal to be heard by you.
First, the law around both charter consideration and appeal has been misapplied through this entire process at all levels.
In every hearing so far, we've heard a version of Vallejo Unified is in receivership and so case closed.
Nothing to see here.
We heard this from the district.
We heard it from the county, from the CDE, from the ACCS, even in the face of abundant evidence that there is genuinely a live factual dispute
over the legal standard for consideration of a charter petition under Section 47605C8.
The status of being in state receivership is a condition that triggers a rebuttable presumption of denial of a new charter.
This presumption can be overturned if the petitioners can demonstrate that the district, while in receivership, can actually absorb the impact of the new school.
This is something that we have presented and demonstrated multiple times to various bodies who continue to insist that receivership alone constitutes an automatic charter denial,
which is directly contrary to what the law says.
Only with the posting of the CDE staff report for this meeting, just in the last few days, has the correct standard actually been affirmed.
Unfortunately, though, this about face really comes after damage was done to Caliber just a month ago at the ACCS meeting.
Second point, there's a real factual dispute over whether there's sufficient evidence to demonstrate an abuse of discretion in the consideration of our petition by the district in the county.
The CDE and ACCS recommendations for summary denial are both flawed in their assessment of the issue.
The law says that ACCS's role is to review the documentary record to determine whether there was sufficient evidence for the state board to hear or summarily deny.
We had anticipated just that kind of discussion last month.
You know, that's what we expected to be talking about at the ACCS meeting.
But the CDE staff report completely took the ACCS off course.
The CDE asked the ACCS to vote for summary denial because Caliber did not rebut the district's status of receivership.
But as we've shown and as the CDE has since affirmed, including just now from Mr. Heimbigner, that's not the correct legal standard.
By adopting the CDE's flawed recommendation, the ACCS's recommendation is now also flawed and neither of them can be relied on by you.
A further consequence of this detour is that you still don't have a comprehensive review of the documentary record to determine whether there was an abuse.
You don't have it, we don't have it, nobody has it.
Given the CDE's prior recommendation, there was no reason for the ACCS to review the entire documentary record because the CDE's recommendation only focused on the district's receivership status.
Now that the CDE presents the correct legal standard to the State Board, there is a factual dispute about the evidence, namely whether there was an abuse of discretion.
This is exactly the type of appeal that warrants a hearing by the State Board.
This is the standard the CDE has told you applies in all of the other appeals to date.
Of course, there's a factual dispute here.
Caliber presented evidence of an abuse of discretion and the district and county denied that there is one.
That is a dispute.
The CDE's recommendation does not actually show a detailed analysis of Caliber's claims that there were abuses of discretion.
We would ask that you not only vote to hear our appeal, but also instruct the CDE to publish a point by point analysis of Caliber's appeal.
Caliber and his families deserve a chance to have their day in court.
The district and the county did abuse their discretion in this denial.
Caliber cited four different specific reasons for abuse of discretion.
And families who are seeking choice really deserve the State Board to lean in on this and to figure out what actually happened here.
Ultimately, there's not a lot that we're not asking for a lot from the State Board.
Really just your time and consideration.
We're not asking you to be Caliber's authorizer or to be involved long term.
Just that you exercise the authority that the law gives you to check abuses of discretion that occurred here.
Marcus, I'll hand it back over to you.
As Janelle said, we're not surprised to be here today after the district board ignored their staff report and denied our petition without any meaningful discussion of our rebuttal.
We are surprised that there's any question about whether the SBE should hold a hearing.
Under AB 1505, you have a specific and critical role to provide a check against abuses of discretion by authorizing entities.
This is what we're asking you to do today.
We documented numerous abuses and we believe that our families deserve a hearing on these.
As the State Board of Education, you are charged with the important work of ensuring that all children have access to high quality, equitable education.
And while this work isn't simple, it is critical.
Our families have been asking for our Caliber High School for years.
Their need has never been disputed.
Both the district and the county affirm the Caliber's educational program is sound and that it addresses a need in the community.
But the district board decided not to meet that need.
Despite a staff report finding no factual basis for a denial on fiscal grounds, they nonetheless use that as a basis for their denial.
And they did it without seriously considering Caliber's rebuttal that the district can, in fact, infort our school.
Why did they do so?
We believe that they did so for other motives that represent an abuse of their discretion.
Our families deserve a proper review and assessment of the district's actions.
They ask you to fulfill your statutory responsibility provided to them.
And we are asking you to not only have an appeal hearing, but to ask the CD staff to provide that detailed analysis.
I thank you for your time, and I'm happy to answer any questions that you may have about our presentation.
Thank you.
At this point, I think we want to hear from the district and our county office.
Hello. Good afternoon. My name is Leslie Locker, and I am legal counsel for Vallejo City Unified School District.
I'm going to go ahead and share my screen.
I'm having trouble again locating the presentation. Superintendents Baldwin, are you able to locate it?
Let's see if I can do this.
This happened at the prior hearing as well.
How's that?
There we go. We've got it.
Can you see? Excellent. Thank you.
Your 10 minutes starts now.
All right. Thank you so much. Thank you very much for this opportunity.
President Darling-Hammond, Vice President Glover Woods, Superintendent Thurmond, and members of the board.
I'm going to move pretty quickly through this because we have to share our time.
We're going to move fairly quickly through this.
Let's see this.
There we go.
BCUSD is in full support of the recommendation that comes from both ACCS and CDE.
It also was backed up by the County Office of Education, Solano County Office of Education, and FICMAT.
Basically, it comes down to this, and it's a reading of the law, and it's a very clear reading of the law.
This is a very clear-cut, straightforward analysis.
The BCUSD is under state receivership and is therefore not positioned to absorb the fiscal impact of the proposed charter.
According to the law, 47605C8 and the 181505 that preceded it,
bottom line is that a district in receivership in and of itself satisfies the requirement and the test for determining that it is not in a position to fiscally absorb the impact of proposed charter schools.
At no time and at no level did Caliber successfully rebut the legal presumption set out in this Ed Code.
We are, in fact, in receivership.
We've been in receivership for close to 20 years now.
I won't go through this entire timeline, but you can see that it all began in 2004.
That was five superintendents ago.
We're paying off a $60 million loan.
We're still paying off a $60 million loan.
And we are one of four school districts in the state of California in this situation.
Our receivership only ends when, one, the loan is fully repaid and, two, the county receivership trustee is withdrawn.
And that receivership trustee is only withdrawn at a point after the loan is repaid when it's determined that the district is in a position to be out on its own.
Caliber's, the petitioners brought up a number of contentions.
We were rebutting every one. We rebutted each one that they brought forward.
We did have factual rounds. We were clear from day one that we just saw this as a fiscal impact, a potential fiscal impact, because of our receivership.
That was in our very first staff, our very first staff set of findings.
They have also questioned that, you know, the board is following the law.
The board is able to, as a sovereign school board, make a decision either to either to deny or to approve.
And under the circumstances, they made the decision to deny, but they were fully informed and made the decision that is bequeathed to them.
The other question that's come up is that the board failed to consider Caliber's rebuttal evidence untrue.
They've got a full hearing, you know, through the process.
They actually, their presentation took about twice as much time as mine did to the board on December 15th.
They've had a hearing at every single stage of this process through the county office, through ACCS, and now for you.
And that even though we're under state receivership, we are positioned, their assertion is even under state receivership,
we are still positioned to absorb the fiscal impact.
But the law says that being in receivership in and of itself is a demonstration that you're not in a position to absorb the fiscal impact.
That's in the law. That was in AB 1505.
That's in the language that it came out of Assemblyman Patrick O'Donnell's letters to every entity that's seen us as the author of the AB 1505 law.
There is, you know, there's absolutely no abuse of discretion here.
The fiscal impact finding basically uses three criteria.
This is in 47605C8 and basically allows three things.
That a district that is in qualified status but can demonstrate that it would go into negative status, negative certification, is able to say no.
Or that a district is in negative certification is able to say no.
And by the way, on the first one, from qualified to negative, it has to be certified by the county office and FICMAT.
The third criteria is if the district is in state receivership, period.
And I want to point out that of these three objective standards, because we all know what qualified and negative status is, state receivership is the most clear-cut, the most tangible, the most objective standard.
Because this is not a self-certification of your fiscal status as a district.
This is where, in fact, the district has gone insolvent.
The district has taken up legislation that is carried by a legislator to actually loan the district money to be repaid, has got rid of its superintendent, and has dismantled its board.
Those are the requirements under the law.
So there's nothing here that is subjective at all.
It is clear-cut.
And there's nothing in the law that says, well, your receivership isn't so bad because, you know, we've done calculations, you know, that we think that you're better off than you think you are.
Receivership is the standard.
And the AB 1505 basically set up some new parameters and guardrails for both county offices and the State Board of Education so that this kind of thing could be considered and that districts such as ours in receivership would not take a second trip to receivership because they allowed a charter open that would draw off more finances.
Leslie, do you want to take it from here?
Sure.
You can move the slide, please.
That would be great.
Caliber has asked.
Oh, this one's actually yours.
I'm sorry.
And in point of fact, even though we don't have to demonstrate, you know, the impacts and quantify them, they have been quantified.
We've talked about the pressure that we're under as a district.
Twenty nine million dollars in budget cuts in the last few years.
Closure or consolidation of six school campuses.
Year over year declining enrollment, averaging about four percent.
So we continue to be in distress.
We still don't have to prove that because only the receivership in and of itself provides the test.
But we offered this as a as a counter to what what the petitioners brought forward.
And the petitioner has brought forward their own calculations that still show on their projections that we would lose out on five point seven million dollars over time.
But the law does not say it has to be five point seven or it has to be two or it can only be fifty thousand.
The law says receivership.
Sorry about that.
Not a problem.
All right.
Caliber has asked the Solano County Board of Education, the ACCS and now the SBE to expand the term rebuttable presumption of denial to mean that not withstanding the district's receivership status, it can nevertheless fiscally absorb the charter school.
This is not the legal definition set out in the law and is entirely improper for caliber to ascribe a meaning to this term that does not comport with the express language of the statute.
Caliber has also raised the argument that if the rebuttable presumption does not apply to the district's ability to absorb the fiscal impact of the charter school, this would essentially create an auto denial provision that could be used by any district meeting one of the three criteria.
This is simply not the case.
Section 47605C8 was never intended to create an automatic bar of approval of a petition.
It was specifically designed to give districts and fiscal distress the ability to make a local decision to deny a petition based on fiscal impact.
Next slide.
Despite the contentions raised by caliber throughout this appeals process, one element remains consistent and unwavering.
The district has the full support of the Solano County Board of Education, Assemblymember Patrick O'Donnell, who authored AB 1505, Michael Fine of FICMAT, CDE, and the ACCS.
I know we're limited on time, but we have included some pretty distinct quotes in here that demonstrate how clear cut this matter truly is.
As Michael Fine of FICMAT stated, FICMAT agrees that if the district approved the charter school petition, the district would face an ongoing adverse fiscal impact due to the loss of enrollment.
While the Caliber Public Schools appeals speaks to many points, FICMAT believes there is only one relevant factor appropriate for consideration.
The district remains under state receivership.
Until the loan is fully repaid, the district is not positioned to absorb the fiscal impact of the proposed charter school.
Next slide.
These are also quotes that were raised by two commissioners during the ACCS hearing, and again, due to the time, we'll go ahead and move on to the next slide.
Again, the answer is clear.
The documentary record unequivocally demonstrates that the district remains under receivership and therefore is not positioned to physically absorb the charter school.
The district therefore respectfully requests that the SB stand in solidarity with the district and take action to summarily deny a Caliber High School petition appeal.
Thank you.
At this point, we want to open the phone line, I think, for public comment.
So we need the public comment slide.
If I may, this is Lisa Estrella Henderson, Solano County Superintendent of Schools.
We have Courtney DeGroove, who is also part of the 10 minutes representing the County Board of Education.
Okay, we have one more minute.
Sorry, didn't realize you had more to go.
There are 30 seconds left remaining in the 10 minutes.
If you don't mind, may you make me part of a participant so that I can share my screen?
Thank you.
So my name is Courtney DeGroove, and for the sake of time, I'm just going to go ahead and scroll through our slides very quickly and go to this slide right here.
I just want to note that a lot of discussion has been regarding what the district did or did not do.
And I just want to emphasize that the State Board of Education shall also be considering what the County Board did.
And focusing on the documentary record, the county conducted a comprehensive review of the charter petition.
Thank you.
I apologize for interrupting.
I'm sorry, but time's concluded.
At this point, I think we need to go to public comment.
There are currently eight people in the queue for public comment.
I will open the phone line now.
Good afternoon, State Board of Education.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller ending with the last four digits, 4377, you are live.
Please start your public comment now.
Okay, moving on.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
My name is Rachel Weingarten and I'm a Vallejo parent.
We have a duty to do what's best for our children.
Less than one out of three high school graduates in Vallejo were A to G eligible before the pandemic.
This new charter school is about dramatically increasing the number of kids who come out of Vallejo Public Schools prepared for college and career.
This school will be a life changer for our kids.
Today we're asking you to understand that there's a debate here that deserves a full hearing on Caliber's appeal.
The simple fact that CDE staff relied on two different standards to analyze our case in between the ACSS and this meeting demonstrates that there is enough of a factual dispute here that our case deserves to be heard by you.
Our ask to you today is simple.
Please give us the chance to show that our dream of a caliber high school is possible.
CDE's recommendation has absolutely no analysis in it.
It has a one sentence conclusion that essentially says nothing to see here.
It is a text box and doesn't show how they reached their conclusion.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon President Barley-Hammond and his Dean Board members.
This is Gina Plate on behalf of the California Charter Schools Association.
We are here in support of Caliber High School and respectfully ask, as outlined in our letter submitted on Friday, that you give this school the right to be heard in front of this body.
Caliber is a strong organization that has demonstrated success serving students and families for many years, and we're here because families are demanding a school.
The purpose of this item before you is not to determine whether or not they should have a school.
This item is solely to determine if Caliber should have the right to be heard.
I can say confidently that they deserve the opportunity to have a hearing in front of the state boards and are entitled to that opportunity under AB 1505.
We respectfully ask that you reject the recommendation to summarily deny and instead offer the school and the students and families they represent the opportunity to be heard.
Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Desiree Heminger and I'm a Vallejo parent. Members of the State Board of Education, we know that you do this work because you care for the children of California and I know that you care about my children.
Today we're asking you to vote to hear Caliber's appeal for the children of Vallejo.
Caliber High School program is the option that we need in our city.
As parents, we continue to come to these meetings because we've been told over and over that Caliber High School is a strong program and that it will be successful.
But our children cannot have it. Why? If student learning is the first priority as it must be, why aren't we doing everything we can for our children?
The least we deserve is a full hearing on Caliber's appeal with you to show that there is a real debate here.
Please don't deny us our opportunity to make our full case with you. Our kids are worth it.
All we are asking for is your time. Please give us your time and full consideration. Thank you for allowing me to speak.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
My name is Mary Madrigal. I am a Vallejo High School alumni, public school with the Vallejo School District, and I want better for my children.
Caliber has changed my children's lives. I have a ninth grader who's supposed to go to Caliber High School this year and an eighth grader who can still go next year if you don't overturn these unjust denials.
This morning, President Darlene Hammond discussed the importance of education, the whole child addressing individual learning needs and prioritizing social and emotional health.
I'm telling you, we have this at Caliber. We deserve to have it all the way through to the 12th grade. We deserve high quality and equitable education options in Vallejo.
The analysis of our petition has been mismanaged from the start. Every time we have come to a meeting, the response changes. It went from we don't have the financial analysis or we are in refugership.
We did the financial analysis, but we just can't show you. We still have not seen any of the receipts. At Caliber, my child is asked to do some work.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
The Caliber School is a very important part of our community, of our city, and it offers opportunities for students from Vallejo.
For example, the Flask Football League, which was initiated by Caliber's staff, now has more than 500 participants from the district's schools and from the charters.
The Flask Football League is not only half of the student scholarships. We know that Caliber High School will be one of the strongest schools, but we still do not have specific evidence on why the district cannot offer a charter. Please vote to have a new audience on our petition. Our students deserve an opportunity. Thank you.
Thank you, caller. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
My name is Moana, and I'm an 11th grade student. I graduated from Caliber Changemakers in 2020, and I was on the planning committee that helped design the high school. I wish I had the opportunity to go to a Caliber High School.
I actually attend one of the charter high schools in Vallejo that VCSD is currently trying to close down. In fact, VCSD recently tried to shut down four charter schools that have consistently outperformed them, and I believe they will likely keep trying.
VCSD is trying to deny me access to a quality education at every turn and push me into their troubled high schools. The superintendent repeatedly says that they are not anti-charter, but the record shows otherwise.
I believe that as the state board of education, we should be interested in listening to our appeal. We are real people with our educational features on the line, and we are only asking for your time.
I believe we deserve the benefit of your full time. Your job is to look out for every single student in the state, cutting above politics and addressing wrong decisions of individual school districts, and we're really just asking for you to listen to us. Please vote to hear Caliber High School appeal. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello, it's Eric Premack with the Charter Schools Development Center. We disagree profoundly with CDE's analysis here.
We agree with the legal counsel for Caliber and their analysis of how the statute is actually supposed to work here.
Second, we'll note that while CDE asserts a common definition of receivership, the law actually on state loans never actually uses the term receivership and instead uses county administrator, county trustee, and other terms, not state receivership, and anyone who asserts that this is a state receivership is simply making it up out of thin air.
Third, it's worth noting that the Vallejo district, notwithstanding having a outstanding state loan balance, is actually an extremely strong financial position with an enormous 69 million projected financial reserve at the end of this year, which is 37% of its estimated expenditures for the year.
And while there's more to being fiscally sound than having a massive curve, the fact that the district is in very sound position here, we think that the district is simply slow walking its way.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Michael Juba and I'm a classroom teacher representing the California Teachers Association.
The primary purpose of AB 1505 was to return control of charter school authorizing to local school districts.
Vallejo City Unified School District rightly denied the Caliber petition with the C8 finding and the Solano County Board affirmed this finding in their denial.
Additionally, Solano County staff thoroughly and appropriately analyzed exactly how the establishment of Caliber High School would exacerbate structural deficits for the district using conservative projected enrollment loss.
The district and the county board both acted in accordance with the law in denying the charter position.
We urge the SBE to follow the CDE's recommendation to similarly deny the Caliber appeal. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Christina and I'm a Caliber parent.
Caliber has a track record in our city of being a top performing school and providing positive student and family experiences year after year.
And we deserve to continue that with the Caliber High School.
It is extremely difficult to hear that our existing TK through eighth grade program and our plan for our high school is making the difference.
But we continue to hear no regarding the expansion for reasons beyond our control.
As a parent and a Caliber advocate, we are doing everything that we can to continue to fight for this.
But now we need an opportunity to be heard again.
All California students should have endless opportunities in the safe place to learn and thrive.
They could have this in a Caliber High School.
As a parent to a current and former student of Caliber, I have seen and benefited from all of the deposits made into our family and into my sons.
However, I've also fallen victim to not having enough options in Vallejo to place my older son in a school that shares the same values and practices as Caliber.
Thank you. Your time is up.
That concludes public comment for item number nine.
Thank you very much.
At this point, we're going to go into board discussion.
Board members, remember to raise your Zoom hand if you have a comment or a question.
Panelists, if a board member has a question for you, then you will be recognized and unmuted so that you can respond.
But please do not raise your hand during the board's deliberation because we are in board discussion now.
With that, I'm going to open it up for board discussion.
Member Glover Woods, please share your thoughts.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
I just wanted to provide some initial comments as on one of the liaisons along with Member Okun.
So just wanted to just kind of, again, reemphasize the important decision that's in front of us today, which is to the recommendation with the recommendation is to summarily deny review of the appeal.
I really appreciate hearing the presentation from the petitioners as well as the district and the county and most importantly, the comments that were given during public comment.
What we have in front of us really is a consideration as to if the appeal should be heard due to the fact that we have gotten information that there is an abuse of discretion.
And more importantly, I do want to say the fact that the district is in receivership and the allowances that are in the Ed code is foremost to the front as well.
As we've gotten information that from the district, the county office and from the fiscal crisis management assistance team that the district is unable to absorb the fiscal impact due to their status and receivership.
So I'll actually turn the remaining time over to Member Okun for additional framing comments before we go into discussion and then we'll continue forward. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
First, Vice President Glover Woods for framing where we are and also all of you who presented today and spoken up for public comment.
I just wanted to provide a little bit more context on what happened at ACCS.
And so in in the CD report, we heard that the initial vote at ACCS, which lost three to five, was that we should hear the appeal at the state board.
And that was based on concern that it was being suggested that when a district is in state receivership, there's really no way to rebut the presumption of denial.
We heard that again today, but we also in the CD report, we we heard that they that the charter had not provided sufficient evidence to rebut the presumption that while in state receivership, the district is able to absorb the financial impact.
So I think just the reason I'm saying this is I'm sort of laying out these two pieces is our role today is simply to decide if if we believe that it should if we believe that we should be hearing this appeal.
We the two sides that we're hearing are on the one hand, because the district is one of only four districts in the state under state receivership and there really is no way to rebut the presumption of there's really no way that they can absorb the financial impact.
And on the other hand, we're hearing maybe they can and that's the point of having a hearing is to decide if that's true or not.
Sorry, I got lost my own thoughts there.
But my point is simply that we've heard two different pieces about what the law says.
And actually, it leads me to a question, which is I'm wondering if I'm wondering if we can see the actual text where of the law where it says that it gives the three criteria for districts, being able to have the option to deny based on financial considerations.
And then what the what it says about the ability to rebut that.
And I just like to see because that feels to me like it's at the crux of the conversation today.
Is that something that our team can make available to us at the point where you pulled it up?
We could certainly read it aloud. I have it and others do, but maybe it's on a slide somewhere.
But if not, you could read it aloud.
This is this is Craig, Craig Bickner again, and I've pulled up the slide from Ed code section forty seven six oh five C eight.
So if you'll see the three bullet points, the third one is that it is under state receivership and it mentions a rebuttable presumption of denial.
I just wanted to clarify something while I'm up here very briefly.
The item that we submitted did not have as much clarity or elaboration as we presented in our actual recommendation at ACCS.
We did slightly elaborate, but we did not, in our opinion, did not materially alter our recommendation.
And the exact same recommendation that we presented to ACCS is the same one that we're presenting today.
So I just wanted to kind of clarify that because there seems to be some contrary views on that.
So here is our bullet.
I hope that helps members of the state board to look at the standard.
So there are these three conditions and there's also the fact that charter schools
satisfying one of these conditions shall be subject to a rebuttable presumption of denial.
And I appreciate you giving us the opportunity to see that again.
Remember, Glover Woods, do you have an additional comment you'd like to make?
Your hand is up. I actually, yes, I did put it up again.
I wanted to ask if we could hear from Executive Director Mike Fine from FICMAT in regards to the analysis that FICMAT made that the district was unable to absorb the fiscal impact.
And just to get a little bit more detail as to is it solely because they are in state receivership or were there other things that was looked at?
Good afternoon, Madam Chair and members of the board and Mr. Allen and staff.
Thank you, Dr. Glover Woods for the question.
FICMAT's main role here was to affirm the district status of state receivership.
That seemed to be in part being debated along the way.
There were various parties that even debated whether there were certain phases or certain levels of state receivership.
There is only one you are either in state receivership or you are not.
You do progress through recovery through different phases.
There is no question, and I can provide you evidence as you need it, there's no question that the district is in state receivership.
It does not, while it is nearing the end of its final phase, it does not currently meet the conditions to exit state receivership.
Comments even today about is there state receivership or is it county receivership?
I think they're designed to confuse folks.
When this district became insolvent and the legislature appropriated funds for it, there was only state receivership.
In 2018, long after this district crossed that line, the statute was changed to make the focus of the ongoing corrective action and ongoing monitoring to shift that focus from the state superintendent to the county superintendent.
But as CDE pointed out in their presentation, we use the term receivership to broadly describe this process.
There's not a distinction on whether it's state receivership or county receivership.
ICMAT did not individually do the assessment of their current fiscal condition or their ability to absorb the impact.
That work was actually done by the county superintendent of schools.
They did consult with us as the statute requires, and they worked through that process.
So specific questions about that would be directed to the county superintendent number team.
Our role so far has been purely to define the district statuses in receivership, to consult with the county superintendent, the trustee assigned to the district,
and then in the preparation of our February letter to consult with a variety of policymakers that were involved in 81505 to better understand the intention of the language.
Thank you.
I actually would like to ask, I think it is Courtney DeGroaf, who was about to represent the fiscal analysis of the county, I believe, if she could say a little bit more about that.
Did I understand that that's what you were about to present in that half a minute?
Yes, President Darling, thank you.
Thank you.
So what I was going to indicate is, you know, there's been a lot of talk regarding Vallejo City Unified School District status as state receivership, which the county board did consider, but which is outlined thoroughly in the staff report by the Solano County Office of Education,
and they conducted a comprehensive review of the fiscal impact of the proposed charter school, and that can be found in pages 13 through 17.
Again, the State Board of Education is charged with reviewing whether or not the documentary evidence or record, excuse me, supports a summary denial.
So if you look on pages 13 of 17 of the staff report, you can see there's a comprehensive review of the proposed fiscal impact.
There's some charts in there that demonstrate that there is an estimated impact on the LCFF revenues as a result of enrollment loss, and then also there's another chart that represents the potential impact on Vallejo City Unified School District's multi-year projections for the five-year term.
Of the charter petition, and so county considered that, and then they also did consider the rebuttable presumption, or excuse me, the rebuttable evidence that Caliber did present, and that's also on page 14 of the staff report.
There's a list of the evidence that Caliber presented, and after reviewing that evidence and doing a comprehensive fiscal analysis, the County Board of Education concluded that Caliber had not sufficiently rebutted the presumption of denial and decided to deny the charter petition based on force evidence.
It does exactly what I wanted to clarify, so that the presumption of fiscal impact of being in receivership was not taken as irrebuttable.
It was, in fact, investigated and the evidence on both sides considered, if I understand the process.
Yes, you're correct.
Thank you. Other comments or questions from members of the board?
Yes, Member Olken. You're on mute.
Sorry, I appreciate the information you just shared and that you were about to share when your time got cut off, so thank you for that.
Thank you for that, and I would like to point out that your explanation of the condition for denying sounds quite different than what we heard from the district, in which what we heard was because they are in state receivership, there is no way to rebut.
Nobody's trying to rebut from what I understand that the district is in state receivership, but they wanted to rebut whether the impact could be absorbed or not, and so I appreciate your explanation of the financial implications and actually taking and laying it out.
But I do want to point out that that sounds quite different to me than what we heard from the report from the district, and maybe that has some bearing on
how we would vote on, there are two denials here, and we are in fact voting whether there was an abuse of discretion at either place, at either denial.
And I wonder if perhaps we're seeing that there is a difference between the two.
Excuse me.
Sorry, this is Judy Sias, Chief Counsel for the State Board. We are not voting on abuse of discretion at this time.
This is a summarily denied petition, so abuse of discretion is not an issue. Sorry to interrupt, I just wanted to clarify that, Member Olgen, that this is not. So the question really is whether or not to summarily deny based on the facts that you have been presented here today. Thank you.
Thanks. These are issues that are complicated because we're hearing these questions under 1505 for the first time. It's all confusing, there is no doubt about it.
Yeah, can I ask clarification of that? Just that I know I should put it differently. I know this is complicated, and so hearing it more than one time is helpful probably not just for me, but it is helpful for me. So can you explain the difference between what you were just saying?
So the Education Code provides the board with two options when an appeal is received. One is to summarily deny. That is not defined in Education Code at all. The second is to hear the appeal. And if the board determines to hear the appeal, at that point then they will determine, they can only reverse the decision of the district and the county if there is a determination on abuse of discretion.
Right, thank you. And right, because we at this moment are not making a decision about whether there was an abuse of discretion or not.
Correct. At this point you're making a decision whether or not to summarily deny the appeal. And if you do so, as Craig said, maybe Craig could go to the end slide here. If you make a determination that to summarily deny the appeal, then the district and the county's decision stands.
Make a decision that you want to hear the appeal. It will come back to you at the meeting, November or maybe January meeting, and at that point then you will have a hearing on whether or not there has been an abuse of discretion.
So the facts will be the same at the November and January meeting. It just will be presented a little bit differently I assume.
So what we are deciding is whether we want to hear if there was an abuse of discretion or not.
No.
Okay, so what we're deciding is whether there will be a hearing.
No, you're deciding whether or not to summarily deny the appeal.
Okay, great. Thank you.
Yes, and I want to clarify that the points on the slide, the conclusion, the first point makes the point that Vallejo is under state receivership and satisfies those requirements.
It also addresses the fact that it is a rebuttable presumption in the next bullet, but that the rebuttal has been inadequate from the perspective of the CDE to require a further hearing.
On your initial question of is that presumption rebuttable, what we are being asked to consider accepts the notion that the presumption is rebuttable simply has not been sufficiently rebutted, if that's helpful.
Member Escobedo, I saw your hand go up.
You're on mute.
Unless there's any other discussion, I'm ready for a motion.
I just find the law is quite clear on this.
And if it's okay for me to motion to summarily deny the review, I would love to do that, unless you want to continue with.
We can certainly take that motion. Is there a second?
All right, we've got a second.
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez, I saw your hand go up.
And I just, is there any further discussion?
Member Olken, is your hand up for discussion or is it just still up?
And I'll just note that I think that we are making our way through these issues that the question that arose about is this presumption rebuttable is an important one to affirm that the presumption may be rebuttable.
In this particular case, if we vote to summarily deny, we're not seeing a reason that the analysis was inadequate enough to require an additional hearing.
So with that, Brooks, can you call the roll?
President Garland-Hammond.
Aye.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Aye.
Member Olken.
You're on mute.
No.
Sorry, Member Olken, I couldn't, it wasn't audible?
I think she said no.
Would you mind affirming? Sorry.
We say it three times.
No.
Thank you.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Aye.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Yes.
Member Porter.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
The motion passes.
Thank you and thanks to everybody who came and made comments.
We know that these are really difficult issues and that the parameters for our consideration
are fairly narrow in these cases, but we thank you for the presentations.
They were very much appreciated.
At this point, what I'm going to suggest we do, given the time, is postpone Item 1 to
take action on the preliminary report of the actions draft of July 2022 meeting minutes
and report on our liaison assignments until 8.30 tomorrow morning so that we'll be fresh
and able to concentrate on that.
And then to go ahead and conclude today with the general public comment.
So I'm moving to Item 10, which is the general public comment.
If we can put the public comment slide that's right there.
If you have any comment on items that have not been included in the printed agenda and
want to make a general comment, call the number on the public comment slide.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record and remember to turn down the volume
on your computer if you're following the live feed.
Speakers will be limited to one minute each.
Is there any public comment?
There is no one in the queue for public comment.
All right.
Maybe just give I think we've got a little bit of a data lag in the video.
We'll give a 30 second wait time.
We can all do a little bit of mindfulness.
Take a deep breath.
Okay.
It looks like we do have one caller now.
I will open up the phone line.
I'm glad we waited.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, it's Eric Premack with the Charter Schools Development Center.
I wanted to kind of up Periscope after the prior item and talk about the larger process
here on Charter Appeals.
As many of you know, there was an attempt some months or a little over a year ago
to address many of these unclear terms and processes in the law through a
regulatory process.
That attempt failed and instead what we have now is what I call bureaucrats
making terms up.
And this is a very clear textbook example of establishing law through
underground regulations.
We believe it constitutes a most egregious abuse of the Administrator's
Procedures Act.
And we would urge correcting this process and either re-engaging the effort to
clarify these problems through the regulatory process or through a statutory
process.
We think this is a really serious problem, one that is going to weigh very
heavily on the state board's reputation.
Thank you.
And one that begs being addressed immediately.
That concludes public comments for item 10.
Thank you very much.
It is 5.07.
I hereby conclude today's session.
And please note that we will begin tomorrow at 8.30 a.m.
See you then.
Thank you all.
Thank you.